ATKINS BATES BACKER ORIGINS
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE
DALLY DODD DORADO EGGMAN
GONZALEZ GROVES HERTZBERG HUESO
HURTADO JONES LAYERED LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN WHICH PROVOKED. PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR LAYERED
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR LEYVA. GRACIOUS
GOD OF TRANSFORMATION AND
RENEWAL. AS WE COMPLETE THE
FORMER CELEBRATION OF BLACK
HISTORY MONTH AND TURN TO
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. MAY WE
CONTINUE TO REFLECT ON THE
STORIES THE HERITAGE AND THE
STRUGGLES OF WOMEN THROUGHOUT
THE AGES. MAY WE PAUSE BEFORE
THE SILENCE OF HISTORY. AND
CRAFT NEW WAYS OF INCLUSION FOR
THE ADVANCEMENT OF OUR
CIVILIZATION. HEY WE LET GO OF
OLD ASSUMPTIONS AND LEARN TO
SEE THE PRESENCE AND INFLUENCE
OF WOMEN IN ALL ASPECTS OF
SOCIETY. AS WE LEARN FROM THOSE
WHOSE VOICES HAVE BEEN LEFT ON
HER. MAY WE ACKNOWLEDGE OUR
COMPLICITY IN FAILING TO NOTICE
THE GIFTS TALENTS AND POTENTIAL
IN WOMEN AS WELL AS MEN. MAY
OUR DESIRE FOR INCLUSIVITY AND
DIVERSITY LEAD US TO GREATER
HEALING AND RECONCILIATION AS
WE SEEK LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. A MAN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE. UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA. ONE ISSUE
HUNDRED IN THE. SIX OVERALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
GLAZER LIMON AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WE WELCOME YOU
SENATORS. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR FEBRUARY TWENTY
SECOND THROUGH TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTIONS WILL
BE PLACED ON TODAY'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR ACR ELEVEN AC
ARE FOURTEEN AND AC ARE
EIGHTEEN. CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS WE WILL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER. FIVE IN THE FACE
OF. SENATOR BATES. AM I ON THE
RIGHT OF. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENTE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DANIELS AND BALI BEFORE THE
APPOINTMENT TO THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL HE MOST
RECENTLY SERVED THE GOVERNOR S.
SENIOR ADVISER FOR STRATEGY AND
COMMUNICATIONS HE ALSO SERVED
AS SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT.
SENIOR ADVISER TO THE GOVERNOR
TO GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
CABINET SECRETARY TO GOVERNOR
DAVIS AND CHIEF OF STAFF TO
FIRST LADY MARIA SHRIVER HE WAS
APPROVED IN THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FOUR ON A FIVE DOUBLE VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM SENATOR
HERTZBERG. JUST VERY BRIEFLY OF
AMANAH PRESIDENT I WANT TO
STAND ALSO IN SUPPORT CERTAIN
HAVE VOTED AS A MEMBER OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE BUT- YOU KNOW
MISTERS AND GOLLY. KNOWN FOR
MANY YEARS AND HIS FAMILY FOR
MANY YEARS AND I JUST. YOU KNOW.
WE APPROVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
ONCE IN AWHILE OR SOMEBODY.
WHO'S JUST EXTRAORDINARY IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL PERSON AND HIS- AS
WAS INDICATED BY. SENATOR BATES
IS JUST HIS HIS- RESUME IS
STRONG BUT HIS HEART IS
STRONGER COMPETENCIES
EXTRAORDINARY AND I'VE GOT THE
GREATEST REGARD FOR HIM AND I'M
SO HAPPY HE'S WILLING TO SERVE
AND STAND STRONG SUPPORT. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SINGMAN
THE ROLE PLEASE. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER HI PORGES I BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO HI I. CORTESE. I
DALLY I DODD. HI THE RHIZOME I
EGGMAN. FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
FIVE HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HURTADO. JONES FIVE LAYARD I
LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
I MAN. AYE NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I
A SHOW OF VOGUE I PAN. I
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE ALL
RIGHT HI MY COUNTY. WHITE HOUSE
E. I WIENER I WILK HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HUESO.
HURTADO HI ONE MOMENT. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT. IS AFFIRMED ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATOR BATES. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF MONIQUE FOR
YEAR TWO THOUSAND FRANCISCO BAY
AREA WATER EMERGENCY TRANSIT
AUTHORITY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
MISS MOYER WAS APPROVED IN THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH ON A
FIVE ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER I FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. HI
CORTESE I DALY I DODD. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG. I HUESO.
HURTADO HI JONES FIVE LAYERED I
LEYVA I REQUIRE I MELENDEZ.
FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
HI PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH I RUBIO.
I SKINNER I NUMBER ONE FIVE BY
CAL SKI. I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HUESO. I THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
AFFIRMED ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
JOSEPH HOLLOWAY S. CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
CONSERVATION AND LIQUIDATION
OFFICE T THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE UNDER THE AUTHORITY
OF THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
THE CLO ASSUMES CONTROL OF A
TROUBLED INSURANCE COMPANY AND
OPERATES IT IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE POLICY HOLDERS
UNTIL IT CAN EITHER BE
SUCCESSFULLY REHABILITATED. OR
LIQUIDATED HE WAS APPROVED IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOUR ON A FIVE
OH VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS. YOU'RE SAYING THEN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BAKER. FIVE FORGES I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE. HI DALLY I DODD. I TO
RAZA. I EGGMAN I GONZALEZ. I
GROWTH. I HERTZBERG I HUESO.
HURTADO I JONES I CLEARED I
LEYVA. I REQUIRE HI MELENDEZ HI
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A
CHIRLA VOTE. I PAN I PORTANTINO
BY ROSS. I RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
I'M BURKE I LIKE HOUSEKI HI
WIENER I WILK. HI. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. SENATORS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING ITEM NUMBER CAN.
SENATOR PENN ARE YOU PREPARED
HE IS PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TEN BY SENATOR PAN
RELATIVE TO JAPANESE AMERICAN
CONCENTRATION CAMPS CENTER PAN
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM RESIDENT SENATORS TODAY
I RISE AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS 2% S. R. TEN RESOLUTION
TO COMMEMORATE THE SEVENTY
NINTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE. ON FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO
PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT SIGNED
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY SIXTY
SIX UNDER HICH MORE THAN A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE INCARCERATED TEN DIFFERENT
CAMPS SCATTERED THROUGHOUT THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. JAPANESE
AMERICANS WERE TARGETED
STRIPPED OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
AND IMPRISONED SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF THEIR HERITAGE. SEVENTY NINE
YEARS LATER WE'RE STILL
REMEMBERING THIS PAINFUL
HISTORY AND REFLECTING ON THESE
UNJUST POLICIES ROOTED FROM
DISCRIMINATION SYSTEMIC RACISM
AND XENOPHOBIA. AS WE ARE
FORTUNATE WITNESSING A LARGE
UPTICK IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST
ASIAN AMERICANS STUDER OF
RACIST RHETORIC ABOUT THE COVE
IT PANDEMIC. IN THE LAST MONTH
THE BAY AREA HAS PARTICULARLY
SEEN MORE MORE ATTACKS DIRECTED
TOWARDS SENIORS FACT ONE EIGHTY
FOUR YEAR OLD MAN OF THAI
DESCENT WAS PUSHED TO HIS
DEATH. IN A NUMBER OF THE
ATTACK. EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY
SIXTY SIX IS A STARK REMINDER
THAT WE MUST ACT WITH
DETERMINATION TO NEVER REPEAT.
THE SAME BETRAYAL OF OUR VALUES
AS A NATION AND TO PROTECT THE
CIVIL RIGHTS AND LIBERTIES OF.
ALL AMERICANS. I ASK YOU TO
JOIN ME IN REMEMBERING THE
ISSUANCE OF EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINETY SIXTY SIX. I CONTINUE TO
SEEK OUT ITS LESSONS. BY
ADOPTING S. R. TEN HIRE DRIVERS
THANK YOU. SENATOR MEN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MORE GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO
FOR INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION.
AS A MEMBER OF THE EIGHTY AYE
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I WANT TO
REITERATE SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUES IN
SACRAMENTO JUST MADE. IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
PREVIOUS HARDSHIP THAT ARE
ASIAN AMERICAN ANCESTORS HAVE
SUFFERED SO THAT THIS TYPE OF
INCIDENT NEVER HAPPENS TODAY.
WITHOUT THESE PREVIOUS
SACRIFICES PEOPLE LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO NINE
WOULD NOT BE SERVING IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE TODAY-
ROUGHLY THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
JAPANESE VETERANS FOUGHT
BRAVELY FOR A COUNTRY DURING
WAR TO. IF THEIR FAMILIES WERE
INCARCERATED BEHIND BARBED WIRE
YOU TO FDR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
NINETY SIXTY SIX SOMETHING THAT
WILL GO DOWN IN HISTORY. AS ONE
OF THE WORST ACTIONS THAT HIS
PRESIDENCY. NOW WE KNOW THAT
THE SCAPEGOATING OF ASIAN
AMERICANS GOES ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE VERY FIRST DAYS OF ASIAN
IMMIGRATION TO THIS COUNTRY.
WHETHER THE YELLOW PERIL
RHETORIC WHETHER THE CHINESE
EXCLUSION ACT WEATHER IS THE
JAPANESE INTERNMENT CAMP- SO
MANY OTHERS WE CANNOT KEEP
REPEATING HISTORY IN THIS WAY.
AND YET WE RUN THAT RISK UNLESS
WE LEARN OUR HISTORY. WE LIKE
TO SAY THESE TYPES OF THINGS
NEVER WILL HAPPEN AGAIN BUT
THEY WILL UNLESS WE KEEP
REMINDING OURSELVES. AND OUR
NEXT GENERATIONS OF HISTORY. AS
I NOTED WITH THE API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY NOT JUST WITH OTHER
API'S BUT WITH OTHER
HISTORICALLY MARGINALIZED
GROUPS IS SO IMPORTANT. AND I
ASK YOU ALL TO STAND WITH US
TODAY IN SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MANAGER.
CENTER ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE A SHARE
THE MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
TEN WHICH DECLARES FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH IS A DAY OF
REMEMBRANCE REGARDING THE
EVENTS SURROUNDING THE
INCARCERATION OF AMERICANS OF
JACK JAPANESE ANCESTRY DURING
WORLD WAR TWO. IN PARTICULAR AS
A FELLOW VETERAN I WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THE FOUR FORTY
SECOND INFANTRY REGIMENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ARMY. NO TO ALL
OF US AS THE FOUR FOUR TWO THE
FIGHTING FOUR FOUR TWO. THE
FOUR FOUR TWO IS AN EFFORT TO
REGIMENT. WHO SERVED DURING
WORLD WAR TWO WITH HONOR AND
DIGNITY BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY.
THE FOUR FORTY SECOND IS BEST
KNOWN FOR ITS HISTORY AS A
FIGHTING UNIT. COMPOSED OF
ALMOST ENTIRELY SECOND
GENERATION AMERICAN SOLDIERS OF
JAPANESE JAPANESE ANCESTRY WHO
ENLISTED. IN THE WAR. IN SPITE
OF THE INCARCERATION THAT WAS
HAPPENING BACK HOME WITH HER
FELLOW FAMILY MEMBERS WERE
KARCHER RATED. THE FOUR FORTY
SECOND BRAVELY FOUGHT IN THE
EUROPEAN THEATER IT WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. IN THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY WE HONOR THEM EVERY
SINGLE DAY. IN FACT. THE GO FOR
BROKE MONUMENT IN LITTLE TOKYO
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES NEAR MY
DISTRICT. IN THE DISTRICT OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO MY RIGHT. AND I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT IT
COMMEMORATES THE JAPANESE
AMERICANS WHO SERVED THE UNITED
STATES ARMY DURING MORE WORK TO.
THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT HISTORY
NOT JUST FOR CALIFORNIA BUT THE
ENTIRE WORLD. FOR THESE REASONS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S. R. TEN
AND THANK YOU AUTHOR FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR BRINGING IT FOR
TODAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
TEN RECOGNIZING FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE TO
INCREASE THE PUBLIC AWARENESS
OF THE EVENTS SURROUNDING THE
INCARCERATION OF AMERICANS OF
JAPANESE ANCESTRY. DURING WORLD
WAR TWO. FEBRUARY NINETEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MARKED THE
SEVENTY NINTH ANNIVERSARY THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT AUTHORIZED
JAPANESE AMERICAN INTERNMENT
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. THIS
POLICY WAS A GRAVE INJUSTICE
AGAINST AMERICAN CITIZENS AND
RESIDENTS OF JAPANESE ANCESTRY
PRESIDENT GERALD FORD ISSUED A
PROCLAMATION WHICH TERMINATED
THIS POLICY AND IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT PRESIDENT RONALD
REAGAN SIGNED THE FEDERAL CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT INTO LAW. WHICH
DECLARED THAT THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER AUTHORIZING THE
INTERNMENT OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS WAS NOT JUSTIFIED DAY
MILITARY NECESSITY. THE CIVIL
LIBERTIES ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT HAD THREE CO
SPONSORS INCLUDING THEN SENATOR
PETE WILSON WHO LATER BECAME
THE THIRTY SIX GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT STATED THAT
THE GOVERNMENT ACTIONS DURING
WORLD WAR TWO HAS BEEN BASED ON
QUOTE RACE PREJUDICE WAR
HYSTERIA AND A FAILURE OF
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP IN QUOTE
AS APPROVED AS OPPOSED TO
LEGITIMATE SECURITY REASONS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ISSUED A FORMAL APOLOGY TO
SURVIVORS WHO EXPERIENCED THE
DARKEST DAYS OF AMERICAN
HISTORY. SO TODAY WE GET MARK
THIS DAY OF REMEMBRANCE FOR
THOSE COUNTLESS AMERICAN
FAMILIES OF JAPANESE DESCENT
WHO ENTERS SUFFERING. OR OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO DID SUFFER.
AND IT'S GREAT THAT WE HAVE
THESE GOVERNMENT RESOLUTIONS
BUT IT TAKES MORE THAN THAT IT
TAKES. IT TAKES FAMILIES- AS A
YOUNG BOY I REMEMBER MY PARENTS
TAKING ME MY SISTER TO THE
MANZANAR INTERNMENT CAMP OFF
HIGHWAY THREE NINETY FIVE IN
INYO COUNTY. AND A GENERATION
LATER I TOOK MY CHILDREN
BECAUSE WE CAN NEVER FORGET
THESE TYPE ACCESS BECAUSE WE
DON'T HISTORY WILL REPEAT
ITSELF AGAIN. SO AGAIN I
PROBABLY STAND- WITH MY FRIEND
FROM SACRAMENTO AS AN AYE VOTE
FOR SR TEN. SENATOR BAKER. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION DECLARING FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH A DAY OF REMEMBRANCE
BUT MY COLLEAGUE WHO JUST SPOKE
I TOOK MY FAMILY LAST SUMMER TO
THE MINDS IN OUR CAMP HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS WERE IN TURN THERE IT
WAS A STARK REMINDER OF THIS
INJUSTICE AND GLAD WE HAVE THIS
RESOLUTION TO REMEMBER THIS. IS
MY CALLING IRVINE SAID. IF WE
DON'T REMEMBER THE HISTORY. WE
ARE DOOMED TO REPEAT IT AND WE
HEARD RECENTLY ALSO WAS
REFERENCED THE RECENT TAX-
ASSAULTS AND BATTERIES INSULTS
AGAINST MEMBERS OF OUR ASIAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY I WAS AT A
RALLY THIS WEEKEND BUT WE STOOD
UP FOR ASIANS IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND I'M PROUD TO STAND SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION TODAY. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DRAWS A. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. TEN IN
REMEMBRANCE OF THEIR
INCARCERATION OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS. AND ALSO BECAUSE-
SIMILAR ATTACKS HAVE BEEN WAGED
AGAINST OTHER GROUPS IN THIS
COUNTRY. IN THE NINETEEN
FORTIES THE SUIT. SUITORS WERE
ATTACKED IN LOS ANGELES WHERE
THOUSANDS WERE BEATEN UP THIS
IS AT THE SAME TIME BUT THE
SAME KIND OF RACIAL ATTACKS
WERE TAKING PLACE IN MOBILE
ALABAMA BEAUMONT TEXAS DETROIT
AND NEW YORK CITY. THEN THERE
WAS OPERATION LEAD BACK IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES. WHEN THEY
WERE MILITARY STYLE TACTICS
WERE USED TO DEPORT THOUSANDS
INCLUDING MEXICAN AMERICAN
CITIZENS. COLLEAGUES WHAT
MATTERS IS WHAT WE DO BOTH
INDIVIDUALLY. AS A LEGISLATURE
AND AS A SOCIETY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR BRADFORD.
PRESIDENT AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT ABOUT
SARGSYAN TO REFLECT ON THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN OF JAPANESE
HERITAGE THAT WERE INTERNED IN
THIS COUNTRY DURING WORLD WAR
TWO AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO GREW
UP IN GUARDINO WHICH WAS
APPROVED FOR DONNELLY JAPANESE
COMMUNITY IN THE SIXTIES AND
SEVENTIES WHEN I WAS A KID I
HAVE PLENTY OF FRIENDS WHO HAD.
IT'S AND GRANDPARENTS WHO WERE
IN TURN NOT ONLY MANZANAR BUT
IN TULE LAKE TOO. MANY OF THEM
REFERRED TO AS NO ONE ELSE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO REFUSE TO
SIGN A DECLARATION DECLARING
THEIR LOYALTY. TO THE UNITED
STATES EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE
BUT DENOUNCING THEIR JAPANESE
HERITAGE WHICH THEY REFUSED TO
DO. AND MANY AT TULE LAKE LAKE
WORKFORCE IN THE HEART. OF
WINTER THE STANDING IN THE COLD
AND SNOW IN THEIR UNDERWEAR AND
BE TORTURED REPEATEDLY TO GET
THEM TO SIGN A FORM WHICH THEY
REFUSED TO DO. YET AND STILL
MANY OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS ONE
OFF THE FIGHT. AS STATED IN
pWORLD WAR TWO. KNOWN AS THE
FOUR FOUR TWO THE GOAL FOR
BRINGING. SOME OF THE BRAVEST
MEN IN WORLD TWO WHO FOUGHT
FOR THIS COUNTRY DESPITE HAVING
MANY OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS.
INTERNED HERE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND AS A MEMBER WHO'S BEEN
APPOINTED TO THE REPARATIONS
COMMITTEE. LOOKING AT THAT
WHICH WAS STOLEN FROM AFTER
AMERICANS WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK
AT WHAT WAS STOLEN FROM
JAPANESE AMERICANS BECAUSE OF
WE KNOW OUR HISTORY WE KNOW
BACK WHICH IS NOW PALACE
BIRDIES. WHICH PRIMARILY
JAPANESE FARMLAND IN THE EARLY
FORTIES IN VERY LITTLE OF THAT
WAS EVER RETURNED TO THEM AFTER
THEY RETURNED HOME. BUT THERE
WAS A SECTION THAT DID BELONG
TO THEM THAT WAS RETURNED AFTER
WORLD WAR TWO. AND I WAS LITTLE
TOKYO AND DOWN TO LOS ANGELES
AND THE REASON IT WAS RETURNED
TO ON BECAUSE IT WAS PROTECTED
BY. THE AMERICANS. AND THAT WAS
CAUGHT BROWNSVILLE BECAUSE
AFRICAN AMERICANS MOVED INTO
THOSE COMMUNITIES MOVED INTO
THOSE HOMES. MOVED INTO THOSE
BUSINESSES AND PROTECTED THOSE
BUSINESSES MAINTAIN THOSE
BUSINESSES AND HOMES AND RETURN
DON'T WITHOUT FUSS NOR MONTHS.
UPON THOSE INDIVIDUALS BEING
RETURNED SO IT'S BEEN A LONG
ALLIANCE BETWEEN. JAPANESE
AMERICANS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
MY GRANDPARENTS LIVED AND TOKYO
IN JAPAN FOR NUMBER OF YEARS
AND MY GRANDMOTHER WAS FLUENT
IN JAPANESE AND SHE INSTILLED
IN ME AT EARLY AGE. THE LOCAL
STRONG TIES. AND CULTURAL-
AWARENESS OF JAPANESE ARE I
STAND STRONG TO OF US
UNDERSTANDING THE HISTORY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY NEVER
FORGETTING IT THANK YOU.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ESTARá TEN AS-
SENATOR REPRESENTING A LARGE-
AREA OF API COMMUNITY I REALLY
WANT TO OFFER MY SUPPORT AS
WELL I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT WE ALWAYS
REMEMBER OUR HISTORY AND REALLY
RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE AGREE
JUST MISTAKES WE'VE DONE AND
MADE ON BEHALF OF FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND SO I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE AS OUR
GREAT SENATOR FOR MOLLY SHARED-
MAKE. AMERICANS DEALT WITH A
LOT OF INJUSTICES IN THAT ERA
OUR FRIEND FROM GUARDINO JUST
STATE IT. OUR FRIENDS AFRICAN
AMERICAN FRIENDS HAVE DEALT
WITH SUCH INJUSTICES AND I
THINK IT'S TIME WE STAND
TOGETHER IN SOLIDARITY AND
OFFER ARC. FOR THIS COUNTRY AND
THEY WERE TREATED SO UNFAIRLY
AND THEIR FAMILIES WERE TREATED
SO UNJUSTLY I DO HAVE-
INTERNMENT CAMP. THAT WAS IN MY
DISTRICT AND SO THAT'S ALWAYS A
REMINDER FOR ME. TO ALWAYS
REMEMBER NEVER REPEAT THOSE
MISTAKES AND COLLECTIVELY I
THINK WE NEED TO SAY THANK YOU
TO JAPANESE AMERICANS. FOR
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE DONE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO THIS COUNTRY
THANK YOU. SENATOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE L. G.
CAUCUS BUT TO ALSO SPEAK ON
THAT S. R. TEN- WE ARE OLD
MEANING MAKING CREATURES WHO
FULL FORM OUR LIVES AROUND
STORIES OF OUR LIVES WHEN I WAS
A SOCIAL WORKER DOING HOSPICE
WORK- IN THE IN THE STOCK
INTERLOCUTOR THERE'S A LOT OF
JAPANESE FAMILIES WHO HAD
SETTLED THERE AND- AND SPENT
TIME IN CAMPS AND I WAS ALWAYS
AMAZED WHEN I WOULD GO INTO A
JAPANESE HOME. AND THE PICTURE
OF THE CAMPS WOULD BE CENTERED
UP ON THE WALL AND THAT WAS
PART OF THE TOUR OF THE HOUSE
IT WOULD TAKE ME TO SEE THE
PICTURE OF THE CAMPS. AND WOOD
NO BETTER. BUT WITH THE WITH
THE THIS IS A PART OF OUR LIFE.
THAT WE WANT TO SHARE AND THEN
THE STRENGTH THE FAMILY. STILL
TOGETHER THEN TOWARD THE END OF
SOMEONE'S LIFE. CARING FOR
SOMEONE. WHEN I WAS IN. IN IN
IN COLLEGE IT WAS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE AIDS EPIDEMIC
AND I REMEMBER DISTINCTLY. IN
COLLEGE CLASSES IS PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT INTERNMENT CAMPS.
PLACES THAT WE WOULD PUT PEOPLE
TO KEEP US SAFE WHICH IS THE
SAME THING WE DID. DURING THE
WAR WE PUT JAPANESE PEOPLE
AWAY. TO KEEP US SAFE BECAUSE
WE ARE AFRAID. I THINK WE NEED
TO PUSH BACK THEN WE CERTAINLY
SHOULD HAVE PUSHED BACK ON THE
HIV AIDS CRISIS AND WE DID- BUT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO BE
VIGILANT TO THESE KIND OF
THINGS THESE ARE MESSAGES WE
DON'T WANT ANYBODY ELSE. WITH
PICTURES OF CAMPS ON THEIR ON
THEIR LIVING ROOM WALLS. THAT
THEY ORGANIZE A STORY OF THEIR
LIVES AROUND THAT WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO HAVE TO BE. THAT
RESILIENT TO RISE ABOVE. THE
HATRED OF YOUR VERY COUNTRY. WE
DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT LGBT
PEOPLE IN THE CAMPS DURING THAT
TIME WE DO KNOW ABOUT. JIRO A
NEW MONTH. BECAUSE YOU CAN
IMAGINE TO BE IN A CLOSET IN A
CAMP WAS REALLY DIFFICULT. SO
WE CAN JUST IMAGINE THE KIND
THE COMPOUNDING. OF OPPRESSION
THAT IT CAN OCCUR AT THIS TIME
SO. I RISE ON BEHALF OF S. R.
TEN AND ASKED US ALL TO STAND
IN SOLIDARITY THAT WE WILL
NEVER FORGET AND WE WILL NEVER
REPEAT THE MISTAKES. OF THE
PAST THANK YOU MEMBERS. SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I FIRST OF ALL I THINK ALL OF
MY- COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS R. TEN AND- FOR
THE DAY OF REMEMBRANCE-
REMEMBERING HIS CERTAINLY- VERY
IMPORTANT BUT NINE US AND WE
ALSO NEED TO RESOLVE TO NOT
ALLOW THESE THINGS TO HAPPEN
AGAIN WE CANNOT. CHANGE HISTORY.
BUT WE CAN CHANGE THE FUTURE.
WHAT THAT HIRED AN AYE VOTE ON
S. R. TEN THANK YOU. MEMBERS IF
THERE IS NO OBJECTION THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION I
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE THE- RESOLUTION PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SENATOR
ATKINS. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SEVEN BY
SENATOR ATKINS AN ACTUAL
RELATING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY AND OCCURRING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MADAM PRETEND THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN WHICH EXTENDS
A SUNSET OF EXISTING CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT OR
SEEK WHAT STREAMLINING
PROVISIONS. AND ENABLE SMALL
SCALE HOUSING PROJECTS TO
BENEFIT FROM THE STREAMLINING
AS WELL. IT'S BEEN A YEAR SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC
AND WHILE WE HAVE MANY
IMPORTANT ISSUES TO TACKLE
DIRECTLY RELATED TO MITIGATING
THE EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
CANNOT LOSE FOCUS ON OTHER
EQUALLY IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUES
SUCH AS HOUSING PRODUCTION. I
MADE A PLEDGE ON THIS FLOOR
WELL OVER A YEAR AGO THAT THE
SENATE WILL FOCUS ON HOUSING
PRODUCTION. WE MADE GOOD ON
THAT PLEDGE AND WE PUT FORTH A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF BILLS
TO INCENTIVIZE AN INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION AND OUR
STATE. WELL WE WERE NOT
COMPLETELY SUCCESSFUL AND
GETTING THESE BILLS ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE WE WERE CLOSE. BY
ALONG WITH A GROUP OF LEAD
SENATORS ON HOUSING. SENATORS
MCGUIRE CABALLERO DRAW SO
GONZALEZ ROTH RUBIO CORTESE AND
SKINNER. WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT
ON THESE BILLS. TO MAKE THEM
LAW AND I PARTICULARLY WANT TO
EXTEND MY APPRECIATION. TO
SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR- PRESENTING
THIS BILL IN- EQ COMMITTEE AND
APPROPRIATIONS. BUT OUR WORK
CONTINUES AND S. B. SEVEN AS
PART OF THE WORK DONE ON THE
HOUSING PRODUCTION PACKAGE OF
BILLS TO ADDRESS THE CRITICAL
NEED FOR HOUSING SUPPLY. IN OUR
STATE. IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AB NINE HUNDRED
WHICH IS STABILISED A NEW
PROCESS UNDER SECRETIVE
STREAMLINED ADMINISTRATIVE
RECORD PAPERWORK. AN EXPEDITED
LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR LARGE
MULTI BENEFIT HOUSING. CLEAN
ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
PROJECTS THAT HAVE A CAPITAL
INVESTMENT OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. AB NINE
HUNDRED SUNSET ON JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I HAD A BILL
LAST YEAR TO EXTEND THE SUNSET
AND THE BILL PASSED BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY WITH
LARGE MAJORITY VOTES. BUT WAS
UNABLE TO GET TO THE SENATE
FLOOR LAST YEAR DUE TO THE END
OF SESSION TIME CONSTRAINTS. SB
SEVEN EXTENDS AB NINE HUNDRED
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
EXPANDED SO THAT IT WOULD APPLY
TO MUCH SMALLER HOUSING
PROJECTS AND THIS IS SO THAT
ALL PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. HAVE
ACCESS TO THE BENEFITS OF THIS
TOOL NOT JUST LARGE CITIES BUT
RULE COMMUNITIES ALSO. WERE
CURRENT AB NINE HUNDRED LAW NOW
SAYS IT ONLY- BUT THAT ONLY
PROJECTS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
OR GREATER OR ELIGIBLE SB SEVEN
LOWERS THAT THRESHOLD TO
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
SMALLER HOUSING PROJECTS
QUALIFY. LIKEWISE THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE HOUSING
PROJECTS AVE AT LEAST 50%
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE REQUIRED IN STATE
LAW. AND TO DATE AB NINE
HUNDRED HAS RESULTED IN AT
LEAST FOURTEEN SEPARATE MEGA
PROJECTS REPRESENTING OVER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OF INVESTMENTS
IN OUR STATE. ACCORDING TO
INFORMATION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH AND
THE SENATE OFFICE OF RESEARCH
THESE PROJECTS HAVE PROVIDED
OVER TEN THOUSAND NEW HOUSING
UNITS. AND CREATED THOUSANDS OF
NEW HIGH WAGE CONSTRUCTION AND
PERMANENT JOBS. SINCE THE AB
NINE HUNDRED PROGRAM SUNSET ON
JANUARY FIRST WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE EXISTING
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ALREADY IN
THE PIPELINE FOR APPROVAL DO
NOT HAVE TO BEGIN THAT APPROVAL
PROCESS AGAIN. SB SEVEN IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN GENERATING
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN THE STATE
AS WELL AS ENSURING COMMUNITIES
LARGE AND SMALL. BENEFIT FROM
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
GENERATING QUALITY HIGH PAYING
JOBS. BY USING PROPERLY SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKERS. SB SEVEN
IS A KEY PART IN FULFILLING
THIS PLEDGE TO SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION CALIFORNIA IT'S
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR BURGESS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. I WANT TO
INTRODUCING THIS MATTER- I
THINK WE KNOW. OUR HOUSING
SHORTAGES ARE NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY- AND THE THICKENING OF
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY SON
TELEVISION PROGRAM RECENTLY
THAT. HELP EXPLAIN THIS
CONCEPT- AND IT MADE A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME. IS THAT WE HAVE
CREATED A NUMBER OF SYSTEMS IN
GOVERNMENT WHETHER THEY BE
CHECKS AND BALANCES ARE
OVERSIGHTS. FOR JUST YOUR
CREDIT PROCESS SEES THAT
ENCUMBER INCREASE CHALLENGES
FOR US TO DEAL WITH ARM MOST
IMMEDIATE NEEDS. NOWHERE IS
THIS MORE SIGNIFICANT AND
GLARING AS A SEQUEL. NOW I HAVE
INTRODUCED BILLS- MY FIRST YEAR
REGARDING C. ESPECIALLY TO PLAY
INSTEAD TO HOUSING AND
STREAMLINING. BUT I GOTTA SAY
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE. WE'RE
DEALING WITH- THE PANDEMIC AND
IT WILL NO DOUBT. TAKE ALL OF
THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE. I AM
HOPEFUL THAT WE HAVE THE
COURAGE. TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
ON ITS MERITS IN THE YEAR
TWENTY TWO. BECAUSE I SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
TODAY. BUT THE FACT THAT WE ARE
STREAMLINING SEQUEL FOR
PRIORITY PROJECTS UNDERLIES THE
FACT THAT SEQUEL IS NOT WORKING
THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED. AND I
THINK IT WE HAD OF THE BODY WE
HAVE TO HAVE THE COURAGE TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE. DESPITE THE
SPECIAL INTERESTS IN THE
PREVAILING POLITICAL WINDS OF
THE TIME. WE CAN'T SIMPLY
SIDELINED SPECIAL PROJECTS AND
CERTAIN NEEDS- TO DIVERT AROUND
THIS CUMBERSOME PROCESS WHICH
CLEARLY IS NOT DELIVERING WHAT
WE NEED. ALL WITH THAT I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BECAUSE IT
IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE MOVE
FORWARD ON THESE THINGS. BUT
IT'S EVEN MORE ESSENTIAL- THAT
WE SOLVE OUR LONG TERM PROBLEMS
OF HOUSING IN SICK WHAT NEEDS
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
THAT DISCUSSION. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE I STAND
AS A PRODUCT- ALTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. I LIKE
TO THINK THE PRO TEM FIRST
READING THE EFFORTS AND GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE AT THE
TABLE TO HELP. CRAFT THIS BILL
ALONG WITH OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES
WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
BY THE PRO TEM. MEMBERS
FAMILIES CONTINUE TO LOSE THEIR
HOMES THEY CONTINUE TO CALL
KREIN. URGING US TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF THEM ON THE
BRINK OF BEING HOMELESS. AND SO
HOMES ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AND THIS TIME BECAUSE THEY ARE
BECOMING UNAFFORDABLE FOR
EVERYDAY AMERICANS AND EVERY
DAY CALIFORNIANS WHICH IS WHY
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT AND SO
TIMELY. THIS BILL IS ALSO A JOB
CREATOR AND AS WE KNOW PREVENT
NINETEEN HAS THREATENED TO
FAMILIES ECONOMIC STABILITY.
AND THIS BILL DOES BOTH IT
CREATES GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
HELPS BUILD HOMES FASTER AND IT
ALSO HELPS STRUGGLING
CALIFORNIANS TO PUT THEM ON THE
PATH OF HOME OWNERSHIP. WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I MET WITH
MANY STAKEHOLDERS IN MY OWN
DISTRICT I MET WITH MY CITIES
MY CITY MANAGERS EVEN THE L. A.
COUNTY DELEGATION AND THE
CONSENSUS IS CLEAR WE NEED.
MORE HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE
SO I ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU. SENATOR CORTESE.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT TO ARISE IS
A PROUD CO AUTHORED SB SEVEN
WHICH HAS ALREADY STATED- COME.
BY MADAME PRO TEM AND THANK YOU
FOR HER LEADERSHIP EXTENDS
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SINCE IT
ENACTED IN TWENTY ELEVEN BY AB
NINE HUNDRED- I'M SPEAKING
BECAUSE THE SENATE BILL- WILL
CONTINUE AB NINE HUNDRED
SUCCESS IN CREATING JOBS AND
INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA BY
STREAMLINING PAPERWORK. AND
EXPEDITING LEGAL CHALLENGES TO
LARGE MULTI BENEFIT HOUSING
ENERGY MANUFACTURING PROJECTS.
IN MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO ONE
OF THE BUSIEST TRANSIT HUBS ON
THE WEST COAST. DURRETT ON
STATION IN THE DEER DOWN
STATION REDEVELOPMENT AREA THIS
BILL WOULD LEAD TO A TREMENDOUS
INFUSION OF JOBS INCLUDING
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED
CONSTRUCTION JOBS. IN THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE IMMEDIATELY
ADJACENT TO THE DIRT ON
STATION. WOULD ALSO LEAD TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF FOUR THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS IN THAT AREA 25%
OF WHICH WILL BE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- THAT PROJECT ALONE
WILL BE TRANSFORMATIVE NOT ONLY
PERSONAL SAY. A BURKE PERCENT
OCCUR COUNTY AND OF COURSE A
HUGE CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TERMS A HOUSING
PRODUCTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN AND APPLIED THE PRO
TENS EFFORTS TO PROTEINS
EFFORTS IN ELIMINATING SOME OF
THE BARRIERS REYES BY SEQUEL
LITIGATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW BY STREAMLINING SEQUEL
LITIGATION. THEY WILL ALLOW
THESE PROJECTS TO BEGIN SOONER
IT WILL ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
OVERLY EXPENSIVE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH SEQUINS REVIEW
PROCESS SAVING THE STATE TIME
AND MONEY. AND WHILE WE'E
DOING THIS TODAY AND IT'S A
GOOD STEP WE AS A LEGISLATIVE
BODY NEED TO DO MORE WE NEED TO
BRING MORE PRODUCT TO MARKET
FOR OUR FAMILIES. RECENTLY MY
WIFE AN ASSET AND I. HAD TO
WAVE GOODBYE IS MY DAUGHTER.
THAT SON IN LAW AND ONLY
GRANDSON MOVED OUT OF STATE
BECAUSE THEY COULD NO LONGER
AFFORD TO LIVE HERE. THEY HAD A
MARGINAL TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT.
THAT WAS MORE THAN THE MORTGAGE
THAT MY WIFE AND I PAY SO WE
HAVE TO DO MORE. AND THEN
FINALLY SB SEVEN WILL ENABLE
THESE DEVELOPMENTAL PROJECTS TO
CREATE MORTGAGE PAYING JOBS
SOMETHING. THE STATE
DESPERATELY NEEDS IN THE TIME
OF AT 9% UNEMPLOYMENT. HAS THE
SENATE REPUBLICAN LEADER I'M
GLAD TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE. TO SUPPORT
THE CREATION OF MORE HOUSING
AND BETTER PAYING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO ADD TO WHAT EVERY UP
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE SAYING
IN A GREAT SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
HUNDRED THANK THE PRO TEM FOR
TAKING THE LEADERSHIP IN MOVING
IN OUR WORKING GROUP FORWARD TO
COME UP WITH- THE LEGISLATION
THAT NOT ONLY IS GOING TO
ADDRESS HOUSING IN GENERAL
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN GENERAL
BUT THAT GIVES SPECIFIC
IMPORTANCE TO THE CREATION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO- HAVING
BEEN INVOLVED- YEARS AGO WITH
AB NINE HUNDRED. I WAS VERY
GLAD TO SEE THE CREATIVITY OF
THE PRO TEM IN TAKING THAT AND
TURN IT INTO SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO HELP ON THE HOUSING
FRONT SO I. URGE SUPPORT.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MADAM PRO TEN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CONCLUDE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ONLY TWO
POINTS- WILL THREE I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO'VE
SPOKEN I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- AND YOU'RE A
TENACIOUS NOUS ALONG WITH ME AS
WE TRY TO GET THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ACROSS. THE FINISH
LINE AND FINALLY I THINK IT'S
SO IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY NOW TO
POINT OUT HOW IMPORTANT WAS
THAT WE MAKE SURE THIS TOOL IS
AVAILABLE FOR ALL PARTS OF OUR
STATE NOT JUST THE LARGE
METROPOLITAN AREAS LIKE THE
CITY THAT I REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES OR SAN FRANCISCO ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE SO THEY CAN
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY FOR ECONOMIC
ADVANCEMENT. FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES GOOD PAYING JOBS AS
WELL AS MUCH NEEDED SUPPLIES
HOUSING I URGE A NO VOTE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES I BAKER I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO FIVE
CORTESE HI DOLLY I DODD. I
DORADO I EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HUESO. HI
HER TADO HI JONES I LAYERED I
LEYVA FIVE REQUIRE. HI MELENDEZ.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN. I NIELSEN FIVE
CONTROL OF BOTH. I PAN HI
PORTANTINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE HI WHAT
KASKY HI WIENER AYE WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
SO FAR. THIRTY FOUR ON THE
URGENCY SIX ZERO ON A THIRTY
FOUR AYES ZERO NO THIRTY FOUR
ON THE MEASURE. NOES ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. THERE ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THIS
CALENDAR. SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ELEVEN
FOURTEEN AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AN ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BECKER. I FOR JUST I
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY I DODD. HI THE
RAZA I EGGMAN HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES. I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA I MCGUIRE. FIVE
MELENDEZ. I MEN HI NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN I- CHILLAGOE. I PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. I AM BURKE HI I BY CAL
SKI HI WIENER. I WILK HI. FIVE
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO. ON ACR
ELEVEN HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
ON ACR FOURTEEN FIVE THIRTY SIX
KNOWS THEY'RE ON A C. R.
EIGHTEEN ALL OF THESE ARE
RESOLUTIONS ARE ADOPTED THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR IS
DONE IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. RICHARD. SENATE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU I KNOW THAT
WE ARE MOVING TO A GERMAN
MEMORIES NOW BUT- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE AS WE PLANNED- BUT WE
WILL HAVE OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY
MARCH FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AT NINE AM. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED
BUT WE WILL PROCEED TO SENATORS
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YEAH. MEMBERS THOSE OF YOU THAT
DO NOT WISH TO STAY WE ASK THAT
YOU TO EXIT. THE CHAMBERS
EXPEDITIOUSLY GOING TO BEGIN
THE INTERNET MEMORIES WITH
MADAME PRO TEM ATKINS SENATOR
LAYERED SENATOR SKINNER SKINNER
SENATOR HER TADO AND SHOULDN'T
SENATOR LEYVA THAT WILL BE THE
LINE AT.
MEMBERS WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT WE NEED YOU TO CLEAR
THE CHAMBERS IF YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO STICK AROUND FOR THE
INTERNET MEMORIES. AND OUT OF
RESPECT ASK THAT YOU. DO IT
QUICKLY
SENATOR ATKINS MADAM
PRO TEMP THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THIRTEEN
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY WHO
PASSED AWAY OVER THE PAST YEAR
AND I WILL MEET THE TEN MINUTE
MARK. LARRY T. BOZ A WAS A
NATIVE SAN DIEGANS A PILLAR OF
THE ARTS COMMUNITY BOTH
REGIONALLY AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL AS WELL AS A FEAR SOCIAL
JUSTICE ADVOCATE. HE PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT THE AGE OF
SEVENTY SIX DO TO COPE AT
NINETEEN. I WAS PROUD TO
APPOINT LARRY TO THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL WALL ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
SIXTEEN. AND I REAPPOINTED HIM
AS SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY HE WAS
JUST ELECTED COUNCIL CHAIR ON
DECEMBER SECOND TWENTY TWENTY.
LOCALLY IT WAS MY MENTOR FORMER
SAN DIEGO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
KRISTEN KEOGH AND SENATOR KIKO
WHO TAPPED HIM TO SERVE WITH
SAN DIEGO PRIDE IN THE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES. HE ALSO SERVED WITH
THE SAN DIEGO L. G. B. T. Q.
COMMUNITY CENTER. SAN DIEGO
DEMOCRATS FOR QUALITY THE SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
THE NATIONAL ENDOWMENT FOR THE
ARTS JUST TO NAME A FEW. FROM
CHICANO PARK TO BALBOA PARK
LARRY'S LEGACY OF ART AND
PHILANTHROPY LISSAN. REST IN
POWER MY FRIEND. DON LARSEN A
POINT LOMA HIGH ALUMNUS AND THE
NEW YORK YANKEES PITCHER. IS
IMMORTALIZED IN BASEBALL
HISTORY FIRST PERFECT GAME IN
GAME FIVE OF THE NINETEEN FIFTY
SIX WORLD SERIES AGAINST THE
BROOKLYN DODGERS. IT REMAINS
THE ONLY NO HITTER IN WORLD
SERIES HISTORY. LARSON WAS BORN
AUGUST SEVENTH NINETEEN TWENTY
NINE IN MICHIGAN CITY INDIANA
HIS FAMILY MOVED TO SAN DIEGO
IN THE MID NINETEEN FORTIES AT
POINT LOMA HIGH HE PLAYED
BASKETBALL AND BASEBALL HE
SIGNED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN FORTY SEVEN WITH THE
ST LOUIS BROWNS. FOR A FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR BONUS AND A
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR LARSON
WAS INDUCTED INTO THE SAN DIEGO
HALL OF CHAMPIONS. BRIDPORT
HALL OF FAME HE MADE SEVERAL
TRIPS TO SAN DIEGO OVER THE
YEARS OFTEN IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE ANNUAL HALL OF CHAMPIONS
CELEBRATION. LARSON PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
AT THE AGE OF NINETY. DR DAVID
CHADWICK WAS WORKING AT A
HOSPITAL IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY WHEN AN EIGHTEEN
MONTH OLD GIRL CAME IN WITH
SEVERE FRACTURES THAT HER
MOTHER ATTRIBUTED TO ACCIDENTS.
CHADWICK THOUGHT OTHERWISE HE
WANTED TO REPORT THE MOTHER BUT
THERE WAS NO MECHANISM FOR
DOING SO AND THAT CHANGED. AND
CHADWICK HAD A LOT TO DO WITH
IT. MOVING TO SAN DIEGO HE
BECAME AN INTERNATIONAL AND
SOMETIMES CONTROVERSY OLD
PIONEER AND IDENTIFYING
TREATING AND PREVENTING CHILD
ABUSE. HE HELPED WRITE ONE OF
THE NATION'S FIRST MANDATORY
ABUSE REPORTING LAWS. SET UP A
SPECIALIZED MEDICAL CENTER IN
SAN DIEGO THAT NOW BEARS HIS
NAME AND ORGANIZED AN
INFLUENTIAL ANNUAL CONFERENCE
THAT DRAWS HUNDREDS OF
PHYSICIANS NURSES. AND SOCIAL
WORKERS. DR CHADWICK PASSED
AWAY ON JANUARY NINETEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY THREE. ARCHITECT MICHAEL
C. JOHNSON WAS FAMOUS FOR HIS
WORK SHAPING DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO
SKYLINE HE WAS CO FOUNDER OF
CARRIER JOHNSON CULTURE AND
AWARD WINNING LOCAL
ARCHITECTURAL FIRM WITH GLOBAL
REACH. KERRIER JOHNSON HAS TIES
TO SOME OF THE REGION'S MOST
RECOGNIZABLE PROJECTS. AND HE'S
PLAYED A FORMATIVE ROLE IN THE
TRANSFORMATION OF EAST VILLAGE.
FOR THIRTY FOUR YEARS JOHNSON
WAS THE DRIVING FORCE BEHIND
THE SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS SUCH
AS THE DESIGN OF SAN DIEGO'S
DOWNTOWN COURTHOUSE AND PARK
TWELVE. THE HIGH RISE APARTMENT
COMPLEX OVERLOOKING PETCO PARK.
JOHNSON PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY
ELEVENTH AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
SEVEN. REVEREND GEORGE WALKER
SMITH WAS A TITAN IN SAN DIEGO
CIVIC LIFE FOR SIX DECADES AND
A TRAILBLAZING LEADER IN THE
REGION'S AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. HE WAS BORN IN
HAYNESVILLE ALABAMA THE SON OF
SHARECROPPERS HE WAS A STUDENT
WHO STOOD OUT AMID THE
IMPOVERISHED AND SEGREGATED
SCHOOLS IN THE SMALL TOWN.
SMITH'S LIFE TOOK HIM FROM
SMALL TOWN TO SEMINARY AND
PITTSBURG AND ULTIMATELY TO
BUILDING AND LEADING AND
INFLUENTIAL CHURCH SAN DIEGO.
THE THROUGH LINE IN HIS LIFE
WAS HIS FAITH AND HIS
DEDICATION TO EDUCATION. HE HAD
A CLEAR EYED AND UNCOMPROMISED
ON COMPROMISING VIEW OF THE
EVILS OF RACISM AND IT'S
EQUALLY ABIDING BELIEF THAT IF
PEOPLE SIMPLY COMMITTED TO
SPEAKING WITH EACH OTHER
CIVILLY I GOT TO KNOW ONE
ANOTHER. THEY WOULD REALIZE
THAT THEY WERE FAR MORE SIMILAR
THAN DIFFERENT. SMITH WAS
OUTSPOKEN AND UNAFRAID TO TAKE
ON A STORY AND SPEAK OUT
AGAINST INJUSTICE. HE WAS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN ELECTED
TO OFFICE IN SAN DIEGO WINNING
A RACE FOR THE SCHOOL BOARD IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE HE STARTED
THE CATFISH CLUB AND YES THEY
DID SERVE CATFISH. A WEEKLY
LUNCH MEETING ON CIVIC AFFAIRS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY IT SOON
BECAME AN INTEGRAL PART OF
PUBLIC LIFE IN THE CITY A
MANDATORY STOP FOR ASPIRING
POLITICIANS ELECTED OFFICIALS.
AND THE QUIET POWER BROKERS IN
THE CITY REVEREND SMITH PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
TWENTY TWENTY AT THE AGE OF
NINETY ONE. MARY CATHERINE
MICKEY WRIGHT WAS REGARDED BY
MANY AS THE GREATEST WOMEN'S
GOLFER IN HISTORY. THE SAN
DIEGO NATIVE BECAME CONSUMED BY
THE SPORT AT AGE ELEVEN AFTER
SEEING AN EXHIBITION BETWEEN.
BYRON NELSON AND LEO DIJUAL AT
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTRY CLUB IN
CHULA VISTA. RIGHT ONE EIGHTY
TWO TOURNAMENTS ON THE LPGA
TOUR IN A SHOW OF DOMINANCE ON
THE WOMEN'S SIDE THAT WAS
COMPARABLE TO WHAT TIGER WOODS
HAS DONE ON THE MEN'S TOUR.
GOLF LEGENDS BEN HOGAN AND
NELSON JUDGE RIGHTS SWING THE
BEST THEY'VE EVER SEEN MAN OR
WOMAN. SHE WAS A HOOVER HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE WHO HONED HER
GAME AT THE LEVOY COUNTRY CLUB
AND START US COUNTRY CLUB NOW
RIVER WALK. DOWN IN MISSION
VALLEY SHE DIED ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE. IN
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AS A
FEDERAL JUDGE IN SAN DIEGO
WILLIAM B. N. RIGHT DELIVERED
HIS RECKONING DOZENS OF TIMES.
HE LOCKED EYES ON THE DEFENDANT
HE WAS ABOUT TO SENTENCE AND
SAID. YOUR WORST FEARS HAVE
COME TO PASS TODAY IS THE DAY
WE SETTLE ACCOUNTS THE BILL
COLLECTOR COMES FOR YOU LIKE HE
COMES FOR ME. LIKE HE COMES FOR
EVERYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM. BUT
IN RIGHT ALSO UNDERSTOOD
JUSTICE IS SOMETHING MORE THAN
JUST LOCKING PEOPLE UP HE
COMPILED A LIST OF THOSE HE
INCARCERATED AND HE KEPT TABS
ON THEM. REDUCING SENTENCES FOR
GOOD BEHAVIOR WHEN HE THOUGHT
IT WAS APPROPRIATE. OVER THE
YEARS HE HANDED SEVERAL HE
HANDLED SEVERAL HIGH PROFILE
CASES ON THE BENCH INCLUDING
THE J. DAVID DOMAN ALLEY FRAUD
TRIAL. A STRING OF APPEALS BY
CONVICTED MURDERER ROBERT ALTON
HARRIS. AND A CLASS ACTION SUIT
AGAINST BUSINESS GIANTS SEE OUR
HOLD SMITH. FOLLOWING THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE COLLAPSE
OF THE UNITED STATES NATIONAL
BANK. THE MAIN CONFERENCE ROOM
AT THE U. S. DISTRICT COURT
DOWNTOWN IS NAMED AFTER HIM. HE
DIED ON MARCH SEVENTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR. MARGARET
BURBRIDGE WAS THE UC SAN DIEGO
ASTRONOMER WHO MADE LANDMARK
DISCOVERIES ABOUT THE NATURE OF
STARS. HELD POPULARIZED THE
NOTION THAT HUMANS ARE COMPOSED
OF STARDUST. AND HELP WOMEN
FIND A HOME IN SCIENCE. HER
MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE
BECOMING THE FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE AS DIRECTOR OF LONDON'S
ROYAL GREENWICH OBSERVATORY.
LADY STARDUST AS SOME PEOPLE
CALLED HER ALSO WAS PART OF THE
FOUNDING FACULTY OF UC SAN
DIEGO. IN THE EARLY SIXTIES AND
LATER CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT. OF HUBBLE SPACE
TELESCOPE SHE DIED ON APRIL
FIFTH AT THE AGE OF ONE HUNDRED.
DAN WALTERS WAS THE PADRES
CATCHER IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO
AND NINETY THREE. AND A FORMER
SAN DIEGO POLICE OFFICER HE WAS
SHOT AND GRAVELY INJURED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE. HIS DEATH WAS
CONSIDERED A LINE OF DUTY%
FATALITY WALTERS WHO ALSO
PLAYED AT SANTANA HIGH TO IN
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TWO YEARS
AFTER HIS BASEBALL CAREER
ENDED. BECOMING A POLICEMAN WAS
SOMETHING I'VE HAD IN THE BACK
OF MY MIND EVEN WHILE PLAYING
WALTER SAID IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINE INTERVIEW WITH THE
UNION TRIBUNE. ON NOVEMBER
TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND THREE FIVE
YEARS INTO HIS NEW PROFESSION
HE WAS ON PATROL ON FORTY THIRD
STREET IN CITY HEIGHTS WHEN HE
CAME ACROSS OFFICERS WHO WERE
RESPONDING. TO A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DISPUTE. WHEN WALTERS
EXITED HIS PATROL CAR THE
SUSPECT IMMEDIATELY CONFRONTED
HIM AS THE TWO STRUGGLED
WALTERS WAS SHOT IN THE NECK.
AND THEN A PASSING MOTORIST
STRUCK HIM HE SUFFERED TO CREST
CERVICAL VERTEBRAE. WALTERS WAS
A WHEELCHAIR UNTIL THE TIME OF
HIS DEATH HE DIED ON APRIL
TWENTY THIRD AT THE VERY YOUNG
AGE OF FIFTY THREE. STEVE WEST
WAS A DISTINCTIVE RADIO VOICE
WHO CAME TO SAN DIEGO BY WAY OF
SOUTH LONDON. HE IT WAS A
FRIENDLY BLOKE FROM THE PUB
KIND OF VOICE WARM AND
CONVERSATIONAL BUT STILL
BRITISH AND THEREFORE VERY
COOL. THE LONGTIME LOCAL DISC
JOCKEY WAS PART OF NINETY ONE
EXES ORIGINAL ROCK OF THE
EIGHTIES ON AIR TEAM. AND A LOT
OF WAYS THE WAS THE SIGNATURE
VOICE OF NINETY ONE X. AT THE
TIME SAID DESTRUCTIVE BRIAN
SHOCK. WHO BEGAN WORKING WITH
WEST WHEN THE RADIO STATION W.
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. IF
YOU WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL BACK
THEN AND LISTENING TO NINETY
ONE X. YOU'RE BEGINNING YOUR
LIFE AS A YOUNG ADULT. AND
THEIR STATE. AND THEN IT'S THE
NINETIES AND MAYBE YOU'VE COME
BACK TO SAN DIEGO AND THERE WAS
STATE. AND IN THE TWO THOUSANDS
HE STILL YOUR GUY HE DIDN'T
TALK AT YOU HE TALKED WITH YOU.
HE MADE YOU FEEL LIKE HE WAS
YOUR FRIEND. HE DIED ON MAY
ELEVENTH AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
EIGHT. AND IN SPECIAL
RECOGNITION I THINK OF S. R.
TEN TODAY BUT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO. JOSEPH YOU MATA AND
ELIZABETH KIKUCHI. THEY MET HIS
CHILDREN AT THE WORLD WAR TWO
IN INTERNMENT CAMPS IN PASTA IN
ARIZONA. AFTER THE WAR THEY
WENT TO SAN DIEGO HIGH SCHOOL
TOGETHER AND THEN TO UC
BERKELEY. THEY GOT MARRIED IN
THE FIFTIES RAISED A FAMILY AND
LEFT THEIR MARKS ON SAN DIEGO.
IN LANDSCAPE AND ARCHITECTURE
AND ALSO COMMUNITY SERVICE.
WHEN THEY RETURNED TO SAN DIEGO
FOR BERKELEY SHE BECAME THE
FIRST ASIAN TEACHER AT SAN
DIEGO HIGH. HE WORKED FOR
HARRIET WIMMER A PIONEERING
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECT. IMMODEST
PROJECTS INCLUDE DESIGNS FOR
SEA WORLD. UCSD THE OLYMPIC
TRAINING CENTER IN CHULA VISTA
AND THE PARKS ALONG THE
EMBARCADERO. LIZ YOU MIGHT
ACQUIT TEACHING TO RAISE THE
COUPLE'S THREE CHILDREN. AND
WHEN THEY WERE GROWN SHE WORKED
AS AN ADMINISTRATOR IN HER
HUSBAND'S FIRM AND EVENTUALLY
BECAME A PARTNER. SHE ALSO
REPORT THREE WAS ACTIVE AS A
DIRECTOR ON A VARIETY OF BOARDS
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
COLLEGES MUSEUMS AND
FOUNDATIONS. JOSEPH DIED ON MAY
ELEVENTH. AND LIZ DIED ON MAY
TWENTIETH BOTH OF THEM AT THE
AGE OF NINETY. JORDANES COUGH
VONN. WON TALK WAS BORN A COAL
MINER'S DAUGHTER BUT WITH OUR
HARD WORK PERSEVERANCE AND
ADVENTUROUS SPIRIT HE ROSE TO A
TOP POSITION IN THE NAVY
FORGING A PATH LIKE NO OTHER
WOMAN WHO CAME BEFORE HER. SHE
SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN THE NAVY
ATTAINING THE RANK OF CAPTAIN
EIGHT YEARS BEFORE HER
RETIREMENT IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX. BUT IT WAS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY WHEN SHE ECAME
PREGNANT WITH HER DAUGHTER
LEANNE. THAT SHE BECAME A
OFFICERS WHO FOLLOWED IN HER
WAKE. SHE WAS THE FIRST FEMALE
NAVAL OFFICER IN THE US TO BE
ALLOWED TO REMAIN ON ACTIVE
DUTY. AND COMPLETE A NORMAL
CAREER WHILE RAISING A CILD.
THIS OPEN THE DOOR FOR A CHANGE
IN POLICY REGARDING WOMEN WITH
CHILDREN IN THE NAVY. SHE DIED
ON JUNE TWENTY SECOND AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY NINE. AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST. I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE INTO MANIS AGE NINETY
MOTHER OF OUR FORMER DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BONNIE DUMANIS. SHE
DIED PEACEFULLY IN HER HOME ON
FEBRUARY TWELFTH SURROUNDED BY
BONNIE HER DAUGHTER IN LAW
DENISE NO LISTEN AN EXTENDED
FAMILY MEMBER THE HONORABLE
JUDY COPELAND. AND WAS BORN IN
THE BRONX NEW YORK AND LIVED
MOST OF HER LIFE IN BROCKTON
MASSACHUSETTS WHERE SHE AND HER
HUSBAND OF FIFTY SEVEN YEARS A-
RACER TWO DAUGHTERS. AND WHERE
SHE DEVELOPED HER LOVE OF
LOBSTER ROLLS PATRIOTS RED SOX
IN CAPE COD POTATO CHIPS. SHE
WORK FOR WITH WOMEN INFANTS AND
CHILDREN. AS WELL AS WITH A
PHYSICIAN FOR MANY YEARS. THE
GREAT A STRATEGY OF HURDLES
TRAGEDY OF HER LIFE OF COURSE
WAS THE DEATH OF HER DAUGHTER
DONNA AT AGE EIGHTEEN. HER
GREATEST JOY WAS BONNIE SUCCESS
AS AN ATTORNEY A JUDGE AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. ANNONAY
MOVED TO SAN DIEGO IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE TO BE CLOSE TO
BONNIE. AND UNTIL A STEP IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THEY LIVED IN
THE RANCHO BERNARDO COMMUNITY
WHERE MEMBERS OF ENTERTAINMENT.
THEY WERE ACTIVELY P. FLAG ROAD
EVERY GAY PRIDE PARADE PLUS
ENJOYED MEETING NEW FRIENDS
DURING BODIES CAMPAIGNS. THEY
ATTENDED CITIZENS OF COURAGE
LUNCHEONS AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY
AWARDS BANQUETS AMONG OTHER
THINGS. A SERVICE WILL BE HELD
THIS SUMMER IN BROCKTON
MASSACHUSETTS. ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND JENNIFER HERE I
WOULD LIKE TO- EXPRESS MY
SYMPATHY TO BONNIE AND DENISE
AND TO THE ENTIRE FAMILY.
SENATE PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THESE- MOMENTS TO
MAKE THESE ADJOURNMENTS. PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DEATH SO
THAT THEY MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR LAYERED. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. PARDON.
MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF ALISON AND- ALISON
WAS A GRADUATE OF UC SANTA CRUZ
FORMER LEGISLATIVE STAFFER. HE
WAS THE ONLY PERSON THAT WORKED
ON MY CAMPAIGN TWENTY YEARS AGO
WHEN I RAN FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. SHE WAS MY SANTA CRUZ
DISTRICT DIRECTOR FOR SIX YEARS.
SHE HAD HER TWO DAUGHTERS MOLLY
AND LUCY. WHILE WE WERE WORKING
TOGETHER AND SHE WENT TO
HALFTIME SHE WORKED. SHE DID A
FULL TIME ABOUT PUT IN A
AWARDS FOR FAMILY FRIENDLY
OFFICE SAID I KEPT TELLING HER
SHE'S THE ONE THAT SHOULD BE
GETTING THE AWARDS. I ALWAYS
SAID THAT IF SE'S ONE OF THOSE
RARE PEOPLE THAT IF I GOT A
CALL AND SHE WAS IN SIBERIAN
STRANDED I WOULD BE ON THE NEXT
FLIGHT TO HER. SHE WAS THE
CONSCIENCE OF OUR OFFICE. THERE
ARE MANY STORIES WHERE SHE
STEERED US WHERE SHE WAS
STRONG. ON MANY DIFFERENT
ISSUES STRONG ON COMMUNITY
SERVICE. AND SUBSEQUENTLY SHE
WORKED FOR TWO COUNTY
SUPERVISORS. AS THEIR STAFF
MEMBERS FROM SANTA CRUZ. WHERE
SHE WORKED WITH CONNECTING
FIRST TIME MOTHERS WITH NURSES
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT- AND REALLY
BEING THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM AS HER
LEGACY. SHE ALSO MAINTAINED A
LIFELONG TO MORE DEVOTION WITH
HER ALMA MATER AND SHE WAS A
GREAT FRIEND TO MY SPOUSE AS
WELL. A ONE TIME WHEN WE HAD A
STAFF RETREAT UP IN THE SIERRA
THEY BOTH LEFT A DAY EARLY AND
HE TALKED TO HER THE ENTIRE
FOUR HOURS BECAUSE HE WAS
AFRAID SHE WOULD FALL ASLEEP.
SHE TOLD ME AS RECENTLY AS
WEEKS BEFORE WE LOST HER. THAT
SHE DIDN'T MIND AT ALL. SHE WAS
TAKEN FROM US IN A TRAGIC
ACCIDENT. AND SHE IS MISSED
EVERY DAY- THERE'S A
SCHOLARSHIP FUND IN THE OWNER
OF HER TWO KIDS ALISON IS
SURVIVED BY HER SPOUSE ANDY
TATUM. AND OUR TWO DAUGHTERS
MOLLY AND LUCY. SERGEANT DAMON
GUTS WHILE THERE WAS A FOURTEEN
YEAR VETERAN OF SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE WHO
LAID DOWN HIS LIFE FIRST
COMMUNITY DURING A TRAFFIC THE
SHOOTING IN BEN LOMOND. HE
LOVED HIS COMMUNITY IN THIS
COMMUNITY LOVED HIM IN RETURN.
WITHIN A DAY OF LOSING HIS LIFE
I WAS ONE OF THOUSANDS FROM
ACROSS SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. WHO
SHOWED UP TO HIS VIGIL. HE WAS
A GRADUATE OF APTOS HIGH AND
LATER ATTENDED CABRILLO
COLLEGE. HE BEGAN VOLUNTEERING
FOR THE LOCAL SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AT AGE EIGHTEEN
BEFORE BEGINNING HIS
DISTINGUISHED CAREER AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER. HE WAS
KILLED IN THE LINE OF DUTY LAST
JUNE. WHILE ANOTHER SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY WAS WOUNDED IN THE SAME
ACTIVITY. THERE WAS A TRAGEDY-
THE COMMUNITY CAME TOGETHER THE
GOVERNOR CAME DOWN TO GIVE HIS.
OUR CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY.
AND HE IS REMEMBERED BY HIS
WIFE SAVVY AND HIS TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN. ONE OF WHOM WAS BORN
AFTER HE DIED. YES THAT WE HAVE
TERM IN HIS MEMORY. DOMINGO WE
ON TOP OF OUR- SPENT DECADES AS
A BUS DRIVER TRANSPORTATION
REPRESENTATIVE IN UNION LEADER
IN THE SANTA CRUZ AREA. HE
SPENT HIS CAREER FIGHTING FOR
WORKERS RIGHTS AND REMAINED
ACTIVE IN THE UCSC COMMUNITY AS
A BUS DRIVER EVEN AS HIS
RETIREMENT AFTER HIS RETIREMENT
FROM SANTA CRUZ METRO. HE
CONTINUED TO DRIVE UCSC
STUDENTS DURING THE HEIGHT OF
THE PANDEMIC BRAVELY PROVIDING
AN ESSENTIAL SERVICE UNTIL HIS
DYING DAY. HE DIED FROM
COMPLICATIONS OF COVERED LAST
DAY FROM. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE SERENA HIS DAUGHTER MANDY
HIS SON DAMIEN AND TWO
GRANDCHILDREN DAMIEN AND SASHA
TOVE ARE PAGE. EARNEST CHARM
WAS A LIFELONG PUBLIC SERVANT
WHOSE WORK INCLUDED SERVING AS
A COMMISSIONER OF THE STATE
PARKS AND RECREATION
COMMISSION. HE ALSO SERVED A
TERM AS CHAIR OF THAT BODY. HE
WAS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND EXPRESSED FERVENT
SUPPORT FOR RENAMING STATE
PARKS IN HONOR OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURALLY RICH
AND DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. HE WAS
BOLD AND IMAGINATIVE COMBINE
ALWAYSHAD THIS MIND THINKING
OF WAYS TO SERVICE COMMUNITY.
THE PARK IT A COMMUNITY BASED
INITIATIVE TO PROVE PARK PLANS
ACCESS AND SUSTAINABLE TRAFFIC
FLOW IN THE BIG SUR AREA. WAS
HIS BRAINCHILD. HE WAS INJURED
IN A CYCLING ACCIDENT IN THE
LEFT WITH THE SPINAL CORD AND
THIS INJURY HE CONTINUED TO
SERVE ON THE STATE PARKS
COMMISSION WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
HE PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH.
SABRINA LEASE WAS A DAYCARE
CENTER WORKER FROM PASO ROBLES
WHOSE LIFE WAS CUT SHORT BY ON
HIGHWAY ONE OH ONE IN SOUTH
MONTEREY COUNTY ON FEBRUARY
SECOND SHE WAS JUST TWENTY
THREE. SHE WAS RETURNING HOME
AFTER A DAY AT THE BEACH WITH
HER BOYFRIEND AND BELOVED DOG.
WHEN AN IMPAIRED DRIVER CROSSED
THE MEDIAN AND HIT HER HEAD ON
THE LINE. SHE WAS KNOWN FOR HER
COMPASSION AND LOVE FOR ANIMALS
AND SMALL CHILDREN AND
DEDICATED HER LIFE'S WORK TO
PROVIDING CARE FOR THE
VULNERABLE. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER PARENTS POLIS AND MICHELLE
GURLEY OF PASO ROBLES. THREE
BROTHERS PATRICK GLEASON QUITE
CLIFTON OF PASO ROBLES AND PAUL
JUNIOR OF CARMEL VALLEY. AND
TWO SISTERS MADISON CLIFTON AND
MEGAN HARRIS OF PASO ROBLES.
HER BEST FRIEND AND COUSIN
BETHANY BAGEL OF ARIZONA AND
NUMEROUS OTHER COUSINS AUNTS
UNCLES GODPARENTS AND GOD.
GRANDPARENTS CHERYL CONWAY WAS
A PASSIONATE ACTIVIST
INTELLIGENT LEADER CARING
VOLUNTEER AND LOYAL FRIEND FOR
LIFE TO ALL THOSE WHO KNEW HER
OF WHICH I WAS ONE. HE PASSED
AWAY SUDDENLY OF UNDIAGNOSED
PROBLEM ON DECEMBER TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWENTY. SHE WAS
BORN IN NEW ORLEANS BUT ONLY
SPENT A SHORT TIME IN LOUISIANA
SHE MET SPENT MOST OF HER EARLY
LIFE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDED LIVE INCLUDING LIVING
IN GARDEN GROVE IN SALINAS.
FROM THE FAMILY HOME IN SALINAS
SHE ATTENDED CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO AND COMPLETED A BACHELOR
OF ARTS DEGREE IN JOURNALISM.
AND A MASTER'S DEGREE IN
COUNSELING FROM THE EDUCATION
PROGRAM. SHE WAS A POLITICAL
ACTIVIST. SHE WAS AN OFFICER OF
THE N. DOUBLE ACP SHE WAS A
LEADER IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
CENTRAL COMMITTEE FOR OVER A
DECADE. SHE WAS TREASURER FOR
SEVERAL YEARS AND WAS AT ONE
POINT CHOSEN FOR THE VOLUNTEER
OF THE YEAR AWARD. I THAT WAS A
BIG CHALLENGE FOR THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE SHE WROTE. ALL THE
HONORING OF THE VOLUNTEER OF
THE YEAR AND SOMEBODY ELSE HAD
TO DO IT WITHOUT HER KNOWING.
SHE WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE REJUVENATED SAMOSA THIS BUT
DEMOCRATIC CLUB. AND SERVED AT
EVERY LEVEL IN THE PARTY SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND JIM
CONWAY. HER BROTHER TERRY
RUSSELL HER NEPHEW WALTER
RUSSELL AND HER NIECE RIANA AND
RUSSELL AND MANY LONG TIME
FRIENDS. FOR DECADES SURELY
BIANCHI EXEMPLIFIED THE VALUES
OF HARD WORK IN PUBLIC SERVICE
IN OUR COMMUNITY. SHE WAS
PERSISTENT AND DEDICATED IN
ADVOCATING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
AGRICULTURAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUES. HE SERVED TWO TERMS AS
A SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
DISTRICT TWO SUPERVISOR AND
PRIOR TO THAT SERVED TWO TERMS
ON THE COUNTY PLANNING
COMMISSION. SHE WAS CO FOUNDER
OF THE LAND CONSERVANCY OF SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNTY WHICH HAS
BECOME ONE OF THE LARGER LAND
CONSERVANCIES INTEGRATOR
REACHING. HER MANY ACHIEVEMENTS
AND ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE
ESTABLISHING A PROGRAM TO
COMBAT SUBSTANCE ABUSE BY
PREGNANT WOMEN. AND GUIDING THE
SUPERVISING AND RESTRICTING
DEVELOPMENT AND VERY OTHER IN
VARIOUS OTHER AREAS OF THE
NORTH POST IN THE COUNTY. SHE
IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND OF
FIFTY SEVEN YEARS A BILL AS
WELL AS THEIR THREE DAUGHTERS
KATHERINE MARIANNE AND JAN
MALES HE WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH
BY HER SON JOHN. HOME BENITO
JOSEPH JOE PRESSIONE THROUGHOUT
HIS LONG ACCOMPLISHED LIFE TO
BUILD A FOUR DECADE LONG
CAREER. AS AN ARCHITECT AND
HELD A STRONG PASSION FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE. THE SERVICE
COMMUNITY ON THE WOODLAND CITY
COUNCIL AND SPENT TWO TERMS AS
MAYOR OF PISMO BEACH ALWAYS
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT HE HELD
OFFICE IN TWO DIFFERENT CITIES.
HE PASSED AWAY IN WOODLAND
SKILLED NURSING. IN JANUARY
FROM A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER
HE IS SURVIVED BY THIS WIFE
MARCIA THERE FOR CHILDREN AND
SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN HE WILL BE
LAID TO REST AT THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY NATIONAL CEMETERY. AND I
WILL SUBMIT A GERMAN MEMORIES
FOR TERRY WHEN CONTINI AND MARK
MELTS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
LAYERED PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU
BRING THEIR NAMES TO THE DESK
SO THEY CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR HER
DAUGHTER. SENATOR HURTADO THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO CHURN
IN MEMORY OF PREMIER OF GARY
THIRTY YEARS OLD OF SINGER A
YOUNG MAN WITH HOPES AND DREAMS
OF A BETTER LIFE HE WAS CARING
AND OFTEN. LOOK AFTER OTHERS HE
WAS QUIET A GREAT LISTENER WITH
A BEAUTIFUL SMILE HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER HIS
FATHER SISTERS BROTHER AND MANY
OTHERS AND LOVED HIM. JOSE LUIS
RIVERA FIFTY THREE OF FRESNO.
HE WAS A FOOD STREET VENDOR.
TRYING TO MAKE ENDS MEET HE WAS
ALSO A FATHER AND A GRANDFATHER
WHOSE LIFE WAS TRAGICALLY CUT
SHORT HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY WILL REMAIN AND SO
WILL THE DREAM TO PROVIDE
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE.
THAT COME AFTER US. ROBERT FORD
FIFTY SIX OF BAKERSFIELD HAS
LIKE GONE TOO SOON. AS HE WAS
PEACEFULLY PRACTICING HIS RIGHT
TO DEMONSTRATE HIS MEMORY WILL
FOREVER REMAIN IN OUR COMMUNITY.
PICTURE DANIEL MARTINEZ THIRTY
SIX OF LINDSEY'S BORN TO A
MOTHER AND EXPLAIN MY **** IN
FEBRUARY NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
AND TWO THOUSAND AT THE AGE OF
THIRTEEN. TO RECEIVE THE TULARE
COUNTY JUSTICE AWARD FOR THE
CRITIQUE EXHIBITED IN
TESTIFYING AGAINST THE PERSON
WHO IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
BROKE INTO HIS HOME AND
MURDERED HIS MOTHER AND SISTER.
VICTOR GRADUATED FROM MONEX
HIGH SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
IN HIGH SCHOOL HE STARTED TO DJ
MUSIC AND THIS IS HOW HE CAME
TO MEET HIS WIFE EMILY NUMBER
-(*** THEY BECAME FRIENDS AND
EVENTUALLY HIS PERSISTENCE WON
HER OVER VICTOR WAS A TO
STARTING FATHER TO SON OF THE
ELEMENT DEACONESS AND HIS
DAUGHTER UMBRIEL MARTINUS.
VICTOR WAS ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL
SUPERVISOR AT THE PORTERVILLE
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER OVERSEEN
CUSTODIAL STAFF AND ENSURING
THAT THE FACILITY WAS SAFE AND
SANITIZED FOR. ALL STAFF FROM
THE PANDEMIC. SUSANA GARCIA
FIFTY TWO OF DELAY NO. KNOWN TO
MANY AS SUSIE WAS BORN IN
TIJUANA MEXICO SHE WAS A GOOD
COOK WHO LOVE TO DANCE AND TO
LISTEN TO SINGER JENNI RIVERA.
SHE ENJOYED FAMILY GATHERINGS
SHE WAS OFTEN THINKING OF
OTHERS. AND ATTENDING THE
FUNERALS OF PEOPLE SHE DIDN'T
KNOW IN TWENTY PRAYER CIRCLES
AT ST MARY'S CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
DELANO. AMBER BEESON THIRTY
NINE OF BAKERSFIELD HE
LANDSCAPE DESIGNER AND FOUNDER
OF THE NONPROFIT GIVING TREE
PROJECT AMBER BEESON TRANSFER
VACANT LOTS AND BAKERSFIELD
INTO COMMUNITY GARDENS. SHE WAS
A FORMER PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT
KERN GREEN. CHAIRWOMAN OF THE
COMMUNITY GARDENS COMMITTEE FOR
KEEP BECAUSE FEEL BEAUTIFUL AT
ONE TIME BOARD MEMBER WITH THE
ARTS COUNCIL OF KERN. MASON WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH A CANCEROUS
TUMOR GROWING AT AN ALARMING
RATE DETERMINED TO REMAIN WITH
HER HUSBAND AND FOUR CHILDREN
SHE LAUNCHED A FUNDRAISER TO
HELP PAY FOR CONVENTIONAL AS
WELL AS POSSIBLE TENTATIVE
TREATMENTS. BUT ULTIMATELY SHE
SUCCUMBED TO THE DISEASE IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR. ONE
WEEKEND MENDIS CORPORATE YES OF
HANFORD. ARMY SPECIALIST ONE
MIGUEL MENDEZ COOPER VS DIED
MARCH ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY.
WHEN HIS UNIT WAS ENGAGED BY
ENEMY INDIRECT FIRE IN IRAQ.
HIS FAMILY'S GRIEF WAS
COMPOUNDED BY THE FACT THAT HIS
REMAINS COULD NOT BE
TRANSPORTED FOR TWO MONTHS
AFTER THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BEGAN. TONY SANCIOUS
OF HANFORD TWENTY ONE ZERO
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. WHO DIED
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY ACTUALLY
CONTRACTED COOPER NINETEEN FROM
THE PATIENT. HIS MEDICAL CAREER
SPENT FIFTY PLUS. HIS PATIENCE
NEW HIM AS A COMPASSIONATE
PROVIDER WHO THEY COULD SPEAK
TO IN THEIR NATIVE LANGUAGE.
THEY WERE APPRECIATED OF THAT
OPPORTUNITY. HE WAS ALSO KNOWN
FOR HIS INFECTIOUS LAUGH. BIG
HUGS WARM AND GRACIOUS MANNER
AND HIS GENEROSITY WITH
EVERYONE THAT HE MET. RICHARD
FRANKLIN SHEPARD OF SINGER.
DICK AS HE WAS KNOWN BY MOST
WAS BORN IN JUNE NINETEEN
THIRTY SIX TWO AB AND BERTHA
SHEPHERD AND MACOMB OKLAHOMA.
WHEN HE WAS SEVEN HIS PARENTS
MOVED THE FAMILY TO THE LINNELL
FORM LABOR CAMP YOUR FARMERS
BILL. FOR THE FAMILY WORKED IN
THE FIELDS. AS EDITOR OF THE
SINGER HERALD NEWSPAPER HIS
HARD HITTING STORIES PROMPTED
NOT ONE. BUT FOUR GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATIONS. DICK PROBABLY
SERVED HIS COUNTRY IN THE U. S.
ARMY UNDER MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE BRANCH. SIXTY
DEEPLY LOVED HIS COMMUNITY AND
HAD A UNIQUE PASSION FOR
SERVICE. HIS POLITICAL IDEOLOGY
WAS DIFFERENT THAN MINE BUT WE
SHARE THAT SAME PASSION TO
SERVE AND IMPROVE OUR COMMUNITY.
HE RESPECTED MY POLITICAL
IDEOLOGY AND I RESPECTED HIS
EVEN MORE. HE WAS THE FIRST
PERSON I WENT TO FOR ADVICE ON
SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE. AND I
WILL FOREVER REMEMBER OUR LAST
CONVERSATION WHICH WAS SUMMER
OF LAST YEAR. AS HE WAS
RECOVERING HE WANTED TO WRITE A
STORY ON NURSING HOMES AND HE
REACHED OUT. WE JOKED ABOUT
POLITICS TODAY. HE ADMITTED TO
NOT HAVING VOTED FOR ME AND WE
LAUGHED ABOUT IT. I TOLD HIM NO
MATTER WHAT I ALWAYS RESPECTED
WHAT HE HAD TO SAY. HE WENT ON
TO SAY THAT I WAS DOING A GREAT
JOB AND WAS VERY PROUD OF ME.
HE SAID HE HAD NEVER VOTED FOR
A DEMOCRAT BUT I WOULD BE THE
FIRST. HIS SPIRIT WILL FOREVER
BE WITH US AND WITH ME AND THE
COMMUNITY. BUT HE LOVES S
MUCH. DEKHA SURVIVED BY
NINETEEN HIS WIFE OF THIRTY SIX
YEARS HIS THREE CHILDREN. MIKE
SHEPPARD CASSANDRA GORDON AND
CHRISTOPHER SHEPHERD HIS NINE
GRANDCHILDREN AND IS NINE GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. TO ENSURE THAT
THERE WAS FOOD ON OUR TABLES.
WELL WE WORK FROM HOME BIG
COULD NOT ALL. BE AT HOME WITH
YOUR LOVED ONES. AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF THE
STATE AND WE SHOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS THERE SACRIFICE
ACCORDINGLY. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE. AND A TURN IN MEMORY
OF TWENTY OTHER LOS ANGELES
MUDDLE MUDDLE SILVA A FINGER. I
KNEW HER AS THOUGH YOUR
HEADLINE. SHE WAS MY NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBOR. AND SOMEONE THAT
SOMEBODY CORRUPT FOR MANY YEARS
SOMEONE THEY CARE DEEPLY. ABOUT
NATURE AND YOU WOULD OFTEN FIND
HER. TRIMMING THE TREES.
GATHERING THE LEAVES. AND
ALWAYS HAD A SMILE AND A JOKE
TO SAY. I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE BY
READING A PASSAGE FROM MY
FAVORITE POET. BY AND LARGE
OVER TIME. PAIN TURNS INTO
GRIEF. GRIEF TURNS INTO SILENCE
AND SILENCE TURNED INTO LAW
LONESOME THIS. AS VAST AND
BOTTOMLESS OF THE DARK OCEANS.
YOU THINK YOU CAN NOT LIVEANYMORE YOU THINK THAT THE
LIGHT OF YOUR SOUL HAS BEEN PUT
OUT AND THAT YOU WILL STAY IN
THE DARK FOREVER. BUT WHEN YOU
ARE ENGULFED BY SUCH SOLID
DARKNESS WHEN YOU HAVE BOTH
EYES CLOSED TO THE WORLD. THE
THIRD EYE OPENS IN YOUR HEART.
AND ONLY THEN DO YOU COME TO
REALIZE THAT I CITE CONFLICTS
WITH INTERNAL IT SHOULD. NO I
SEE SO CLEAR AND SHARP AS I OF
LOVE. AFTER GRIEF COMES ANOTHER
SEASON ANOTHER VALLEY ANOTHER
YOU. AND THE LEVER WAS NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND YOU CAN START TO
SEE HIM AT THE DROP OF WATER
THAT FALLS INTO THE OCEAN. AND
THE HIGH TIDE TO FOLLOW THE
WAXING OF THE MOON. OR IN THE
MORNING WHEN THE EXPERTS AT.
FRESH SMELL. YOU SEE THEM IN
THE GEOMANCY SYMBOLS IN THE
SAND IN THE TINY PARTICLES OR
BROCCOLI GREEN UNDER THE SUN
AND THE SMILE OF A NEW BORN
BABY OR IN YOUR THROBBING PAIN.
MUCH LIKE THE POET BELIEVED
ABOUT HIS LOVE ONE SEVEN
HUNDRED YEARS AGO. SIMILARLY
TODAY DEEPEN THE SLOWER LEAN OF
SORROW AND LONGING YOUR LOVED
ONE OUR LOVED ONES. ARE
EVERYWHERE AND IN EVERY SCENE
RUSTY. JUST AS A MOUNTAIN KEEPS
AN ECHO INSIDE ITSELF YOU HOLD
THE VOICE OF YOUR LOVED ONE
WITH ANY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. SENATOR HURTADO
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH SO THAT THEY MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR LEE MON.
THANK YOU. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
MA'AM. EIGHT ZERO THE DAY
MEMBERS REYES FROM SENT TO
RECOGNIZE THE FOLKS FROM SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTY HAVE
PASSED AWAY. THIS PAST WEEK
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY LOST A
VALUABLE MEMBER OF THE I LOVE
THIS TO COMMUNITY FATHER JOHN
STEPHEN HEDGES. FATHER JOHN
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO SERVE
OTHERS THE MOST VULNERABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITY HE WAS INVOLVED
IN VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
FOCUSED IN SERVING THE NEEDIEST
MORE RECENTLY HE SERVED AS A
MEMBER OF THE ISLAND INSTEAD
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT.
FATHER JOHN LEAVES A TREMENDOUS
LEGACY IN SANTA BARBARA WHICH
HAS BEEN APPARENT BY THE NUMBER
OF TRIBUTES MADE ACROSS SOCIAL
MEDIA IN RECENT DAYS. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE MARIA
MELISSA HEDGES TWO ADULT
CHILDREN AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN.
LONG TIME PUBLIC SERVANT JOHN
SHARKEY FORMER PORT WHY NINI
COUNCILMEMBER AND MAYOR PASSED
AWAY IN DECEMBER. DURING HIS
TWENTY FOUR YEARS ON COUNCIL
HIS EFFORTS FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING CULTURALLY REVISION
AN OLD WASTE WATER SYSTEM AND
ADVOCATING FOR LIBRARIES AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HE WAS
RECOGNIZED BY HIS UNIQUE
MUSTACHE AND PONY TAIL ON THE
DYESS. AND IN THE COMMUNITY. HE
WAS A CLASSICAL CLASSICALLY
TRAINED PIANIST WHO AS A
COUNCIL MEMBER WROTE AND PASSED
THE CITY'S CHARTER. JOHN
SHARKEY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
BEVERLY KELLY SIGNED AND
RETIRED US AIR FORCE MAJOR
NEEDS AND SHARKEY. STEPSONS
TREVOR AND BRENDAN KELLY AND
GRANDSONS MAXWELL SHARKEY AND
ELLIOT ST LOUIS. FORMER MEMBER
FONG FORMER CONGRESS MEMBER
STATE SENATOR AND- HIGH MAYOR
ROBERT J. LAGO MARCELINO.
PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR. DURING THE
NINETEEN YEARS HE REPRESENTED
VENTURA AND SANTA BARBARA
COUNTIES IN CONGRESS HE SERVED
UNDER FIVE PRESIDENTS. MORE
NOTABLY HE RECOGNIZE HE'S
RECOGNIZED BY HIS WORK
CHAMPIONING THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE CHANNEL ISLANDS NATIONAL
PARK THE FORTIETH NATIONAL PARK
IN THE COUNTRY. HIS TERM HIS
TERM AS STATE SENATOR IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY ONE TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS UNDERSCORED IN
THIS DISTRICT BY HIS
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO
ESTABLISH A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
IN VENTURA COUNTY. WHICH YEARS
LATER LED TO THE OPENING OF THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY CHANNEL
ISLANDS CAMPUS. MR LOGGER
MARCELINO IS SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER STEP SON OR
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDSON. TWENTY SPOKE ABOUT
ABOUT KNOWN AS FRANK OR CHEN
SHOW WAS AN EDUCATOR AND
CHAMPION FOR STUDENTS. HE WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY BUT EVENTUALLY
MADE OXNARD HIS HOME AFTER
STARTING HIS CAREER IN
EDUCATION AND WILL PETERS
CALIFORNIA. HIS EXPERIENCE IN
THE CLASSROOM WHERE LAND. A
SPOKESPERSON AND STATE
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND SCHOOL PRINCIPAL UNTIL HIS
RETIREMENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX IN RETIREMENT HE CONTINUED
ADVOCATING FOR STUDENTS IN
EDUCATION AS A MEMBER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
MEXICAN AMERICAN EDUCATED
EDUCATORS OXNARD CHAPTER.
DURING HIS TEACHING CAREER HE
WORKED WITH FIVE FRIENDS WHO
TOGETHER FOUND THIRTY F. PRESS
INC A PUBLISHING COMPANY THAT
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE THIRD
LARGEST BILINGUAL EDUCATIONAL
PUBLISHING COMPANY. EXCEEDING
SUPPLY STORE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FRANK LEAVES BEHIND
HIS WIFE ANNA DAUGHTER MONEY
GAS AND GRANTS AS ON THE S. AND
MATTHEW. SANDEEP TULA RESIDENT
OF NIPOMO PASSED AWAY SUDDENLY
IN FEBRUARY. HE SPENT NINETEEN
YEARS AS A MEMBER OF THE ALLAN
HANCOCK FOOTBALL TEAMS SERVING
AS OFFENSIVE LINE COACH. SANDY
WAS A DEDICATED COACH UNLIKE
MANY OTHERS HE KNEW EVERY
SINGLE PLAYER ON THE TEAM. THIS
STORY IS HISTORY AT THE COLLEGE
STARTED AS A STUDENT AND
ATHLETE HIMSELF HE WAS AN ALL
CONFERENCE OFFENSIVE GUARD FOR
HANCOCK COLLEGE. DANDY'S
LEADERSHIP ON THE TEAM IS
RECOGNIZED BY HIS FELLOW
COACHES AND PLAYERS WHO LISTEN
WHEN HE SPOKE HE WILL BE MISSED
BY HIS FAMILY AND IN SPORTS
AMONG THE CENTRAL COAST. LASTLY
I WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE THE FOUR HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN INDIVIDUALS IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND THE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR IN
VENTURA COUNTY WHOSE LIVES WERE
LOST DUE TO CODE IN NINETEEN
THIS PAST YEAR. THESE MEMBERS
DO NOT STAND ALONE THEY ARE
CONNECTED TO THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN JURIED
THIS PAIN OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WHO HAVE LOST LOVED ONES IN THE
MOST CHALLENGING OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THESE
VALUABLE MEMBERS OF OUR VENTURA
AND SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR LEE MON. AND PLEASE BE
SURE TO BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK SO THAT THEY CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORY ALLIES BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR SKINNER.
YEAH. NOBODY USED IT. SENATOR
SKINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK. MEMBERS BY RICE. TRUST
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN IN- DURING
MEMORY FOR CHARLES PARNELL
RICHMOND RESIDENT. CHARLES ARE
RUMORED WAS A VETERAN A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA IN A VERY DEAR
FRIEND AND MENTOR TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT. OF SCHOOLS FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TONY
THURMOND. TERREL STEVEN ARNOLD
WAS BORN ON AUGUST SEVENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY EIGHT IN
GREENVILLE SOUTH CAROLINA AFTER
GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL HE
ENLISTED IN THE U. S. NAVY.
TWENTY SERVED OUR COUNTRY FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS RETIRING AS
A LIEUTENANT COMMANDER. CURLS
ENJOY LEARNING COOKING AND THE
KEEPSAKES THAT IT COLLECTED
FROM HIS TRAVELS HIS FRIENDS
AND HIS FAMILY ESPECIALLY HIS
TREASURED SISTER. BETTY JEAN.
LET ME READ TO YOU NOW
PERMISSION TO READ WHAT
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN SAID OF
HIS GOOD FRIEND CHUCK WAS A
LONGTIME CONSTITUENT COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEER DURING MY TIME I'M
REFERRING NOW TO- DISTRICT
THURMOND DURING MY TIME IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY HE
WAS A NEIGHBOR AND FRIEND THAT
I REGULARLY SPOKE TO AND
VISITED. LIKE ME HE DID NOT
HAVE EXTENDED FAMILY IN THE
AREA YET HE BECAME LIKE A
FAMILY MEMBER TO ME LIKE AN
UNCLE HE WAS OFTEN LOOKING OUT
FOR ME IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SERVED IN HIS LATER YEARS I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME
HIS HEALTH CARE TAKER. TOOK WAS
A TWENTY SEVEN YEAR NAVY
VETERAN WHO SERVED HIS COUNTRY
IN REGULARLY SERVED HIS
COMMUNITY AND HELPS IN
PRODUCING GREATER OUTCOMES I
WAS HONORED TO HAVE HIM JOIN ME
ON THE FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY FOR
MY SECOND SWEARING IN. HAND BUT
HE WAS ABLE TO SEE ME BECOME
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION HE WAS A
DEAR FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR AND A
VALUED CONSTITUENTS. CHARLES
PASS AWAY ON. FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND PER HIS WISHES
HIS ASHES ARE BEING SPREAD OVER
THE OCEAN WATER ON WHICH HE
SPENT MANY YEARS SERVING HIS
COUNTRY. HE WAS PREDECEASED BY
HIS PARENTS BENJAMIN AND LUCY
ARNOLD SISTER BETTY JEAN ARNOLD
AND YOU SURVIVED BY NIECES.
VANESSA EDWARDS SABRINA
MITCHELL AND A HOST OF LOVING
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. AND I HAVE
ONE MORE TO JUST HAVE TO GET MY
GLASS. RIVERS I ASK THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN AN ETERNAL MEMORIES
FOR DOCTOR BURKE LUPIN'S. WHO
PASSED AWAY IN TWENTY TWENTY.
DR BIRD LUPIN WESTIE ZERO FOUR
TIME AT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
OAKLAND HE'S A PEDIATRICIAN A
RESEARCHER HEALTH ADVOCATE A
LOVING HUSBAND FATHER
GRANDFATHER AND A GOOD FRIEND
OF MINE NO ONE MOREINFLUENTIAL
ARE DEDICATED TO HELPING SICK
AND LOW INCOME CHILDREN IN THE
EAST BAY IN THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS THE DOCTOR LUPIN HE WAS
BORN IN NINETEEN THIRTY NINE IN
THE BRONX NEW YORK WHERE HIS
FATHER WORKED AS A HUCKSTER.
SELLING FRUIT OFF THE PLANE
CARE SHOULD PUSH CART HIS
FAMILY MOVED TO PITTSBURGH
WHERE BURKE BEGAN WORKING IN
HIS PARENTS FRUIT MARKET DALY
YEAH HE PRACTICEDAND LEARNED
DRUMS AND BECAME AN EXCELLENT
JAZZ DRUMMER ONCE HE GOT TO
JOIN THE LONELIEST MARC DURING
A PERFORMANCE WHEN FELONIOUS
MUNK STRUMMER BECAME ILL AND
BURKE OFFERED HIS STREAMING
SERVICE. BURKE WAS THE FIRST IN
HIS FAMILY TO GRADUATE COLLEGE
HE WENT ON TO MEDICAL SCHOOL
AND PITTSBURG UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE AND HE WAS DRAFTED
DURING THE VIETNAM WAR AND HE
SERVED AS A DOCTOR AT A HEALTH
CLUB- CLINIC FOR CHILDREN IN
RURAL VIETNAM IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE HE WAS DRAWN TO
SERVE AT CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
OAKLAND BECAUSE OF ITS DIVERSE
PATIENT POPULATION HE BECAME
THE FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTE. AND A TRAILBLAZER IN
THE RESEARCH OF SICKLE CELL
DISEASE HIS RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY LED TO CALIFORNIA
MANDATING ALL NEW NEWBORNS TO
BE SCREENED FOR SICKLE CELL
DISEASE NOW ALL FIFTY STATES
MANDATE THOSE SCREENINGS HE WAS
THE FIRST PEDIATRICIAN TO
SERVICIOS THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN THIS. ANY TIME IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA. HE
COMMITTED TEACH NEXT GEN OF DOT
AND RESEARCHERS AND BIRD
ESTABLISHED AN INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM WHICH SERVES OVER A
THOUSAND STUDENTS OF COLOR. DR
LUPIN'S COLLEAGUES DESCRIBED
HIM AS EVERYONE'S FRIEND MENTOR
CARE GIVER IN HEALER EVEN IN
RETIREMENT HE REMAINED ACTIVE
IN COMMUNITY HEALTH AND ANTI
POVERTY WORK. AND DRIVING WITH
HIS BELOVED JAZZ BANDS DOCTOR
NEWMAN AND HIS WIFE VIVIAN
PROVIDED PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT
TO ORGANIZATIONS AND HEALTH
CLINICS DEDICATED TO
IMMIGRANTS. AND TO COMMUNITY
HEALTH TO JAZZ INTERSPORT
INSTITUTIONS. DR LIVING PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY ON JUNE TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY TWENTY AFTER A TWO
YEAR STRUGGLE WITH A BRAIN
TUMOR AND HE WAS SURROUNDED BY
HIS WIFE VIVIAN SURE LACK AND
FAMILY DOCTOR LUPIN I WILL MISS
YOU. THANK YOU. SANDERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DEATH SO
THAT THEY MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR LEYVA. SENATOR LEYVA
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
TODAY OF SEVERAL CONSTITUENTS
FROM THE TWENTY STATE SENATE
DISTRICT AND THE GREATER INLAND
EMPIRE REGION THAT PASSED AWAY
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS. ON
JANUARY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FLORA P. WALL MOTHER OF
RONALD WALL FROM ONTARIO PASSED
AWAY. FLORA WAS BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO NEW MEXICO IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX. SHE WAS
ONE OF TEN CHILDREN BORN TO
LEOPOLDO AND DOMENICA PERALTA.
SHE WAS ALSO THE FIRST IN HER
FAMILY TO GRADUATE FROM LA HOYA
HIGH SCHOOL. WAS THE
VALEDICTORIAN AND ALSO RECEIVED
A SCHOLARSHIP TO ATTEND
ALBUQUERQUE BUSINESS SCHOOL. HE
THAT AND WORKED IN SAPPORO NEW
MEXICO WHERE SHE MET HER
HUSBAND CORNEWALL BEFORE MOVING
TO CALIFORNIA. UNTIL SHE
RETIRED. DON GRIGGS FROM SAMITY
NO PASSED AWAY ON JULY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY. A
VETERAN MISTER GRIGGS WORKED AT
KAISER STEEL SENATE NORDSTROM
WHERE HE DESIGNED AFROCENTRIC
TICE HE WAS ALSO A TRUE
ADVOCATE FOR THE BOY SCOUTS OF
AMERICA. AS WELL AS A
COMMUNITY. IF THERE WAS EVER
ANYTHING WRONG AT WORK CITY
HALL THE WATER DISTRICT OR
ANYWHERE ELSE MISTER GRIGGS WAS
ALWAYS ONE OF THE FIRST TO
SPEAK UP. TO HELP RIGHT THOSE
WRONGS. ON DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY A LOT IS SAY TO
PO ALSO KNOWN AS ELIAS A
DEVOTED FATHER TO TWO SONS AND
A VOLUNTEER IN THE CITY OF
FONTANA ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATED TO EDUCATION OF HIS TWO
SONS PASSED AWAY. HE ALWAYS
WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
HIS KIDS HAD A GREAT EDUCATION
AND WILL GROW UP TO BE
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS. ON
DECEMBER NINETEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY. DON LEWIS FROM FONTANA
A VETERAN. ALSO KNOWN AS MR
GRUMPY PASSED AWAY HE WORK FOR
KAISER STEEL AND THE FONTANA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. ANY
ALSO SERVED AS A TERM HAVE
SERVED A TERM AS PRESIDENT OF
THE FONTANA EXCHANGE CLUB. HE
SPENT OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
COUNTLESS HOURS HELPING TO
COORDINATE THE ANNUAL FONTANA
DAYS FESTIVAL AND PARADE. AS
WELL AS THE ANNUAL FONTANA
CHRISTMAS PARADE. HE'S IS A
VIRUS ALSO KNOWN AS CHESS FROM
SAMBAR DINO PASSED ON DECEMBER
TWENTIETH TWENTY SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY. A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
SAMBAR DINO HE SERVED IN
THAILAND AS A COMMUNICATIONS
SPECIALIST FOR THEUS ARMY FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE TO NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN MISTER OLIVARES
WORKED AT KAISER STEEL FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS AS A CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER FOR TWENTY
YEARS. HE WAS WELL KNOWN FOR
HIS SENSE OF HUMOR AND ARTISTIC
TALENT AND HE EVEN PAINTED
WINDOWS EVERY CHRISTMAS FOR
FORTY SEVEN YEARS. GLORIA AVILA
FROM SAMBAR DINO PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY. A DEVOTED WIFE MOTHER
GRANDMOTHER AND FRIEND ANDI
UNDERSTAND AN AMAZING COOK SHE
IS MISSED BY HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS ACROSS THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND BEYOND. LESLEE SHAW
FROM POINT FONTANA PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. A WIFE AND A MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN MICHELLE DIED
AFTER BATTLING COVERED NINETEEN
SOON AFTER GIVING BIRTH TO HER
THIRD CHILD. SHE WAS TRULY A
DEVOTED MOTHER TO HER CHILDREN
AS WELL AS A DANCE TEACHER WHO
STRIVED TO INSPIRE ALL CHILDREN.
FRANCIS OF LOVE FROM COLTON WAS
BORN IN SAMBAR DINO AND THEN
LIVED IN COLTON FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS I WAS TOLD THAT MS AVILA
ENJOYED HER BUDWEISER AND HER
CIGARETTES AND IS TERRIBLY
MISSED BY HER FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. SHE PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ON JANUARY TWENTY
SIXTH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
MARGARET REYES PASSED AWAY SHE
WAS A LOVING MOTHER AND FRIEND
AND GREATLY ENJOYED TENDING TO
HER GARDEN. SHE LOVED THE LORD
AND MADE A HUGE IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF MANY. SURELY COMBS
ERRINGTON FOR RIALTO PASSED
AWAY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. A WIFE AND
DEVOTED CARETAKER THAT LOVE
LIFE AND HER MINISTRY. MISS
ERRINGTON WAS A GRACIOUS AND
HUMBLE WOMAN. SHE GAVE BACK TO
HER COMMUNITY AND WAS ALWAYS
AVAILABLE FOR OTHERS. EVEN
THOUGH SHE BATTLED BONE CANCER
SHE WAS ALWAYS IN GOOD SPIRITS
AND SERVES AS AN INSPIRATION TO
US ALL. A MOTHER A GRANDMOTHER
AND FRIEND EVEY RUBIO FROM
COLTON PASSED AWAY FROM COVERT
NINETEEN. SHE VOLUNTEERED AT
SAN SALVADOR CHURCH FIESTAS AS
WELL AS THE LOCAL LUKE
COMMUNITY CENTER. EVEN ON
DIFFICULT DAYS MAYES RUBIO
ALWAYS HAD A SMILE ON HER FACE
THE BRIGHTEN THE DAYS AND LIVES
OF THOSE AROUND HER. MEMBERS I
OFFER THESE ADJOURNMENT REYES
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO LEFT AN
INDELIBLE MARK ON THE LIVES OF
RESIDENTS AND COMMUNITIES IN
SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND ARE
CERTAINLY GREATLY MISSED BY
THEIR FAMILY FRIENDS AND LOVED
ONES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN THEIR MEMORIES.
SENATOR LEYVA PLEASE BRING
THEIR NAMES TO THE DESK SO THEY
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR MEN. SENATOR MEN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. I NEVER HAD
BEFORE. KERN IN MEMORY TODAY OF
LINDA NEARING WE'RE GONNA WOODS
IS DEMOCRATIC CLUB PRESIDENT
FROM CALIFORNIA'S THIRTY SEVEN
SENATE-DISTRICT. WHEN  WAS A
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZER TURNED
DEMOCRATIC PARTY LEADER WITH A
DECADES LONG COMMITMENT TO OUR
COMMUNITY. HE'S A RELENTLESS
ADVOCATE ALWAYS WILLING TO ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES AND DO THE HARD
WORK. A TEN YEAR SHE DOUBLED
HER LOCAL THEM CLUBS MEMBERSHIP
RECRUITED IN ENERGIZED
VOLUNTEERS AND REGISTERED A
SLEW OF NEW LAGUNA WOODS
RESIDENTS. INTO THE DEMOCRATIC
CLUB WE'RE GOING TO WOODS. FOR
THESE EFFORTS AND MORE LINDA
WAS AWARDED THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF ORANGE COUNTY'S MOST
PRESTIGIOUS HONOR. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TRUMAN LIFETIME
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD. LINDA IT WAS
NOT ONLY AN AMAZING ACTIVISTS
AND PRESENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY
HE WAS A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE. I
STILL REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME I
MET HER. FIRST TIME I VISITED
LIMóN WAS DEMOCRATIC CLUB.
HE'S THE SECOND PERSON I MET. I
DIDN'T KNOW A SINGLE SOUL OTHER
THAN HER- AT THAT POINT THEY
WERE TALK ON THE PHONE A LITTLE
BIT. AND SHE REALLY ME WITH
JUST THIS ENORMOUS SMILE IN A
BIGGER HUG. AND THAT WAS THE
TYPE OF PERSON LINDA WAS JUST
SOMEONE WHO WAS SO FRIENDLY SO
FULL OF LIFE- AND I THINK OUR
HISTORY CALLS ON US TO COMPLETE
HER UNFINISHED BUSINESS. TO
STAY INVOLVED TO STABILIZE
VIGILANT. CANNOT ONLY IMAGINE
BETTER BUT TO DO OUR BEST TO
ACTIVATE OUR COMMUNITIES. I
HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME IN
REMEMBERING ONE OF OUR OWN
MAKING UP THIS MANTLE HONOR
LINDA'S LEGACY. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO TURN IN MEMORY OF FORMER
FORMER ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF
SANDRA HUTCHENS. AS ORANGE
COUNTY'S SHERIFF SHERIFF
HUTCHENS BLAZED A TRAIL AS OUR
COUNTY'S FIRST FEMALE SHERIFF.
WHEN SHE ANSWERED THE CALL TO
SERVICE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NATIVE.
HUTCHINS GRADUATED FROM THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
ACADEMY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX. AND WHILE SHE WAS THE
FIRST OF MANY THINGS HE BEGAN
HER LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER AS A
DEPUTY IN THE COUNTY JAILS AND
ON PATROL IN LYNNWOOD. THROUGH
THE DECADES HE CLIMBED THE
RANKS. BREAKING DOWN BARRIERS
AS A DEPUTY SERGEANT
LIEUTENANT. CAPTAIN COMMANDER
AND DIVISION CHIEF FOR THE
OFFICE OF HOMELAND SECURITY. IN
THESE ROLES SHARE HUTCHINS
RECEIVED COUNTERTERRORISM
TRAINING IN ISRAEL. STUDIED
UNDER THE FBI NATIONAL ACADEMY
AND PARTICIPATED IN THE
NATIONAL PREPAREDNESS
LEADERSHIP INITIATIVE PROGRAM
AT HARVARD UNIVERSITY. AFTER
RETIRING WITH THIRTY YEARS OF
SERVICE AT THE LOS ANGELES
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HERE
FUNCTIONS WAS ELEVATED BECOME
ORANGE COUNTY'S TOP COP.
LEADING DEPARTMENT OF OVER
THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED SWORN AND
PROFESSIONAL STAFF. IT WOULD BE
AN UNDERSTATEMENT TO SAY THAT
SHERIFF'S AUCTIONS PRESIDED
OVER THE DEPARTMENT AND ONE OF
THE MOST DIFFICULT TIMES IN ITS
HISTORY. WITH AN UNENVIABLE
TASK OF ROOTING OUT CORRUPTION
AND RESTORING PUBLIC TRUST FAIR
QUESTIONS AGAIN ROSE TO THE
CHALLENGE. BY ALWAYS PUTTING
PUBLIC SAFETY OF ORANGE COUNTY
FAMILY FOR. A MENTOR TO SO
MANY. QUESTIONS INDELIBLE MARK
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL BE
REMEMBERED BY ALL WHO SERVED
ALONGSIDE HER. OUR COMMUNITY
WILL FOREVER REMEMBER HER AS A
DEFENDER OF JUSTICE WHOSE RISE
TO LEADERSHIP INSPIRES US TO
ALSO RISE TO THE HIGHEST COUNTY.
THANK YOU SHARE SANDRA HUTCHENS
FOR A LIFETIME OF SERVICE.
POLITICS I WOULD LIKE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY TODAY OF
GEORGIA IN ORDER. ON OCTOBER
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY
THREE. GEORGETTE WAS BORN IN
THE MANZANAR WAR RELOCATION
CENTER. ONE OF THE TEN JAPANESE
INTERNMENT CAMPS THAT CAME OVER
A HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND MEN
WOMEN AND CHILDREN. FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF HER LIFE
GEORGETTE AND HER FAMILY WERE
PRISONERS OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT. AND YET. MAYBE IN
SPITE OF OR PERHAPS BECAUSE OF
THIS EXPERIENCE. GEORGETTE WENT
ON TO OVERCOME INJUSTICE
PURSUING A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
CAREER. IN PUBLIC SERVICE THAT
CAME TO DEFINE OUR STATE
CAPITOL. BOTH INSIDE THIS
BUILDING AND OUT. PAUL GEORGE'S
CAREER IS MARKED BY COUNTLESS
ACCOLADES IT WILL FOREVER BE
ENSHRINED BY HER MENTORSHIP AND
PASSION FOR GREATER
REPRESENTATION IN THE HALLS OF
POWER. AND FOR ME PERSONALLY
THIS IS REALLY GORGEOUS LEGACY.
TWO GENERATIONS OF API'S
WORKING IN PUBLIC SERVICE
GEORGETTE WAS THE PIONEER THAT
INSPIRED US TO ANSWER THE CALL
THE SERVICE. IT'S THIS LEGACY
THAT MAKES EACH OF OUR STORIES
POSSIBLE. NOW IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO HONOR
GEORGETTE. BY CONTINUING TO
FORCE THE PORTRAYAL SHE PLAYS
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS TO COME
AND BRING OTHERS WITH US.
LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF THE THIRTY NINE
HUNDRED AND FOUR LIVES LOST THE
COVERT NINETEEN IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WE STAND HERE TODAY AT
A GRIM POINT IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY. AS WELL OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN LOST THE COPA NINETEEN.
WITH OVER THREE FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION REPORTED CASES. WHILE
WE CAN CALCULATE THE PANDEMIC'S
ECONOMIC COSTS IN TERMS OF
ABSTRACT STATISTICS AND
FIGURES. WHAT WE CANNOT MEASURE
IS THE GRIEF FOR THE LIVES THAT
WERE TAKEN TOO SOON FROM US.
TODAY WE REFLECT ON THOSE WERE
FORCED TO SAY GOODBYE. NOT EVEN
IN PERSON BUT THERE A SCREEN OR
OVER THE PHONE. WE REFLECT ON
THE DOCTORS AND NURSES WHO
STATED THE BAD SIDES OF THESE
LOVED ONES. FOUR TWO SIX THREE.
WE HOLD IN OUR HEARTS AND
MEMORIES OF GRANDFATHERS AND
GRANDMOTHERS. FATHERS AND
MOTHERS AUNTS AND UNCLES
BROTHERS AND SISTERS COLLEAGUES
AND FRIENDS AND ALL THOSE LOST
BEFORE THEIR TIME. TO EVERY
PERSON TOUCHED BY THIS VIRUS.
KNOW THAT YOU ARE NOT ALONE
YOUR COMMUNITY OUR COMMUNITY
GRIEVES WITH YOU AND PRAISE
THAT YOUR MEMORIES MAY ONE DAY
BRING COMFORT. UNTIL THAT DAY
COMES WE PRAY FOR A SWIFT END
TO THIS TERRIBLE TERRIBLE
PLAGUE. AND REAFFIRM OUR PLEDGE
TO STOP THE SPREAD. VACCINATE
WHEN WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
AND REMEMBER THAT WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER. THANK YOU
MENTORED. SENATOR MAN PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK SO
THAT THEY MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE. SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR NIELSEN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE. I WOULD ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN AN HONOR TODAY. ONE OF
OUR OWN. STAND STATE. A LEGEND
IN THE NORTH STATE WHO SERVED
EIGHTEEN YEARS. IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. SENATE STATION WAS A
MILITARY VETERAN THE GRADUATE
OF CHICO HIGH SCHOOL. HE CAME
BACK FROM SERVICE. THE SERVICE
IN THE BROADCASTING BUSINESS. A
LONG TIME HAVE STEADY HANDS.
CHECK OUT TO BECAUSE TV STATION.
THAT AS WELL A FREQUENT
COMMENTER. ON RADIO STATIONS
THROUGHOUT. FEATURE A VERY
SPECIAL COMMITTEE SET UP BY A
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN. TO HONOR
THE BROADCASTING COMMUNITY IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY. HE ALSO
KERRY'S AND HAD SIGNED INTO LAW
SOME NINETY LEGISLATIVE BILLS.
THE HALLMARK OF WHICH I WOULD
SAY. WAS A BILL DID PASS THE
STATE ASSEMBLY LATER DID NOT
GET THROUGH THE SENATE PASSED
THE STATE ASSEMBLY TO DIVIDE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BY A
CONSTITUTIONAL VOTE. AT THE
NORTH. AND SOUTH. IT STANDS
STATE THEM ALWAYS CHAMPIONED.
THE RESIDENTS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. HE ALSO WAS A
PIONEER AND DRIVING UNDER THE
INFLUENCE LEGISLATION.
PRESIDENT REAGAN NAMED HIM AS A
LIFETIME MEMBER OF THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMISSION ON DRUNK
DRIVING. HE WAS VERY DEDICATED
TO TRY TO ENSURE THAT OUR
HIGHWAYS STREETS AND BYWAYS.
FOR SAFER BY NOT HAVING SO MANY
DRUNK DRIVERS. COMMUTING ON.
STAN LEFT US AUGUST FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY. IT IS MODEL WAS
LIFE MAKE IT WHAT WE CAN MOMENT
BY MOMENT. STAN REVERBERATE
DATED WHAT'S FULLEST AND GAVE
BACK TO HUMANKIND EVERY DAY TO
HIS FOLLOWERS. HE'S TO BE
REMEMBERED BY HIS WIFE LORETTA
RULETA. HE HAS A DAUGHTER
JENNIFER THE SON DEVON.
STEPDAUGHTERS JESSICA. AND
JANICE STEPSONS ERIC AND
STEPHEN MANY GRANDCHILDREN AND
GREAT CHEN GRANDCHILDREN. TRULY
A MAN OF THE LEGISLATURE MAN OF
THE NORTH STATE. TRULY A GOOD
HUMAN BEING ASSEMBLYMAN STAND
STATE ROOM WE WILL MISS YOU.
BOTH FURTHER ASKED LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THAT WE HONOR THE
MEMORY. DEPUTY SHERIFF ADAM
GIBSON. SACRAMENTO COUNTY. A
SIX YEAR VETERAN OF THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DEPUTIES THE
SHERIFF'S OFFICE. WHO WAS
MURDERED JANUARY EIGHTEENTH IN
THE LINE OF DUTY. HE DIED IN
THE HOSPITAL. TRYING TO RECOVER
FROM THOSE TERRIBLE WOUNDS.
ANOTHER DEPUTY WAS WOUNDED
ALONG WITH HIM AS WELL. THIS IS
CANINE RILEY. HE WAS A ROLE
MODEL THE GOOD MAN THE TRIBUTE
TO HIM THAT THIS MEGA CHURCH IN
THE NORTHERN NORTHERN
SACRAMENTO AREA. WAS FILLED TO
THE BRIM. A GRIEVING CITIZENS
AND FAMILY. AND OFFICERS.
REPORTER TO HONOR HIM. A MARINE
VETERAN. THE BRONZE STAR
WINNER- HONOREE IN THE SERVICE.
WITH A MAJOR INCIDENT REVENUE
CONVEYED TO HIM IN NINETEEN OR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT IS FOR
BEING A PART OF A MAJOR
MILITARY ACTION. PLEASE BEHIND
HIS WIFE RACHEL GIPSON. NINE
MONTH OLD DAUGHTER SOPHIE. HIS
PARENTS DOUG AND SANDY GIPSON.
AND SEVERAL SIBLINGS. AS I
MENTIONED THESE MANY WHO
ATTENDED. THE SERVERS. THERE
WAS A VERY SPECIAL PART OF THAT
SERVICE. THAT I BELIEVE THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME I'VE EVER
EXPERIENCED. NOBODY TURNS OUT
MORE TO HONOR THEIR FALLEN. THE
FIRE SAFETY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ON THIS OCCASION. AT THE VERY
ENDING THOSE PEOPLE ARE EXITING.
SOMEWHERE THERE ABOUTS NOT
VISIBLE TO THE ATTENDEES. BUT
THE K. NINE UNIT. BEGAN THEIR
BARKING TRIBUTE THE DEPUTY
SHERIFF. GIPSON I'LL NEVER
FORGET THAT. AND WE SHOULD
NEVER FORGET DEPUTY GIPSON. MAY
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE IN MEMORY
ALLEN BUT NONE OF. TELL AN
ATTENDED MIRAMONTE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN ARDEN MIDDLE SCHOOL
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA. HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH STAGE FOUR HIGH
RISK NEUROBLASTOMA. WHEN HE WAS
ONLY THIRTEEN YEARS OLD. THIS
YOUNG HERO. BATTLED CANCER FOR
FOUR YEARS STEADFASTLY.
CONFIDENCE WITH OPEN ALWAYS
LOOKING FORWARD. HE ROLLED AT
JESUIT HIGH SCHOOL. WITH HIS
STORY THERE AT THAT JESUIT
SCHOOL. INSPIRING FAMILY AND
PEERS. HIS FELLOW STUDENTS. AND
THE WHOLE SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY
KNOLLS NEW THE TALE OF HIS
VALIANT STRUGGLE. HE DID NOT
COMPLAIN. HE NEVER GAVE UP. HE
ALWAYS SMILED. HAD A POSITIVE
ATTITUDE. NO MATTER WHAT THE
PAIN HE WAS SUFFERING AND
DURING. HE CONTINUED A SLIGHT.
CAPITAL HE EVEN. IT SET UP A
CALL A FILTER TO MILK CHALLENGE.
THE RADIATION SOME FUNDS. TO
HELP FELLOW AFFECTED. YOUNG
STUDENTS. THE ORDER IN THE
HOSPITAL. DEALING WITH THEIR
OWN CHALLENGES. HE BOUGHT VIDEO
GAMES. THE RECALL FIRE STICKS
FOR THEM. AS HE STRUGGLED IN
WITH HIS OWN CHALLENGES. HE WAS
EVER MINDFUL OF OTHERS WHO ARE
SIMILARLY CHALLENGED. IN A
LETTER POSITIVELY WITH
CONFIDENCE THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE.
HE PASSED AWAY JANUARY TWENTY
FIFTH. THE YOUNG AGE OF
SEVENTEEN. BUT WITH ALL THOSE
SEVENTEEN YEARS FILLED WITH
CONTRIBUTIONS WITH KINDNESS AND
LOVE. HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS
MOTHER CHRISTINE TWO BROTHERS
STRATTON AND TREVOR A SISTER.
ACTUALLY HE ALSO LEAVES BEHIND
HIS BEST FRIEND THE FRENCH
BULLDOG. TRAFFIC WHO NEVER LEFT
HIS SIDE MAY WE HONOR ALLEN
MANADO BY THE LORD FIND A PLACE
IN HIS HOUSE OF MANY MANSIONS
IN HEAVEN. WITHOUT THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON PLEASE MAKE SURE
YOU BRING THOSE TEAMS FORWARD
SO THEY CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT I'D LIKE TO
INVITE UP SENATOR- CHILL BOKE.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. I RISE TO
CHURN IN MEMORY OF TERRY SPENCE
WHO WAS BECAUSE AT THE SCITUATE
OF MINE FROM BIG BEAR TERRY WAS
WELL KNOWN AMONG THE VETERAN U.
S. FOREST SERVICE FOLKS FOR HIS
THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF SERVICE
BETWEEN. NINETEEN SIXTY TO
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN. HIS
SERVICE BEGAN IN HIS YOUTH WE
CLEARING TRAILS AND CONTINUED
WITH SMOKE JUMPING AND FIGHTING
FIRES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. UNTIL
HE RETIRED AS A GS NINE FOREST
RANGER. HIS LEGACY IN
ENCOURAGING THE FOUNDING OF CAP
MORNING STAR HAS RESULTED IN
THE RICHMOND OF NUMEROUS
CHILDREN SLICE. HE WAS ALSO A
MEMBER OF SPECIAL SERVICES AND
IN THAT ONE HUNDRED AND FIRST
AIRBORNE IN VIETNAM. HE COULD
NAME EVERY FOREST SERVICE ROAD
TELL YOU FUN STORIES OF THE
FOUNDING FIGURES AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN BIG BEAR AND TEACH
YOU BEAUTIFUL LESSONS ABOUT BIG
BEARS FOREST. OUR COMMUNITY
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY THANK YOU.
I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF PASTOR BOB BRYANT
PASTOR BRIAN PASSED AWAY LATE
LAST YEAR DUE TO SEVERE COLD AT
NINETEEN RELATED COMPLICATIONS.
HE WAS A VALUED MEMBER OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE COMMUNITY WHERE
HE SERVED AS AN ASSOCIATE
PASTOR WATER OF LIFE COMMUNITY
CHURCH. OUR CHURCH WHICH IS
ABOUT TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
MEMBER STRONG. HE HAD BEEN WITH
THE CHURCH FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS
BEGINNING HIS MINISTRY AS A
YOUTH PASTOR. FROM THERE HE
SERVED IN MANY KEPT DIFFERENT
CAPACITIES INCLUDING TIME
SERVING IN THE CHURCH HEALING
DEPARTMENT WHERE HE CARED FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING
FINANCIALLY. MEMBERS OF HIS
CONGREGATION DESCRIBED HIM AS
THE MOST LOVING GENTLE KIND
ENCOURAGING UP LIFTING PERSON
YOU WOULD EVER WANT TO BE
AROUND. HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS
LOVING WIFE LORI AND CHILDREN
MISSY JACOB JORDAN AND JOSH.
HIS ABSENCE WILL BE FELT IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT HIS IMPACT WILL
LIVE ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- CHOI BOGUE. SENATOR
PAT ON. SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR
NEWMAN PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY BASED. SO OKAY. STATE
SENATOR NEWMAN. MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE TO JOURNEY MEMORY OF
ZERO P. ROSEN PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY HOOSIERS CAL STATE
FULLERTON FORTY YEARS AND HE
DIED JULY FIFTEENTH AT THE AGE
OF SEVENTY EIGHT AFTER A LONG
AND VALIANT BATTLE WITH CANCER
DURING HIS TIME AT THE
UNIVERSITY BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE JERRY ROSEN
TAUGHT THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
COLLEAGUES RECALL HOW MUCH YOU
LOVE CAL STATE FULLERTON AND HE
REMAINED INVOLVED WITH THE
UNIVERSITY EVEN BEYOND HIS
RETIREMENT. REGULARLY RETURNING
FOR SUCH EVENTS AS FOUNDING
TITANS FOR UNITS AS A SCHOLAR
JERRY ROSEN IS REMEMBERED FOR
HIS GROUNDBREAKING STUDY OF
CHICANOS AND ACTIVISM THE
CHICANO STUDENTS IN LOS ANGELES
LONGITUDINAL STUDY IN WHICH SHE
INTERVIEWED STUDENT ACTIVISTS
INVOLVED WITH THE CHICANO
MOVEMENT IN LOS ANGELES IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND THEN
AGAIN TEN YEARS LATER IS HOUSED
IN THE UNIVERSITY'S LAWRENCE TO
GRAB CENTER FOR ORAL AND PUBLIC
HISTORY. HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS
WIFE AND BEST FRIEND OF FIFTY
FIVE YEARS BARBARA HIS SON
DAVID AND DAUGHTER IN LAW GENET
ROSEN HIS BELOVED GRANDCHILDREN
MIRABELLA ENJU ROSEN HIS SISTER
MAUREEN ROSEN RAINS AND HER
HUSBAND TONY AND A WONDERFUL
FAMILY OF NIECES AND NEPHEWS
HIS MISSED VERY MUCH AND. I
ASKED THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY
IN HIS MEMORY. PRESIDENT I RISE
TO A JURY MEMORY OF JOSEPH
NAPOLI WHO PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY NINTH AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY SIX AFTER A LONG AND
VALIANT BATTLE WITH CANCER.
CHAU CON JOSEPH CONRAD NAPOLI
WAS BORN OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE. HE MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT. A GRADUATE OF THE
INGLEWOOD HIGH SCHOOL HE EARNED
A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE FROM UC
BERKELEY AND AN MBA FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY AND A LAW
DEGREE FROM LOYOLA UNIVERSITY.
HE WAS A PROUD ARMY VETERAN AND
SERVICE ADVANCEMENT PLAYING THE
TRUMPET IN THE FIFTH DIVISION
AND EIGHTY SECOND ARMY BANDS.
JOE NAPOLI HAD A LONG
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSIONAL
CAREER BEGINNING AS AN ENGINEER
AT UNITED AIRLINES THAN
ESTABLISHING HIS OWN CONSULTING
BUSINESS. AND FINISHING OUT HIS
PROFESSIONAL LIFE AS A
PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH. HE
ENJOYED LIVING THE GOOD LIFE IS
A TWENTY FIVE YEAR RESIDENT
LAGUNA BEACH AND HAD MANY GREAT
ADVENTURES TRAVELING THE WORLD
WITH HIS LOVELY AND IF
CALIFORNIAN WAY FOR SIXTY FIVE
YEARS. LOUISE HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS TWO CHILDREN VALERIE AND
JOE JUNIOR AS WELL AS THEIR
RESPECTIVE SPOUSES PAUL. AND
LILY HE WILL BE MISSED VERY
MUCH AN ASSET WE ADJOURNED
TODAY IN HIS MEMORY. MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO A JURY
MEMBER OF CHARLES LAUREN DAHLE
PASSED AWAY ON APRIL TWENTY
FOURTH OF LAST YEAR. AFTER A
LONG AND VALIANT BATTLE WITH
THROAT CANCER. CHARLES LAUREN
DAHLE KNOWN TO HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AS LAUREN WAS BORN IN
PORTLAND OREGON ON AUGUST
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO. HE
GRADUATED FROM SOUTH EUGENE
HIGH SCHOOL AND WAS EDUCATED AS
AN ELECTORAL ELECTRICAL
ENGINEER AT OREGON STATE
UNIVERSITY. AFTER GRADUATION HE
SERVED AS AN ENGINEER IN THE
NAVAL YARD IN BREMERTON
WASHINGTON. AFTER COMPLETION OF
HS NAVY SERVICE LAUREN WENT O
TO EARN A PHD IN BUSINESS FROM
PURDUE UNIVERSITY. AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS AS A PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF BRITISH
COLUMBIA. HE INITIATED A SERIES
OF THREE COMPUTER BUSINESSES
BEFORE LAUNCHING LCP TRACKER A
COMPUTER SOFTWARE COMPANY BASED
IN ORANGE CALIFORNIA. AND
NURTURED ITS GROWTH FROM THE
ORIGINAL THREE EMPLOYEES TO
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED. LAWRENCE
INTEREST INCLUDED HIS DEVOTION
TO FAMILY AND A PASSION FOR
READING SCIENCE FICTION AND
FANTASY. HE WAS A WINNING
BRIDGE PLAYER A FAN OF TV
MYSTERY SERIES A DEVOTED
STUDENT OF PROGRESSIVE POLITICS
AND NAVAL HISTORY. AND IT WAS
JUST A TRAVELER WHO HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF VISITING THIRTY
FIVE COUNTRIES OVER TIME. LORD
ALSO HELPED STEER THE COURSE OF
THE MUSEUM OF TEACHING AND
LEARNING KNOWN AS MODEL WHICH
IS BASED IN FULLERTON. AND
SERVING FOR ELEVEN YEARS AS
MOTAL SECRETARY AND IS A MEMBER
OF ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS BELOVED WIFE
CREDIT NAGEL HIS CHILDREN RYAN
AND CARRICK DAUGHTER IN LAW
STACY. STEP CHILDREN CHRISTINE
AND PAUL AS WELL AS
GRANDCHILDREN JADE AND JOSHUA
AND GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER AUBREY.
LORRIES MISSED VERY MUCH BY ALL
WHO KNEW AND LOVED HIM AND I
ASKED. WE ADJOURN TODAY IN HIS
MEMORY. PRESIDENT I RISE TO
JOIN IN MEMORY OF THREE MEMBERS
OF THE SAME FAMILY. MARTHA OVER
TENNESSEE ALVAREZ NESTOR ANNUAL
ALVAREZ. AND WE'RE MARIO
ALVAREZ JUNIOR. ALL CRUELLY
TAKEN FROM US IN THE SPAN OF A
FEW SHORT MONTHS BY THE VERY
SAME KILLER. THE SARS CO TWO
VIRUS ALSO KNOWN AS COVERT
NINETEEN. MARK THE RETENTION.
BORN ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT IN MEXICO
AND MEXICO AND MIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE TO REUNITE WITH
HER HUSBAND TOMORROW. AND BEGIN
A NEW LIFE TOGETHER IN THE
UNITED STATES. MARTHA WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD HER ENTIRE LIFE
CLEANING HOMES TO HELP PROVIDE
FOR HER FAMILY TOGETHER MARTIN
BUT MORROW SET THEIR EYES ON
THE UNITED STATES WITH THE HOPE
OF PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
THEIR CHILDREN FOR THEIR
CHILDREN THAT THEY HAD NOT
ENJOYED BACK HOME. SHE WAS THE
PROUD MOTHER OF FIVE CHILDREN
IN A BELOVED AUNT AND GODMOTHER
TOO MANY. IN OBTAINING HER U.
S. CITIZENSHIP BYE BYE SAVING
ENOUGH TO PURCHASE HER OWN HOME
AND THE SUCCESS OF EACH OF HER
CHILDREN MARTHA'S LIFE STANCE
IS VIVID PROOF OF HOW HARD
WORKING IMMIGRANTS. CAN CANNOT
JUST STRIP SURVIVE. BUT WILL
INDEED THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA. MR
DANIEL. WAS BORN ON SEPTEMBER
NINTH NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IN
ORANGE CALIFORNIA. NESTOR GREW
UP IN THE CITIES OF FULLERTON
ANAHEIM AND GARDEN GROVE. AS A
BOY HE LOVED PLAYING SOCCER AND
pBY THE TIME HE BEGAN HIGH
SCHOOL MISTER HAD GROWN INTO A
STELLAR MULTI SPORT ATHLETE.
EXCELLING IN FOOTBALL AND
THROWING THE SHOT PUT AND THE
DISCUS. NASSAR WORKED HARD AND
HELD MANY JOBS THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE BUT TOWARDS THE END OF HIS
LIFE HE ENJOYED BEING A DRIVER
MOST. TO THOSE WHO HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING THIS YEAR
HE WAS A BELOVED JOKESTER HUMOR
WHICH IS DEFINING QUALITY. AS
WAS COMPASSION IN NESTOR WAS A
SHOULDER TO CRY ON FOR SO MANY.
HE WAS THE BEST A GIFT GIVERS.
ALWAYS ON THE LOOKOUT FOR
UNIQUE OBJECTS OR SUBSCRIPTIONS
TO GIVE TO HIS NEPHEW TO ME
DOTED ON. AN AVID SPORTS FAN
NESTOR LOVE ROOTING FOR HIS
BELOVED LOS ANGELES DODGERS.
AND RAMS. HIS BROTHER BORN ON
SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR. TOMORROW OLIVAREZ
IN ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA. WAS THE
FOURTH A BILL MORROW AND MARTHA
ALVAREZ HAS FIVE CHILDREN. A
HUGE FAN OF MUSIC BILL MORROW
ATTENDED THE MUSICIANS
INSTITUTE IN HOLLYWOOD. TO
LEARN THE PRODUCTION SIDE OF
MUSIC FOR HIM MUSIC WAS A
PASSION. AND A THERAPEUTIC
ESCAPE. IN ADDITION DOUBLE MAS
LOVE OF MUSIC HE ALSO LOVE TO
COOK FOR HIS FAMILY. AND BECAME
HIS EXTEND THE EXTENDED
FAMILIES TAMALE MAKER EVERY
CHRISTMAS. TOMORROW DREAMS OF
OPENING UP A CATERING BUSINESS
AFTER THE PANDEMIC ENDED HIS
FAVORITE SPORTS TEAMS WERE THE
ANGELS AND THE FORTY NINERS.
AND BILL MORROW TRULY LOVE
SUPPORTING THESE TEAMS TOMORROW
HAD INFECTIOUS LAUGH. AT HIS
PERSONALITY ELIMINATED EVERY
ROOM HE STEPPED INTO. HIS EASY
GOING DEMEANOR AND SHARP WIT
MADE HIM A JOY TO BE AROUND.
NESTOR INTO MORROW ALVAREZ
JUNIOR BOTH PASSED AWAY FROM
COMPLICATIONS TO CODE RELATED
TO COVE IN. ON THE VERY SAME
DAY JANUARY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITHIN THE SAME
HOUR. AT TWO DIFFERENT ORANGE
COUNTY HOSPITALS. COVER THEN
TOOK THEIR BELOVED MOTHER
MARTHA IT JUST OVER A MONTH
LATER. ON FEBRUARY FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. NO FAMILY
SHOULD HAVE TO BEAR THE PAIN
THE ALVAREZ FAMILY HASN'T
TOWARD. AND OUR HEARTS TRULY GO
OUT TO THEM THE DEATHS OF
MARTHA. NESTOR IN TOMORROW
ALVAREZ LEAVE A HUGE VOID. IN
BOTH THEIR FAMILIES AND OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THEY WILL BE
SORELY MISSED. I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURNED. TODAY AND THEY'RE
LOVING MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. PLEASE
BRING THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO
THEY CAN BE PROPERLY MORE
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR PAN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
YOUR DAD. SENATE STATE. SENATOR
PAM THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
IT IS WITH A HEAVY HEART AND
MUCH SADNESS THAT IT RISE TO
CHURN IN MEMORY OF LAWRENCE
LARRY THE NOTE THE THIRD TO
PASS WITH CODE LAST DECEMBER HE
WAS A VALUED MEMBER AN ASSET TO
THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY THIRTY
BEGAN HIS CAREER AS A STUDENT
ASSISTANT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF THE HEALTH
LANSING CERTIFICATION HE THEN
MOVED ON TO THE DEPARTMENT
GENERAL SERVICES IN THE OFFICE
OF FLEET AND ASSET MANAGEMENT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. THERE
IS QUICKLY RECOGNIZED FOR
SUFFICIENCY WAS PROMOTED TO
MANAGER OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
DIVISION IN THE STATE CAPITAL
YOU'LL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED FOR
HIS PROFESSIONALISM ATTENTION
TO DETAIL DEDICATION AND
SELFLESSNESS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
A CHURNING IN MEMORY OF A
MEMBER OF OUR SENATE FAMILY
LARRY LUNA. WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED. I RISE TODAY TO GERMAN
MEMORY OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPUTY ADAM GIPSON
WHO PASSED AWAY WHILE
PROTECTING SACRAMENTO END OF
WATCH JANUARY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. EXEMPLIFYING THE
BRAVE INDIVIDUALS TO PROTECT
AND SERVE OUR COMMUNITIES
DEPUTY SHERIFF ADAM GIBSON WAS
SERVING AS A CANINE OFFICER.
WHEN HE AND HIS FELLOW DEPUTY
ATTEMPTED TO DETAIN A BERKELEY
SUSPECT ON THE GROUNDS OF CALYX
BIO. FOLLOWING A CHASE W.
GIPSON CANINE PARTNER RILEY
WERE BOTH STRUCK AND MORTALLY
WOUNDED. THAT THE GIBSON JOINED
THE SECOND COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT TWENTY FOURTEEN
AFTER SERVING THE UNITED STATES
MARINE CORPS INCLUDING TWO
TOURS IN AFGHANISTAN. A
DECORATED OFFICER DEPUTY GIPSON
EARNED A SHARE OF OFFICE BRONZE
STAR FOR BRAVERY. IN A MAJOR-INCIDENT RENDON IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
DEPUTY ADAM GIPSON LOYAL
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY. OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTY AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WE SEND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FRIENDS AND FAMILY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN A JOURNEY. IN MEMORY OF
DEPUTY. ADAM GIPSON. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MMORY OF DEAN
MALCOLM VERY CALMING PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY TWENTY. AND ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LABOR LEADER
IN SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY DEAN
SERVED AS VICE PRESIDENT THE
SACRAMENTO CENTRAL LABOR
COUNCIL NORTHERN VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS PRESIDENT THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
PRESIDENT THE LOS RIOS COLLEGE
FEDERATION TEACHERS. DEAN
JOINED PSYCHOLOGY DEPARTMENT OF
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE IN
NINETEEN NINETY AND TIRELESSLY
ADVOCATED FOR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION THROUGHOUT HIS
PHENOMENAL CAREER SERVING
VARIOUS CAPACITIES IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS COLLEGE FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS INCLUDING IS
PRESENT FOR THE PAST SIXTEEN
YEARS. BEANS DEVOTION TO
TEACHING AND SERVICE WAS
INSPIRATIONAL CAN BE SEEN
THROUGH COUNTLESS STUDENTS HE
HELPED SHAPE INSPIRED THROWS
TEACHING CAREER LABOR
ACTIVITIES AND HIS UNION
STEWARDSHIP. WE EXPRESS OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE
AMERICANA FAMILY PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A JOURNEY AS AN HONOR OF
DIMERA CONNIE. I RISE TO CHURN
MEMORY OF GEORGETTE I'M MARA
WHO SADLY PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER SEVENTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
SEVEN. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LOST A REMARKABLE WOMAN AND
DEADLY LINK BY HERITAGE
VOCATION AND LIFELONG TIES TO
SACRAMENTO. FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
SERVICE CAREER AND PASSIONATE
ACTIVISM ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
EARNED THE INFIGHTING RESPECT
MANY CALIFORNIANS BOTH INSIDE
AND OUTSIDE OF THIS CHAMBER.
GEORGETTE WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
EIGHTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY THREE
IN THE MAN'S AMAR INTERNMENT
CAMP WHERE PARENTS GEORGE AND
DOROTHY BOTH SACRAMENTO NATIVES
OF JAPANESE DESCENT WERE
FORCIBLY INCARCERATED.
GEORGETTE BEGAN HER PUBLIC
SERVICE CAREER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN THE REST
OF THE RECEPTIONIST OWNING HER
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP SKILLS
IN THE DECADES AHEAD WORKING
FOR LEGISLATORS AND LATER THE
STATE SENATE INCLUDING THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE OFFICE OF
EIGHTY I AFFAIRS. WE THANK THEM
FOR SHARING HER TIME WITH US
AND EXPECT WE THANK HER FAMILY
FOR SHARING YOUR TIME WITH US
AND EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES UNDER PASSING PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE JOURNEY IN HONOR
OF GEORGIA. AMBER A- I RISE TO
JOURNAL MEMORY OF PARTLY WALTER
CAVANAGH. PARTLY JUNIORS BORN
IN NINETEEN THIRTY TO PARENTS
MILDRED JACOBS CAVANAUGH AND
PARTLY W. KAVANAUGH SENIOR A
LOCAL CIVIC LEADER AND FORMER
CITY MANAGER SACRAMENTO. A
GRADUATE OF SANTA CLARA SCHOOL
OF BUSINESS AND UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA YEAH. HE SINGS
COLLEGE OF LAW HE DEDICATED HIS
LIFE TO PROTECTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AS A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. BARTLEY
JUNIOR ENJOYED SPENDING TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY ESPECIALLY
UNDER ANNUAL VACATION TRIPS TO
LAKE TAHOE. HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED BY HIS FAMILY FIRST
KEEN WIT. SHARP MIND AND
UNPARALLELED LOYALTY. LET'S
REMEMBER PARTLY JUNIOR FOR
CIVIC ACHIEVEMENTS IN SERVICE
TO OUR STATE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE JOURNEY AND HIS MEMORY. I
RISE TO CHURN IN MEMORY OF JACK
L. LEVEL. JACK WAS A
DISTINGUISHED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT DEVOTED TO CIVIC.
DEVOTED CIVIC AND GREAT LABOR
LEADER THAT EARNED HIM THE
RESPECT AND ADMIRATION OF HIS
COLLEAGUES JACK BEGAN HIS
CAREER FIGHTING FOR WORKERS
RIGHTS WHEN HE ENTERED THE
GROCERY BUSINESS AT AGE
THIRTEEN AS A PART TIME GROCERY
CLERK FOR WRIGLEY MARKETS.
DURING THIS TIME JACK JOIN THE
RETAIL CLERKS UNION FOR WHAT
WOULD BECOME THE UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION LOCAL EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX RISING THROUGH THE
RANKS TO VARIOUS LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS REPRESENTING WORKING
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES CANADA ASIA AND EUROPE
FOR MORE THAN THIRTY YEARS.
AFTER HIS TIME AT USC W. JACK
BECAME THE PRESENT YOUR SEATS
C. W. FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WERE
MEMBERSHIP BROUGH ENORMOUSLY
BECAUSE OF JACK'S PERSONAL
MOTTO SOLIDARITY WORKS JACK WAS
A FIGHTER FOR LIVING WAGES
QUALITY HEALTHCARE AND
RETIREMENT DIGNITY FOR ALL HARD
WORKING PEOPLE. PLEASE JOIN ME
THE JOURNEY THE MEMORY OF TAX
LEVELS. I RISE TO JOURNAL
MEMORY OF NICOLE CONTRA COHEN
KAPOOR. THE CALL PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IN OAKLAND AT THE AGE OF
THIRTY EIGHT BUT THEIR LOVED
ONES AT HER SIDE. FOLLOWING A
YEAR LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER
THE CALL IS THE DAUGHTER OF
STEVE COHN. THE FORMER
SACRAMENTO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
AND VICE MAYOR. THE COLE'S BORN
IN KAISER MOVE MORRIS HOSPITAL
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AUGUST
SEVENTH NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINETEEN THE
COLD WINTER PARENTS ON THE G.
NINE SACRAMENTO SISTER CITY
TRIP TO CHINA WHERE SHE WAS AN
EXCELLENT PASSER FIRST CITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND CHURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF NICOLE. CONE
COOPER. I RISE TO JOURNEYMAN OF
DR DANNY ASPECTS WHO PASSED
AWAY ON SUNDAY SEPTEMBER
TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY AT THE
pAGE OF EIGHTY SIX AFTER A LONG
BATTLE WITH CANCER. DR OSHKOSH
SERVED AS CHIEF OF RADIOLOGY AT
CENTER GENERAL HOSPITAL IN
SACRAMENTO IS HOME FOR MORE
THAN FIFTY YEARS. DR OZ WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE CREATION
THE CALIFORNIA STATE RAILROAD
MUSEUM THAT OPENED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE NO THE FOUNDING
PRESIDENT OF THE SECOND- TRUST
RESTORED PRESERVATION. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY
OF DR DANI ASPECTS. TODAY I
RISE TO DURING MEMORY VALERIE
ONE BARKLEY WHO PASSED AWAY IN
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. A
TAKE A DEDICATED VOLUNTEER FOR
THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION AND
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY AND
WILL LOVE BY MEMBERS OF THE
SACRAMENTO COMMUNITY. VALLEY
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF ADOPTING
OLDER FOUNDATION A NINETEEN
YEAR OLD GROUP THAT SUBSIDIZES
HOUSING ARRANGEMENTS FOR
SENIORS. VALERIE SPENT HER LIFE
ADVOCATING FOR SENIORS IN OUR
COMMUNITY PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY AND THE MEMORY OF
VALERIE WONG PARKWAY. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF LISA
TERROR LACY. LISA WAS A
DISTINGUISHED. FOR COMPLIMENTS
EARNED HER THE RESPECT OF HER
COLLEAGUES AND ADMIRATION
COUNTLESS LIVES THAT SHE HAS
TOUCHED FORTY CHICAGO THE
CENTER PARENTS MOVED TO
SACRAMENTO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. AFTER ATTENDING SEKHEMRE
STATE UNIVERSITY LISA WENT ON
TO BECOME A RENOWNED PLAYWRIGHT
DIRECTOR ACTOR AND TEACHER. SHE
DEDICATED HER LIFE TO SHARING
HER PASSION FOR THE ARTS MOST
NOTABLY LISA WITH THE CO
CREATOR AND CO WRITER OF
CALIFORNIA'S MUSICAL THEATERS
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
PROJECT PRODUCTIONS KEEPING THE
DREAM ALIVE AND THE DREAM GOES
ON. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY
IN THE MEMORY OF LISA TERRIBLY
SEE. I RISE TO CHURN IN MEMORY
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND TWELVE AMERICANS HAVE DIED
OF IN NINETEEN AS OF FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. INCLUDING OVER FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. IT WAS
ALMOST EXACTLY A YEAR AGO TODAY
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH TWENTY
TWENTY THAT THE FIRST COVER
NINETEEN DEATH WAS REPORTED IN
THE NEWS THE UNITED STATES. AND
JUST ONE YEAR'S TIME OUR
NATION'S FAMILIES HAVE LOST
ALMOST AS MANY LOVED ONES TE
COVE IN NINETEEN. THAT THE
POPULATION. OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO WHICH IS CURRENTLY
FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT. ALMOST THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF MY HOMETOWN. LOST
IN ONE YEAR. IN OUR COUNTRY
PLEASE LET US REMEMBER THE
TREMENDOUS LOSS BY COMMITTING
THE FOLLOWING PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES TO STOP THE PANDEMIC
BUT WEARING A MASK AVOIDING
GATHERINGS AND GETTING TO COVER
TAXING WHEN YOUR TURN COMES LET
US SUPPORT AND COMFORT THE OVER
HALF A MILLION FAMILIES WHO
HAVE LOST A LOVED ONE TO THIS
TERRIBLE DISEASE. NINETY THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN PLEASE BRING
THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO THEY MAY
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
SENATE SENATOR PORTANTINO WHEN
YOU'RE READY. SENATOR
PORTANTINO. BETTER PRESIDENT
TODAY I RISE TO RESPECT TO MY
GOOD FRIEND MARGARET PAIN
FRAXINUS THE SENATE TO ADJOURN
IN HER MEMORY HE WAS A LONGTIME
RESPECTED COMMUNITY LEADER IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN MARGARET
WAS HONORED AS AMBASSADOR OF
THE YEAR BY THE LOCKING OUT OF
FLINT RIDGE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
FOR VOLUNTEERING THOUSANDS OF
HOURS HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
THE FOUNDING OF BOTH CLING ALL
OF PARK AND MAYORS DISCOVERY
PARK MARKET RECEIVED NUMEROUS
AWARDS FOR HER VOLUNTEER WORK
INCLUDING A CAMPFIRE GIRLS
LUTHER HALL THE GOOD LOOK AWARD
A PTA FOUNDERS DAY WITH
HONORARY SERVICE AWARD. AND THE
LESS TOPPER COMMUNITY SERVICE
AWARD FOR OUTSTANDING
COMMITMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY SHE
WORKED TIRELESSLY ON THE
PUBLICATION OF BIOLOGY
BIOGRAPHIES OF LOCKING OUT OF
FOOTBRIDGES MAYORS KNOWN AS OUR
CITY'S FORMER MAYOR SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
INCORPORATION BUT SHE PUT HER
MIND TO SOMETHING NO ONE COULD
SAY NO TO MARKET SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND AJ WHO
MISSES HER TERRIBLY AS DOES THE
ENTIRE EXTENDED FAMILY PLEASE
ADJOURNMENTS. I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF HARRIET HAMMONS SHE
WAS ONE OF A KIND. SHE WAS THE
MOST SENIOR PERSON IN THE
COMMUNITY SHE KNEW EVERYONE AND
EVERYONE KNEW. HARRY STATING
THAT HARRY ATTENDED ALMOST
EVERY EVENT IN THE CRESCENTA
VALLEY AND THEN LOCKING YADA IS
NOT AN EXAGGERATION. HARRIET'S
COMMUNITY LOVE AND SUPPORT.
WERE APPRECIATE APPRECIATED BY
EVERYONE HARRY WAS AN
INTERPRETER PART. OF MANY
ASPECTS OF COMMUNITY LIFE
SERVING YOUNG PEOPLE SCHOOLS
CHURCHES CLUBS PERFORMING CIVIC
ACTIVITIES AND PROVIDING
LEADERSHIP BY BRINGING HIGH
PRAISE TO THE CITY OF WALKING
OUT OF FLINT RIDGE. AND HER
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOODS HERE
NUMEROUS DISTINCTIONS AMONG
THEM THE UNITED METHODIST
CALIFORNIA PACIFIC CONFERENCE
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE AWARD AND
THE UNITED METHODIST WOMEN'S
NATIONAL SPECIAL MISSION AWARD.
SHE WAS A TWO TIME AMBASSADOR
OF THE YEAR AND SPIRIT AWARD
FOR THE LOCKING OUT A CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE SHE ALSO SERVED AS
A DIRECTOR OF THE MONTROSE
VERDUGO CITY VERDUGO CITY
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. AND WAS
HONORED WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
AWARD AND AN ENDEARMENT AWARD
IN BOTH TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AND
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. HARRY TO
SURVIVE BY HIDING AREA MARINO
AND JOHN PHILIP HAMMOND'S HER
SON AND DAUGHTER AND HER
BELOVED GRANDDAUGHTER GRACE
ELIZABETH MARINO. I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN THE SENATE IN THE
MEMORY OF COACH JIM BONDS.
MISTER BONDS WAS A STAR
QUARTERBACK WHO LED HEART HIGH
TO A CIF SOUTHERN SECTION
CHAMPIONSHIP IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX. HE WENT ON TO PLAY AT UCLA
HAS BEEN THE HEART AND SOUL OF
THE ST FRANCIS HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL TEAM FOR TWENTY YEARS.
HE DIED AFTER A LONG BATTLE
WITH CANCER. IN HIS TWENTY
YEARS AS HEAD COACH OF THE
GOLDEN KNIGHTS BONDS AMASSED A
RECORD OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
AND SEVENTY SIX HE GUIDED THE
TEAM TO TWO LEAGUE TITLES THE
CIF SOUTHERN SECTION DIVISION
THREE RUNNER UP PLAQUE. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND A
REMARKABLE NINETEEN PLAYOFF
APPEARANCES. FATHER TONY MARTY
COMMENTED THAT BONDS BELIEVED
IN THE VALUES HE TALKED ABOUT.
THE IN THE SENATE AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE FAMILY
THERE ARE MANY. WHO WORK WITH
US WHO HAD THEIR INSPIRATION
AND LEADERSHIP CREDITED THIS
COACH BONDS. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE TRICIA AND THEIR
CHILDREN JAMES A GRADUATE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO AND
KATIE WHO IS CURRENTLY IN
COLLEGE. AND HER BROTHER. AND
HIS BROTHER TOM. I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN THE SENATE IN HONOR
OF VICTOR ALLEN ROBINETTE. IN
EAST THIRTY YEARS AS A CPA PICK
ROBINETTE WAS DEDICATED TO HIS
MANY LOYAL CLIENTS WHO CAME
BACK YEAR AFTER YEAR YES. DO
THEIR TAXES BUT ALSO TO LAUGH
AND SHARE LIFE STORIES WITH
BACK DEDICATED TO HIS FAMILY
INTO HIS COMMUNITY VIC SERVICE
THE ELECTED CITY TREASURER OF
SOUTH PASADENA FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS. HIS OTHER CONTRIBUTIONS
TO SOUTH PASADENA INCLUDED A
WIRE SO COACH MEMBER AND PAST
PRESIDENT OF QANTAS HE LOVED
THE FOURTH OF JULY PANCAKE
BREAKFAST HE WAS ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER. AND TRUSTEE OF THE
SOUTH PASADENA PRESERVATION
FOUNDATION A BOARD MEMBER OF
HOLY FAMILY CHURCH FINANCE
COUNCIL A LONG TIME AN ACTIVE
MEMBER AND SUPPORTER OF THE
SOUTH PASADENA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. AND A MEMBER OF THE
ONEONTA CLUB HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS BELOVED WIFE GRETCHEN
ROBINETTE HIS TWO SONS PATRICK
AND SCOTT. HIS DAUGHTER IN LAW
JENNY AND ITS CHERISHED
GRANDSONS FINN AND WILL
ROBINETTE. PICKING BRACE LIFE
WITH AMAZING GUSTO SURROUNDED
HIS FAMILY AND FRIENDS WITH
GREAT WARMTH. DEDICATED LOVE
AND LAUGHTER. I RISE TODAY TO
JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE STATE SENATE
FAMILY- THE CRETA IS BELL SCOTT.
SHE IS THE FOURTH WIFE OF OUR
FORMER SENATE COLLEAGUE SENATOR
JACK SCOTT AND SHE PASSED AWAY
ON FEBRUARY SIXTH. THE CREATOR
WAS BORN JULY EIGHTEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY FAR NINETY
THIRTY FOUR TO AV AND RETTA IS
BELL. GROWING UP SHE LIVED IN
VARIOUS TOWNS BUT HOME BASE WAS
OUR BELOVED GRANDPARENTS HOME
IN FORT WORTH. SHE GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL IN ELK CITY
OKLAHOMA AS VALEDICTORIAN OF
HER CLASS HE THEN ENROLLED IN
ABILENE CHRISTIAN COLLEGE WHERE
SHE MET LIFELONG FRIENDS AND
HER HUSBAND JACK SCOTT. THEY
WERE MARRIED ON SEPTEMBER
SECOND NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
DURING THE EARLY YEARS O THEIR
MARRIAGE THE CREATOR WAS BUSY
RAISING THEIR FIVE CHILDREN
MANAGING THE HOUSEHOLD AND
ASSISTED HER HUSBND IN HIS-WORK. SHE RECEIVED HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM
PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY IN THEIR
LATER EARNED A MASTER'S DEGREE
FROM CAL STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH. SHE BEGAN HER CAREER AS
A PROFESSOR OF ENGLISH AT
CERRITOS COLLEGE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND CONTINUED FOR
TWENTY YEARS. THE CREE AND JACK
ENJOYED EXTENSIVE TRAVEL
VISITING THIRTY COUNTRIES AND
SHE WROTE A MONTHLY COLUMN FOR
THE PASADENA STAR NEWS ENTITLED
LIFE LESSONS. THE CRETA SURVIVE
PROVIDERS HUSBAND SENATOR
JACK'S GOT HER FOUR CHILDREN
THEIR SPOUSES ELEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWENTY EIGHT.
GRANDCHILDREN I RISE TODAY TO
INJURED IN MEMORY OF ERIC
ARCHER WHO IS AN ENGINEER AT
NASA'S JET PROPULSION
LABORATORY HE DIED ON JANUARY
NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
HE WAS SIXTY ONE YEARS OLD.
SIXTY ONE YEARS YOUNG. ERIC WAS
AN INTEGRAL MEMBER OF THE
ENGINEERING TEAM AT JPL UNTIL
HE WAS SIDELINED BY THE SAME
FORM OF BRAIN TUMOR THAT TOOK
US SENATORS JOHN MCCAIN. AND
TED KENNEDY. THE FINAL MISSION
ERIC WORKED ON WAS MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY PERSEVERANCE ROVER WHICH
JUST LANDED ON MARS LAST
THURSDAY. HE WAS INVOLVED IN
BUILDING AND TESTING THE
LANDING RADAR ELECTRONICS THE
GUIDED THE ROVER DURING ITS
FINAL POWER DESCENT PHASE PART
OF THE SEVEN MINUTES OF TERROR.
WHICH ULTIMATELY SOFT LANDING
ON THE SURFACE OF MARS. AT JPL
ERIC ALSO LED A TEAM OF
ENGINEERS DEVELOPING ACOUSTIC
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGIES
APPLICABLES TO DOWNHOLE
COMMUNICATIONS COMMERCIAL OIL
WELLS AND THROUGH ICE
COMMUNICATIONS I'M PROPOSED
INSTEAD PLANETARY OCEANS WORLD
LIKE JUPITER. LIKE JUPITER MOON
EUROPA HE WORKED ON THE ANTENNA
SUBSYSTEM FOR THE CASSINI
MISSION TO SATURN. HE TAPPED
HIS LIFELONG INTEREST IN HAM
RADIO TO WORK WITH JPL SECURITY
AND KUIP EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS VAN COVERING
MULTIPLE FREQUENCY BANDS FOR
MULTIPLE AGENCIES. THIS LED THE
INTEGRATED JPL AMATEUR HAM
RADIO CLUB INTO FORMALLY
PARTICIPATING IN JPL'S
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. WHEN HIS
DAUGHTER MARC TO SHOWED AN
INTEREST IN PLAYING SOCCER HE
LEARNED EVERYTHING THERE WAS
ABOUT SOCCER AND BECAME AN
ACTIVE COACH REFEREE AND
SECTION ADMINISTRATOR ALTHOUGH
HE HAD NEVER PLAYED THE GAME
HIMSELF. HE WAS ALWAYS A MAN
YOU CAN COUNT ON AND HE. LOVED
AND WAS LOVED BY MANY. I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
FORMER SIERRA MADRE MAYOR
GEORGE OF OUR- WE'RE SAD TO
ANNOUNCE THAT HE DIED ON
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MAYOR MARROW WAS
NINETY EIGHT YEARS OLD AND
SERVED FOR TWELVE YEARS AS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER AND THREE
TERMS AS MAYOR. DURING HIS
LIFETIME AIR AMERICA OMITTED
MUCH OF HIS TIME TO
VOLUNTEERING IN PUBLIC SERVICE
IN ADDITION TO SERVING ON THE
CITY COUNCIL AND PLANNING
COMMISSION HE WAS A MEMBER OF
THE SIERRA MADRE VOLUNTEER FIRE
DEPARTMENT FOR NINETEEN YEARS
AND ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
QANTAS CLUB. AN ICONIC LEGEND
OF SIERRA MADRE GEORGE MARROW
WAS AWARDED THE FIRST EVER
SIERRA MADRE LIFETIME SERVICE
AWARD AT THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SIERRA MADRE HONORS
AWARDS CEREMONY AT EVERY
CEREMONY SINCE THEN THE WARRANT
HAS BEEN ISSUED IN HIS NAME.
UNTIL RECENTLY MAYOR MAUER'S
OFTEN SEEN AROUND TOWN ON HIS
SCOOTER IN HIS NINETIES I WE
WAS ON A SCOOTER GEORGE MARRIED
LOVE SIERRA MADRE AND ALWAYS
HAD A WELCOMING SMILE AND THE
CITY'S RESIDENTIAL HISTORIANS
WELL REMEMBERED FOR HIS
KINDNESS WISDOM VOLUNTEERISM
AND CHAMPION OF MANY CAUSES. I
RISE TODAY TO DURING THE SENATE
IN ORDER OF OUR DOSHAS ARMAND
KRIKORIAN. AN AMAZING MAN WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY WELL WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY WHAT
GROWING UP IN IRAN ARMAAN
ATTENDED DON BOSCO CATHOLIC
SCHOOL IN THE NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY OF IRAN WHERE HE
EARNED A MASTERS OF ARTS DEGREE
IN ARCHITECTURE AND CITY
PLANNING. HIS PASSION FOR
ATHLETICS LED HIM TO JOIN A
RAND SAYS LET IT SCOUTING AND
CULTURAL ORGANIZATIONS WHERE HE
BLOSSOMED AS A BASKETBALL
PLAYER AND SERVED AS THE
CAPTAIN OF BOTH ALL RIGHT AND
NATIONAL UNIVERSITY OF RAND ALL
STAR TEAMS. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HE MARRIED DAUGHTER THE
LOVE OF HIS LIFE AND THEY WERE
BLESSED WITH TWO CHILDREN ARE
KEEN AND ALINA. HARMON AND HIS
FAMILY MOVED TO THE UNITED
STATES AND SETTLED IN GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA IN MY DISTRICT HE
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST TO JOIN
THE WHOLE MANAGEMENT GLENDALE
ARIZ CHAPTER WHEN IT WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND BECAME THE FIRST
CHAIRMAN OF THE CHAPTERS
DIVISION. HE LATER SERVED LATER
SERVED AS EXECUTIVE BOARD OF
THE IRAQ CHAPTER WITH TWO TERMS
AS ITS CHAIR WHO'S ALSO ELECTED
TO THE BOARD OF A MINUTE MAN
WESTERN USA AND LED THE
REGION'S ALL STAR TEAM FOR THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WORLD
BASKETBALL CHAMPIONSHIPS IN
MONTREAL. AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR HOME MANAGEMENT
ALL RIGHT CHAPTER FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HE
CULTIVATED INVALUABLE.
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
COMMUNITY. HIS HIS FAMILY
FRIENDS COLLEAGUES IN YOUTH
MENTOR WILL REMEMBER OUR MINDS
KIND AND HUMBLE PERSONALITY.
AND HIS TIRELESS SERVICE TO THE
COMMUNITY. I REALIZE TO
JOURNALING AND SENATOR
PORTANTINO. PLEASE BRING
RESUMES FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE THEM.
SENATOR RUBIO WHEN YOU'RE READY.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RIGHTS TO
RETURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED RESIDENTS WHO HAVE DIED
IN SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY TWO
IN THE PAST YEAR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM LOST THEIR
LIVES TO COVERT NINETEEN AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS LOST A FAMILY
MEMBER AND CLOSE FRIENDS LIKE
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES I KNOW
HOW PAINFUL THIS HAS BEEN AND I
WANT TO GIVE MY CONDOLENCES TO
ALL WHO HAVE LOST LOVED ONES IN
THIS TRAGIC LAST YEAR. AND I
WANT TO ALSO THANK THE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND FRONTLINE
WORKERS FOR BEING OUR COMMUNITY
HEROES I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
JOHN HOLLOWAY WHO DIED IN
SEPTEMBER ON SEPTEMBER. TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE AGE OF SEVENTY
THREE HE WAS A U. S. NAVY
VETERAN A LONGTIME COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF UP
WEDNESDAY MISTER HOLLOWAY WAS A
PERSONAL FRIEND SUPPORTER AND A
GREAT ADVOCATE FOR LIKE
WEDNESDAY. HE AND HIS WIFE
HILDA WERE MARRIED FOR FIFTY
YEARS HILDA WAS A FELLOW
TEACHER DURING THIS PANDEMIC HE
PARTNER WITH M A COMMUNITY
DONATION EVENTS THIS LAST
SUMMER WE HAD A DIAPER GIVEAWAY
AND I WAS GRATEFUL TO SPEND
MOMENTS WITH HIM. AND I SHARED
HOW MUCH I APPRECIATED HIM
MISTER HOLLOWAY SPENT THIRTY
YEARS AS AN AEROSPACE ANAGER
OF RAYTHEON HE RAN FOR CITY
COUNCIL IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
SERVICE MAYOR THREE TIMES AND
REPRESENTED THE CITY ON SEVERAL
REGIONAL BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. HE WAS A DEDICATED
AND HARDWORKING PUBLIC SERVANTS
WHO WILL BE MISSED MY
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE AND HIS
CHILDREN. I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF HECTOR
ELIZONDO E. HE DIED FEBRUARY.
OF THIS YEAR AT SEVENTY THREE A
VETERAN HE WAS A DEPUTY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR OF THE
CONGRESSWOMAN GRACE NAPOLITANO
FOR THE PAST ELEVEN YEARS I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF KNOWING HIM
WORKING WITH HIM AND SEEING HIS
PASSION IN EVERY THING HE DID
IN OUR COMMUNITY HE WORKED
CLOSELY WITH MY STAFF WHO
ALWAYS TALKED WITH HIM. ABOUT
COMMUNITY EVENTS AND HE WAS
VERY HELPFUL HE SERVED IN THE
UNITED STATES ARMY AND WHO ALSO
STRONGLY ADVOCATED FOR VETERANS
AND THEIR FAMILIES L. AS ALSO
THE CHAIR OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY VETERANS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. PREVIOUSLY WITH A
FORMER STAFFER WITH
CONGRESSWOMAN LUCILLE ROYBAL
ALLARD AND WORKED AS A
GOVERNMENT LIAISON FOR MANY
YEARS AT BUDWEISER BREWERY.
CONCEPTIONS OF THE SENATE
DISTRICT ARE FOREVER GRATEFUL
AND INDEBTED TO HECTOR HECTOR
IS SURVIVED BY HIS TWO SONS
EDWARD AND FILL UP IT DAUGHTER
IN LAW TWO GRANDCHILDREN. AND
HIS EX WIFE ELAINE. I GREW
TODAY INSTEAD TO TURN IN MEMORY
OF DODA BY THE- FROM THE CITY
EL HAMBRE WHO PASSED AWAY. ON
JANUARY AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY
SIX. LATER. I DAUGHTER WITH THE
SELF DESCRIBED P. T. MOM AND
AROUND FOR THE- HAMBURG UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD SERVING
FOR TWENTY YEARS FROM. NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT TO NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT WHEN SHE FIRST RAN
FOR THE SCHOOL BOARD SHE USED
THE SLOGAN SHE SAW PAINTED ON A
WALL WHEN SHE WAS VISITING
MEXICO IT READ GET IT ANY
NOTICE AT THE CAPITOL THE
TRANSLATION TO LOVE A CHILD IS
TO EDUCATE A CHILD WE SHARED
THE SAME PASSION FOR EDUCATION
AND SHE LEFT A LASTING LEGACY
IN OUR COMMUNITY. DOROTEA IS
SURVIVED BY HER TWO CHILDREN. I
RISE TODAY IN MEMORY OF FLORIDA
WALL THE FORMER RESIDENT FROM
BALDWIN PARK SHE PASSED AWAY IN
JANUARY AT THE AGE OF NINETY
FOUR. AFTER GRADUATING AS
VALEDICTORIAN FROM LA HOYA HIGH
SCHOOL. MRS WALL RECEIVED A
SCHOLARSHIP TO ATTEND
ALBUQUERQUE BUSINESS SCHOOL HE
LATER WORKED IN SOKOTO NEW
MEXICO WHERE SHE MET HER
HUSBAND CORD AND WALL AND-
WHERE THEY LATER MOVED TO
BALDWIN PARK. WHICH IS LOCATED
IN MY DISTRICT. FLORIDA WORKED
AT UNIVERSAL PLASTIC MOLD UNTIL
HER RETIREMENT IN AFTER HER
RETIREMENT MOVED TO
VICTORVILLE. FLUORIDE SURVIVED
BY TWO SISTERS MAGGIE CHáVEZ
UP UP WEDNESDAY IN MY DISTRICT.
AND HANDING OUT THE TERACE OF
BALDWIN PARK SON. RONALD WALL
OF ONTARIO FOR AWHILE WILL BE
SURE YOU MISSED AND HER.
FRIENDS AND FAMILIES. WILL ALSO
MISTER. I RISE TODAY TO ADDRESS
MEMORY JOHN A LITTLE SCHOOL
RESIDENT FROM THE CITY OF
BALDWIN PARK HE'S A KOREAN.
KOREAN WAR VETERAN MR IT ALSO
IS EIGHTY NINE YEARS OLD AND
PASSED AWAY IN DECEMBER. I
OFTEN SAW HIM MY COMMUNITY
EVENTS ESPECIALLY IF THEY WERE
RELATED TO RECOGNIZING OUR
VETERANS HE NEVER MESSED
VETERAN INVENTS AND ALWAYS WENT
OUT OF HIS WAY TO REACH OUT TO
ME AND GIVE ME A HUG. HIS LAST
REQUEST HIS CHILDREN WAS TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR MOTHER. HE
WAS A VERY KIND MAN AND SUCH A
LOVING COMMUNITY MEMBER HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE ITEM. SIX
CHILDREN FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
AND SEVEN GREAT GREAT CHILDREN.
I RISE TODAY WITH GREAT SADNESS
TO A TURN IN THE MEMORY OF THE
MEDIA. BUT PEAK WHO WORKED IN
THE CITY OF WEST COVINA AND
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
THREE TWO TO COVERT NINETEEN.
MRS BUT CREEK WAS A NURSE AT
QUEEN OF THE VALLEY HOSPITAL I
WITH COULD BE ENOUGH FOR NEARLY
THIRTY YEARS. MRS BUCKLEY
PIERCE RECALLED HER AS A
DEDICATED COMPASSIONATE HEALTH
CARE WORKER ANDA MOTHER.
FIGURE TO SO MANY WHO OFFERED
GUIDANCE TO NEW NURSES
ENCOURAGE THEM TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION AND ALWAYS MADE
SURE EVERYONE HAD SOMETHING TO
EAT. HE SPOKE THREE LANGUAGES
AND WAS ABLE TO CONNECT TO
PROVIDE CARE. TO SO MANY
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT MRS
BICKLEY ALWAYS KEPT HER TEAM
LAUGHING EVEN DURING THE
TOUGHEST TIME. HE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND NESTOR FOR THREE
CHILDREN TWO GRANDCHILDREN.
FOUR SISTERS AND TWO BROTHERS.
I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF GMO ROMERO'S RESIDENT
FROM THE CITY OF AZUSA WHO
PASSED AWAY. ON APRIL AT FORTY
SEVEN YEARS OF AGE MISTER
MERECE WITH A LOVING HUSBAND
FATHER GRANDFATHER A TRUCK
DRIVER WHO MARRIED HIS HIGH
SCHOOL SWEETHEART. HE WAS THE
ULTIMATE FAMILY MAN AND WAS
ALWAYS TRYING TO HELP HIS
FAMILY ACHIEVE THE AMERICAN
DREAM. MISTER MARISSA SURVIVED
BY HIS MOTHER FOR SIBLINGS HIS
WIFE SIX CHILDREN AND THREE
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF. LEADER GOOSE MON A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF ROAST
MEAT. THIS IS CHRIS MAN PASSED
AWAY IN JANUARY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY FIVE SHE WAS EXTREMELY
INVOLVED IN THE ROEMEAD.
SCHOOL DISTRICT PTA WAS ALSO
RETIRED EMPLOYEE OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON. THIS IS
BECAUSE MOM MADE A MAJOR IMPACT
WITH STUDENTS AND CONSTITUENTS
OF THE SENATE DISTRICT TWENTY
TWO. AND FOR THAT WE THANK HER.
BUT I AND I ALSO RISE IN MEMORY
OF GUILDFORD RATE BECAUSE MINE.
WAS ALSO A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE CITY OF ROAST MEAT. MISTER
BECAUSE MINE WAS A FORMER CITY
OF ROSE MEET PARKS AND
RECREATION EMPLOYEE. AS WELL AS
A FORMER EMT HE PASSED AWAY AT
THE AGE OF FORTY FIVE FROM KOBE
NINETEEN. JUST SEVEN DAYS
BEFORE HIS MOM ELITA- SMALL AND
DID. THE CRUISE MONTH THAT
FAMILIES WILL BE MISSED BY
THEIR FRIENDS FAMILY AND THE
ROSE MEET COMMUNITY. TODAY I
RISE IN MEMORY OF DAVID
HERNANDEZ GATOR. SIXTY SEVEN
YEARS OLD RESIDENT FROM THE
CITY OTTOM PART TO PASSED AWAY
THIS OCTOBER HE WAS A LONG TIME
BALLPARK RESIDENT OF OVER FORTY
YEARS AND HEAD COACH OF THE
SOCK BUN FRESHMAN SOFTBALL TEAM
AT BOLAND PARK HIGH SCHOOL.
DAVID WAS A MENTOR FOR SO MANY
OF OUR STUDENT ATHLETES AND I
KNOW THAT HE WILL LEAVE BEHIND
A LONG LASTING IMPACT AT EACH
OTHER LIFE'S. OUR RIGHTS TODAY.
THIRTY ONE IN MEMORY THE MISTER
MITCHELL WHO WAS A VETERAN
BLOOD MENTOR TEACHER AND COACH
TO MANY IN THE CITY OF WEST
COVINA COMMUNITY AN ARMY
VETERAN HE MARRIED HIS WIFE
PATRICIA NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
MOVING TO CONVENE A DURING THE
SAME YEAR HE WAS ONE OF THE
FIRST TO TEACH AND COACH AT
WEST COVINA HIGH SCHOOL DURING
HIS TENURE HE ALSO SERVED AS
VICE PRINCIPAL AND THE SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT COORDINATOR WHEN
HIS WIFE PATRICIA PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO HE RACES
CHILDREN TAKING ON THE ROLES OF
BOTH PARENTS AND ATTENDING ALL
SCHOOL AND SPORTING EVENTS
TINO'S LOSSES BATTLE TO CALLING
CANCER KIDNEY FAILURE ON
FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH. HIS WARM
AND HUMOROUS SPIRIT WILL BE
MISSED BY MANY INCLUDING FAMILY
FRIENDS AND HIS STUDENTS HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN AND
THEIR SPOUSES LINDA BETH JANET
AND BOB AS WELL AS HIS GRAND.
CHILDREN CREDIT ABIGAIL. TODAY
I ISE WITH GREAT SADNESS TO
CLOSE. IN A TURN IN THE MEMORY
OF TOTAL SCHOOL A CLOSE FRIEND
OF MINE AND A WONDERFUL MAN WHO
CARED VERY MUCH FOR THE CITY OF
BALDWIN PARK HE WAS A PROUD
VETERAN WHO IS HIGHLY INVOLVED
IN SISTER CITIES. AND MANY
OTHER LOCAL PROGRAMS. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO HE RECEIVED THE
OLDER AMERICAN A WAR FOR THE
SENIOR OF THE YEAR NOMINATED BY
THE CITY OF BALDWIN PARK. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE TO TRAVEL TO
MEXICO WITH MISTER AUTO SCHOOL
AS WE BOTH PARTICIPATED. IN
SISTER CITIES FOR MANY YEARS
TOGETHER WE WORKED ON PROJECTS
ACROSS THE BORDER TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN HAD PROPER
SCHOOLS. AND WHAT THEY NEEDED
FOR A GOOD EDUCATION HE AND HIS
PARTNERS BUT ON SATURDAY THAT
DID SO MUCH TOGETHER FOR OUR
COMMUNITY HE WILL BE. EXTREMIST
COLLEAGUES THIS IS JUST A FEW
MEMORIES OF PEOPLE WHO PASSED.
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE AND
THEY'RE MEANT MEMORY. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO PLEASE BRING
THOSE NAMES FORWARD SO THAT
THEY CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR UMBERG.
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IS WITH
TREMENDOUS SADNESS AND GREAT
PRIDE THAT I RISE TODAY TO
HONOR THE LIFE OF CARRION RICE.
HE WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FROM A
YOUNG AGE SHE WAS TAUGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMPASSION AND
SERVICE TO OTHERS FIRE
GRANDMOTHER. IDA ALICE RICE
TOGETHER WITH THEIR GRANDMOTHER
IDA AND HER SISTER TINA THE
TRIO WOULD VISIT LOCAL NURSING
HOMES TO DELIVER SMALL GIFTS TO
THE RESIDENCE. AT ONE POINT
KERRY MOVED TO THE CITY OF
MISSOULA TO STUDY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF MONTANA- SHE ALSO
WORKED ON CARE TAKING AND CASE
MANAGEMENT FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
MENTALLY DISABLED. ULTIMATELY
CARRY WOULD RETURN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WORK FOR THEIR
SISTER TO CREATE THE HEART OF
ITEM ALONG BEACH BASED
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION NAMED
AFTER HER GRANDMOTHER. THIS
ORGANIZATION WAS FOUNDED WITH
THE PURPOSE TO HELP OLDER
ADULTS RETAIN THEIR
INDEPENDENCE THROUGH AGING.
THROUGH OUR WORK WITH HEART OF
IDA KERRY. HELP COUNTLESS OLDER
THE OLD RETAINER IN. AND OFFER
NUMEROUS SUPPORTERS. IN THE
DAILY LIVES. ON EE KERRY'S
KINDNESS AND SPIRIT WILL CARRY
ON THROUGH OUR WONDERFUL SISTER
DINA. AND HER HUSBAND ERIC HER
KNEES CANNOT HER MOTHER CONNIE
IN THE COUNTLESS PEOPLE SHE
HELPED IN LIFE. COLLEAGUES I
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME IN
RECOGNIZE THE LIFE OF KERRY AND
RICE. MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IT'S TREMENDOUS
SADNESS THAT I RISE. TO HONOR
THE LIFE AND SERVICE OF CAPTAIN
PAUL JACOBS WHO ULTIMATELY AN
UNTIMELY PASSING THIS DECEMBER
IT SAID THE SAW CAPTAIN JACOBS
WAS BORN ON OCTOBER SEVEN
NINETEEN THIRTY SIX. AND MUCH
OF HIS ADOLESCENCE WAS SPENT IN
COASTAL COMMUNITY IN MAINE.
DURING HIS TIME THERE YOU LEARN
THE SKILLS OF SELF RELIANCE
DISCIPLINE AND RESPONSIBILITY
TOOLS THAT WOULD SERVE HIM FOR
THE REST OF HIS LIFE. HE BEGAN
HIS CAREER AS A MARINE ENGINEER
AT THE MAINE MARITIME ACADEMY
WILL GO ON TO RECEIVE HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AT THE NAVAL
POSTGRADUATE SCHOOL IN MONTEREY
CALIFORNIA. EMPOWER THROUGH
SCHOOL AND SERVICE CAPTAIN
JACOBS WOULD EVENTUALLY BECOME
A COMMANDING OFFICER OF THE USS
THE STEAM. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN. RESPONSIBILITY THAT HE
WOULD CARRY THROUGH TWO TOURS
IN VIETNAM. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE NEAR THE CONCLUSION OF THE
VIETNAM WAR CAPTAIN JACOBS
WOULD BE CHARGED WITH THE
UNEXPECTED RESPONSIBILITY AT
EVACUATING U. S. PERSONNEL IN
SOUTH VIETNAMESE REFUGEES FROM
THE COUNTRY. AS THE GOVERNMENT
OF SOUTH VIETNAM FELL CAPTAIN
JAKE WAS MADE AS PRIORITY TO
ENSURE THE SAFE PASSES MANY
ADULT CHILD REFUGEES. S.
HELICOPTERS WOULD CARRY HIS
HEROIC ACTIONS OF MORE THAN
THIRTY THOUSAND REFUGEES FIND
SAFETY IN THE UNITED STATES. AN
ACTIVE SERVICE THAT WOULD
FOREVER IN WHICH OUR COUNTRY
AND OUR COMMUNITY CAPTAIN PAUL
JACOBS WILL FOREVER BE
REMEMBERED IN HISTORY FOR
SERVICE. HE ALSO BE DEARLY
MISSED BY HIS DAUGHTER CATHY
HIS SONS SKIP MARC AND TYLER.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING. IN
MEMORY FOR. MADAM PRESIDENT
BECAUSE- I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MORE TO HONOR THE LIFE OF THE
DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVICE AND
LOVING FATHER LIEUTENANT JOHN
REYNOLDS OF THE GARDEN GROVE
POLICE DEPARTMENT. THE TEN
REYNOLDS WAS A DECORATED POLICE
OFFICER AN ACTIVE COMMUNITY
MEMBER WHO PASSED AWAY THIS
PAST JANUARY. AFTER CONTRACTING
PULL THE NINETEEN WHILE ON DUTY
AS A FIRST RESPONDER. HE WAS A
PROUD PRODUCT OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND GRADUATED.
WITH A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN CAREER AND TECHNICAL
STUDIES FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAN BERNARDINO. IT
ALSO GOING TO RECEIVE HIS
MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION FROM NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY. WITH A REYNOLDS HAD
A PASSION FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT HE SERVED AS
PRESIDENT. AND ON THE BOARD OF
THE DIRECTORS DIRECTORS FOR THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF GARDEN
GROVE AND ACTIVELY. VOLUNTEERED
FOR THE QANTAS CLUB OF GREATER.
TURN GIRLS. DURING HIS DECADES
OF PUBLIC SERVICE LIEUTENANT
REYNOLDS WAS RECOGNIZE ACCOUNT
WAS PUBLIC AWARDS INCLUDING
OFFICER THE YEAR. THE GARDEN
GROVE MIDDLE AMERICA THE
MANAGER WERE GIVEN BY THE
GARDEN GROVE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. HIS DEVOTION AND
SERVICE TO THE BETTERMENT. OF
OUR COMMUNITY HAS BEEN SORELY
MISSED. SO SORELY. A MY DEEP
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE. JENNA
IN HIS THREE CHILDREN THANK YOU
FOR JOINING ME IN RECOGNIZING
LIEUTENANT REYNOLDS. COLLEAGUES
IT IS WITH TREMENDOUS SADNESS
THAT ARISE BEFORE YOUR REMARKS.
ON THE LIFE OF RON DOMINGUEZ
RON WAS BORN IN AUGUST NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE LIVED IN ORANGE
COUNTY WAS STILL MOSTLY ORANGE
GROVES LANDED HIS FAMILY LIVED
ON WAS PURCHASED BY WALT DISNEY
FOR THEME PARK IN NINETEEN
FIFTY FOUR. HE ATTENDED ANAHEIM
HIGH SCHOOL AND RECEIVED A
DEGREE IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA. RON
NEVER LOSSES INVOLVEMENT WITH
ANAHEIM IN OUR COMMUNITY IN THE
WALT DISNEY COMPANY HE WAS
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS MR
DISNEYLAND. HE WORKED AT THE
PARK FROM AS TEENAGERS TO HIS
RETIREMENT HIS CAREER STARTED
AS A TICKET TAKER. DURING THE
SUMMER AND WOULD LEAD HIM TO
BECOME THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT OF WALT DISNEY
ATTRACTIONS WEST IN NINETEEN
NINETY. RON WAS A DOWN TO EARTH
PERSON WHO VIEWED INTERACTING
WITH PARK STAFF IS FAVORITE
PART OF HIS WORK. RON WILL BE
GREATLY MISSED BY HIS FAMILY
INCLUDING HIS WIFE OF FORTY ONE
YEARS BETTY WE MET AT
DISNEYLAND. THIS THREE CHILDREN
CHERYL STEVE AND RONALD. HIS
FOUR GRANDCHILDREN JODY TIM
CHASE CAN READ AND HIS BROTHER
PAUL. RON WAS A DEAR FRIEND
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES FOR
JOINING ME IN RECOGNIZING HIS
LIFE. COLLEAGUES MENTOR PRESENT
TODAY I JOURNAL SO WE JOURNAL
MEMORY OF A DEVOTED COMMUNITY
LEADER IN CALIFORNIA RESIDENT.
COMING SHEA. HE WAS BORN IN
NANTOU TAIWAN IN NINETEEN FORTY
NINE AND IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY BEFORE SETTLING IN
DAVIS CALIFORNIA WITH HIS
FAMILY. HE OPENED HIS OWN
RESTAURANT NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE CALLED ORANGE SHOT WHICH
IS ONE OF THE FIRST CHINESE
RESTAURANTS IN TOWN. AND A
POPULAR SPOT FOR UNIVERSITY
FACULTY AND STUDENTS. IS
OFFICIALLY KNOWN AS OLD TOM TO
MANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF THIS FRIENDLY
PRESENCE AND CONSTANT
ENTHUSIASM. TOM WAS A LICENSED
REAL ESTATE AGENT AND OWNED AND
MANAGED SEVERAL DAYS LOCATIONS.
WAS DEEPLY. INTERTWINED WITH
THIS COMMUNITY. HE WAS A GREAT
SUPPORT TO THE DAVIS CHINESE
CHRISTIAN CHURCH IN GREATER
SACRAMENTO TAIWANESE
ASSOCIATION. AND WAS DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS. HE IS GREATLY
MISSED AND LOVED BY HIS FAMILY
INCLUDING HIS WIFE KIM SIBLINGS
DENNIS BERNICE AND MATT. THIS
CHILDREN ANY OF FRIEND OF MINE
AND CLASSMATE OF MY DAUGHTER
SEAN IN LYNN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN LAYLA. A FRIEND
OF MY GRANDDAUGHTERS. JADEN AND
ALIAH. THANK. YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING HIS LIFE. MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND COLLEAGUES TODAY
SO WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
MICHAEL BEEN BOND TRON. THE
LOVE COMMITTEE MEMBER FROM THE
CITY OF WESTMINSTER. MISTER
TRAN WAS BORN IN VIETNAM IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IN. HONG
NINE. VILLAGE PROVINCE OF QUANG
TREE. BEFORE ARRIVING IN A
STATES MR TRON SERVED AS CHIEF
OF POLICE IN THE CITY OF.
BYLOCK HE WOULD SPEND THE
ENTIRE FIRST HALF HIS LIFE IN
THIS AREA WITH HIS WIFE AND
FIVE CHILDREN BEFORE BEING
APPROVED BY THE COMMUNIST
TAKEOVER OF VIETNAM. DESPITE
HIS ATTEMPTS TO FIND REFUGE IN
SOUTH VIETNAM'S TRAN WAS
ULTIMATELY CAPTURED BY
COMMUNIST POLICE OFFICERS AND
FORCED INTO A RE EDUCATION
CAMP. MICHAEL TRON WOULD
FINALLY FIND SAFE PASSAGE OUT
OF VIETNAM IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE ULTIMATELY FINDING REFUGE
WITH HIS FAMILY. AND FORTY
OTHER FAMILIES BY LIVING ON A
FISHING BOAT FOR THREE WEEKS TO
FIND PASSAGE TO THE
PHILIPPINES. NINETEEN EIGHTY
MISTER TRAN THIS FAMILY FOUND
SAFE UNITED STATES BUT WOULD
NOT BE UNTIL FOUR YEARS LATER
THEY FOUND A COMMUNITY AND A
HOME. AFTER MOVING TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. MICHAEL FOUND
INCREDIBLE LOVING COMMUNITY
WITH HIS OWN FAMILY AND WAS
ABLE TO LIVE IN THE SAME HOUSE
AS A SON ALAN TRêN AND HIS
DAUGHTER IN LAW. NON NGUYEN. IS
ALSO ABLE TO BUILD AN
INCREDIBLE CLOSE RELATION WITH
THIS GRANT FROM PETER
CHRISTOPHER AND LISA. LISA WHO
IS A MEMBER OF OUR STAFF DEEPLY
LOVED HER GRANDFATHER. BEFORE
HIS PASSING MICHAEL IRVIN
TRêN. WAS ABLE TO MEET ALL SIX
OF HIS GREAT GRAND CHILDREN A
PROFOUND LIFE ACHIEVEMENT THAT
WILL FOREVER BE CHERISHED BY
HIS FAMILY. THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR HONORING AND
RECOGNIZING THE LIFE OF MICHAEL
FLYNN TRUMP'S. MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES- I RISE
MASSIVELY JOURNAL THE MEMORY OF
LOVING FAMILY MEMBER TEACHER
MARIA VICTORIA A CHILL. MARIA
WAS BORN IN THE WAY THE ITALIAN
MITCHELL CON MEXICO ON OCTOBER
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR TO
VICTORIA A CHILL AND ONE UNTIL
A- SECOND OF SIX CHILDREN.
AFFECTIONATELY NICKNAMED. NINO
BY HER OLDER SISTER ALTHOUGH
SHE WAS RAISED IN MISSION TEXAS
WHERE SHE WORKED WITH HER
FAMILY AS FARMWORKERS. AND PART
TIME STUDENTS. UNDER EIGHTEEN
THIRTY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
NINO. WAS NATURALIZED AS A U.
S. CITIZEN SHE TEN IN MISSION
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND WENT TO PAN
AMERICAN UNIVERSITY. GRADUATE
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. WITH
THE PS IN EDUCATION. SHE
CONTINUED EDUCATION TO PURSUE A
DREAM OF BEING AN EDUCATOR AND
RECEIVED A MASTERS IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION. ALONG WITH
CERTIFICATIONS FOR BILINGUAL
ENGLISH SECOND LANGUAGE. AND
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
EDUCATION. FOR NINE YEARS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN TO TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. NINO WAS A
SPECIAL EDUCATION INSTRUCTOR.
IN ADDITION TO HER WORK AS AN
EDUCATOR SHE WAS A EUCHARISTIC
MINISTER ù TWENTY YEARS AT A
LOCAL NEIGHBORHOOD CHURCH MARIA
WAS A LIFE LONG AND VERY DEVOUT
CATHOLIC MARIA PASSED. AWAY
THIS PAST THURSDAY FEBRUARY
TWENTY FIVE SHE IS REMEMBERED
DEARLY BY HER MOTHER VICTORIA
HER SISTERS HOLDEN AND LILY
BROTHERS ONE CELL AND JERRY AND
BY ALL OUR NIECES AND NEPHEWS
INCLUDING YOUR NEPHEW DAVID.
WHO'S ALSO A FINE MEMBER OF OUR
STAFF THANK YOU MEMBERS. THANK
YOU SIR NUMBER PLEASE RING
THEIR NAMES FORWARD SO THAT WE
CAN PROPERLY ADJOURNED AND
THEIR MEMORY. CENTER BY CAL SKI.
RIGHT KELSEY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I S. THAT THE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
GENEVIEVE. ANGELINA'S GENVIEVE
WAS A FREMONT RESIDENT SHE'S
EIGHTY NINE YEARS OLD WHEN SHE
PASSED SHE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
EDUCATIONAL. TELEVISION
TEACHERS STARTING WITH OUT IN
CAPTIVITY SHE'S A LIFETIME
ACTIVIST WITH THE AC USA IS
ALSO ACTIVE WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THE FREMONT UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE AND
CONVERSATION AT THE FREMONT
LIBRARY THE CONTRA COSTA
WOMEN'S TOWNSHIP IS A MEMBER
SICK NECKLACE GREEK ORTHODOX
CHURCH IN SAN JOSE. AND AS YOU
MIGHT EXPECT THE CUTS IN THE
FORMER C. SURE FEEL ENJOY. SHE
DIED ON MAY. TENTH MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE AND ASKED THE
SENATE TO CHURN IN THE MEMORY
OF CHAOS. GAIL WAS EIGHTY YEARS
OLD WHEN SHE PASSED FOR SEVERAL
DECADES GAIL STEELE WAS A GIANT
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY POLITICS AND
GOVERNMENT. SHE WAS. CHOOSE A
LONG TIME PUBLIC SERVANT SHE
SERVED ON BOTH THE EIGHT WERE
CITY COUNCIL FOR EIGHT YEARS.
IN THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR EIGHTEEN. SHE
WAS A STRONG CONSISTENT VOICE
FOR CHILDREN AND THE POOR EACH
YEAR SHE ALSO LED THE MEMORIAL
REMEMBERING ALL THOSE WHO LOST.
HER THOSE LOST TO VIOLENCE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SHE ALSO FOUND
THAT THE EVEN YOU CENTER
INSERTED THIS AS ITS DIRECTOR.
FROM. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO
NINETEEN NINETY TWO SHE PASSED
AWAY. ON JUNE TWENTY SIX. WHEN
PRESIDENT I RISE TO A TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY O TODD
OLSON. DONNA WAS EIGHTY EIGHT
YEARS OLD WHEN SHE PASSED AWAY
ON JULY NINTH. FOR ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS DON OLSON WAS THE DRIVING
FORCE OF THE TRI CITY COLLEGES
CENTER AN ORGANIZATION SHE
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE. THE ECOLOGY CENTER OPENED
A RECYCLING CENTER THAT YEAR
AND IN THE NEARLY HALF CENTURY.
SINCE HAS CONTINUALLY WORKED ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES IN
SOUTHERN ALAMEDA COUNTY I WAS
PROUD TO ALL. TO HONOR THE
ECOLOGY CENTER IS A TEN SENATE
DISTRICTS NONPROFIT OF THE YEAR
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. DONNA SAID
THAT THIS AT THE CENTER OF ALL
THE SUCCESSES OF THE ECOLOGY
CENTER. HAS A CHEAT FROM
HELPING TO EXPAND THE DON
EDWARDS SAN FRANCISCO BAY
NATIONAL WILDLIFE REFUGE AND
PROTECTING WETLANDS TO
ADVOCATING FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPROVEMENTS. SHE WAS THE ONE
CONSTANT WHO DROVE THE
ORGANIZATIONS EFFORT FORWARD
FREMONT'S HILLSIDE IS PRESERVED
TODAY BECAUSE OF THE ECOLOGY
CENTER'S SPEARHEADING OF THE
SUCCESSFUL NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE.
FREMONT HILL INITIATIVE
DAUGHTER WILL. BE MISSED BY THE
COMMUNITY. MATTER PRESIDENT I
RISE TO ASK THE SENATE TO JUROR
IN THE MAY OF. THE END OF ROOM
E. DELLA MARRIED THE LOVE FOR
LIFE RICHARD IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN AFTER MOVING TO FREMONT.
CALIFORNIA NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT
THE OTHER BEGIN WORKING FOR
KAISER IS A RADIOLOGY
TECHNOLOGIST SHE WORKED AT
KAISER FOR TWENTY NINE YEARS
UNTIL SHE RETIRED. DANIEL LOVE
TO TRAVEL AND SPEND TIME WITH
HER FAMILY BETTER FAMILY SPEECH
CAP AND SHE WOULD ALWAYS TELL
ME ABOUT THAT. SHE WAS INVOLVED
IN MANY PHILANTHROPIC
ACTIVITIES THIS IS WHERE WE
FELT HER IMPACT. THROUGHOUT HER
LIFE SHE- HAS MADE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE CRAIG.
HOSPITAL IN ENGLEWOOD COLORADO
MISTER MONEY ESTABLISHED THE
RICHARD REMINDING MORRELL FUN
TO DRESS DIRECT PATIENT NEEDS
NOT COVERED BY INSURANCE.
LOCALLY THE END OF FUNDED THE
RENOVATION OF THE IRVINGTON
HIGH SCHOOL SOFTBALL FIELD IN
FREMONT IS THAT HER HUSBAND'S.
MEMORY ALSO SHE STEP WAS THE
DENOUEMENT THE MATH PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDED LOW ACHIEVING
STUDENTS EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
THAT ALLOW THEM TO.%
ACADEMICALLY EX EXCEL SHE
PASSED AWAY ON SEPTEMBER
NINETEENTH. I RISE TODAY IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IN THE
MEMORY OF FED UP ON A LEAD T.
WHO WAS FORTY THREE YEARS OLD
AND HER SON MOHAMMED PARMELEE
TEA WHO WAS FIFTEEN. OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE AUTISM
COMMUNITY NATIONALLY LUSTED
TRULY COURAGEOUS WOMAN WHEN FED
UP I'M A LEADING ANDERSON
MOHAMMED WERE KILLED IN THE
TRAGIC HOUSE FIRE BUT IN. IN
SEPTEMBER FEATHER SERVED AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF SEVERE AUTISM AND
WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
FREMONT SPECIAL EDUCATION TASK
FORCE AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
DISTRICT ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
SHE WAS A RELENTLESS ADVOCATE
FOR DISABILITY RIGHTS AN
INSPIRED INSPIRED OTHERS
THROUGH HER PASSION AND HER
COMMITMENT TO FAMILIES IN
AUTISTIC CHILDREN MOST OF ALL
SHE WAS A LOVING MOTHER AND
DEMONSTRATED HER. UNCONDITIONAL
LOVE TO THE VERY END FEATHER
AND MUHAMMAD PASSED AWAY. ON
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SIX. MAN
PRESIDENT IS WITH GREAT THAT I
RISE TO CHURN IN THE MEMORY OF
DON TELLEMENT. DEL DON WAS A
HUNDRED AND FIVE YEARS OLD WHEN
HE PASSED. IN HE WAS A SANTA
CLARA RESIDENT WHO BROUGHT
SCORES OF RECORDS INCLUDING
FIVE AGE GROUP WORLD RECORDS AT
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SENIOR
OLYMPICS WHEN HE COMPETED AT
THE AGE OF ONE HUNDRED. HE WON
THE HUNDRED METERS HIGH JUMP
LONG JUMP DISCUS AND SHOT PUT
DESPITE THE HIGH TEMPERATURES
ON THAT DAY HE WAS ONE OF THE
OLDEST ATHLETES EVER FEATURED
IN SPORTS ILLUSTRATED. HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN TRACK AND
FIELD WHAT COVERED BY OTHER
NATIONAL MEDIA'S TO MR PERLMAN
WAS ON THE TRACK TEAM FELL
ACROSS STATE TEACHERS COLLEGE
BEFORE HE HAD TO LEAVE THE TEAM
DURING THE DEPRESSION. TO FIND
A JOB HE DIED ON OCTOBER
ELEVENTH AFTER FALLING. AFTER
FAILING HEALTH FOLLOWING HIS
HIP SURGERY. HE WILL BE DEARLY
MISS. MADAM PRESIDENT I ASKED
THAT THE CASE STATE SENATE
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
RICKY RICARDO. RICKY WAS THE
OWNER OF RICKY SPORTS THEATRE
AND GRILL A LEGENDARY SPORTS
BAR IN SAN LEANDRO. MISTER
RICARDO TURNED HIS FATHER'S PUB
INTO A HAVEN FOR EAST BAY
SPORTS FANS ESPECIALLY RAIDERS
READER NATION HIS FATHER OPEN
THE DOORS TO NINETEEN FORTY
SIX. EVERYBODY KEPT GOING FOR
FOUR DECADES GENERATIONS OF
FANS OF THE OAKLAND A.'S GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS AND THE RAIDERS
CHEERED ON THEIR TEAMS WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. DURING THE
READER'S GLORY YEARS AND IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVERAL
PLAYERS FREQUENTLY VISITED THE
SPORTS PARK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE SPORTS ILLUSTRATED NAMED
RICKY'S THE SECOND BEST SPORTS
BAR IN AMERICA. MISTER RICARDO
WAS ALSO A VIETNAM VETERAN
VETERANS ANY PASSED AWAY. ON
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH. I RISE
TODAY NASA SENATE TO CHURN IN
THE MEMORY OF A LANE MARGARET
LEVINE WHO'S NINETY ONE COULD
SHE PASS. ELAINE WAS THE
FOUNDING EDITOR AND PUBLISHER
OF THE MIL PAETUS POST AND
LATER A GROUP OF COMMUNITY
WEEKLY MAGAZINE MAGAZINES
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH. IN BAY
AREA MISS LEVINE WAS ALSO
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE FOUNDING OF
THE MIL PAETUS HISTORIC SOCIETY
WHICH SHE WAS AN AVID GARDENER
AND ACTIVE IN THE MASTER
GARDENERS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. SHE PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH. MADAM
PRESIDENT I ASKED HIM TO SEND
THE CHILDREN IN THE MEMORY OF
EILEEN WEINRIB. I LEAN WAS THE
FIRST ELECTED WOMAN MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF HAYWARD. I LEAN ONE
RIB GOT HER START OBSERVING
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS FOR THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS AFTER
WATCHING SEVERAL COUNCIL
MEETINGS SHE THOUGHT TO
HERSELF. I CAN DO THIS SHE WAS
ELECTED TO THE COUNCIL IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT AND
ELECTED MAYOR IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR SHE SERVED TWO
TERMS WAS A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SHE HELPED
LAUNCH EATEN HOUSING IT WAS A
LONGTIME MEMBER OF. ITS BOARD
EVENING WHY REPLACE AN OF HER.
MISS WEINREB WAS MEMBER OF
TEMPLE BETH SHALOM IN FAT SAN
LEANDRO FOR OVER SIXTY YEARS
WHEN SHE PASSED AWAY ON
NOVEMBER TWENTY SECOND. AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY NINE SHE. WAS A
TRUE TRAILBLAZER. MADAM PRESS I
AM THAT THIS JOE. IN THE MEMORY
OF ANTHONY TONY ROACH A JUNIOR.
TONY DEDICATED THIRTY YEARS
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY FIRE
DEPARTMENT HE WAS A LONGTIME
RESIDENT OF HAYWARD CASTRO
VALLEY IN THE LATE NINETEEN
FIFTIES HE WAS DRAFTED AND
SERVED OVERSEAS ON A MEDICAL
TEAM IN THE UNITED STATES ARMY.
INTERESTING TONY WAS STATIONED
IN WEST GERMANY WITH ELVIS
PRESLEY HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE
TRANSFER FIGURATION CATHOLIC
CHURCH IN CASTRO VALLEY HE
LOVED TO PLAY SANTA CLAUS AT
START SCOUTING PARTIES IT WAS A
SCOUT LEADER- TONY LOVES. TO
ATTEND HOLY GHOST FESTAS AND
SHARED THE LOVE OF HIS FAMILY'S
PORTUGUESE HERITAGE HE WAS THE
FATHER OF FOUR WITH CAPS WITH
HIS WIFE KATHLEEN A FIFTY FIVE
YEARS INCLUDING FORMER. COUNTY
FIRE CHIEF DAVE ROCA HE PASSED
AWAY ON SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH.
THE MAN OF PRESIDENT I ASKED
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE ADJOURNED
IN THE MEMORY OF LIVING- BY A-
MISS BY A WAS A UNION CITY
RESIDENT FROM THE MOTHER OF
COUNTY SUPERVISOR RICHARD FIGHT-
A LIVIA VIçT WAS THE FIRST
UNION CITY CROSSING GUARDS.
HIRED BY THE CITY OF A CITY OF
UNION CITY'S POLICE DEPARTMENT
SHE WAS ALSO A CHARTER MEMBER
OF THE AMERICAN GI FORUM.
BOLIVIA LOVE THE OUTDOORS
ENJOYED PLAYING SOFTBALL OR SHE
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY
TWENTIETH. TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU CENTER BY CAL SKI
PLEASE BRING THEIR NAMES
FORWARD SAY CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR WIENER. AT.
YES. WHEN I LEFT. SENATOR
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF TOM
TAYLOR A LONGTIME AND HIGHLY
RESPECTED LEADER IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S ON START
CONSIDERING. START START. THANK.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I RISE
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF TOM TAYLOR A LONGTIME
HIGHLY RESPECTED LEADERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S LGBTQ COMMUNITY TOM
WAS A LONG TERM HIV SURVIVOR
WHO WAS TOLD TO PREPARE FOR HIS
OWN DEATH IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. BUT IN A VERY TOM WAY HE
SAID NO THANK YOU AND INSTEAD
OF DYING HE LIVES IN FOR
ANOTHER THIRTY SEVEN YEARS- AND
HE THRIVED. FOR THOSE THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS TOM WAS TRULY A
REPRESENTATION OF HOW TO LIVE
LIFE TO ITS FULLEST HE WAS
KNOWN MOST BROADLY FOR HIS
EXTRAVAGANT ALONG WITH HIS
HUSBAND TOM FOR HIS EXTRAVAGANT
CHRISTMAS DECORATIONS WITH
LIGHTS AND ORNAMENTS ADORNING
THE OUTSIDE IS BEAUTIFUL HOME
AND ICONIC. SIXTY FIVE FOOT
TALL CHRISTMAS TREE EVERY YEAR.
BUT A GREAT SING TO THE
COMMUNITY TOM WAS THE STEWARD
IN THE CARETAKER OF THE
ORIGINAL RAINBOW FLAGS AT
HARVEY MILK PLAZA. AND CREATED
THE DIVERSITY FOUNDATION IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO MAINTAIN THE FLAG.
AND TO UPHOLD WHATEVER
REPRESENTS. A THIS FLAG IS NOW
IN MANY WAYS THE FACE IN THE
SYMBOL. FOR OUR LGBTQ PRIDE
MOVEMENT THROUGHOUT HE WORLD.
ANTON'S DEEP COMMITMENT TO THE
FLAG WHAT IT STOOD FOR WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN. TOM WAS A
KIND SELFLESS AND GENEROUS
HUMAN BEING. WHO IS ALWAYS
THERE FOR THE REST OF US NO
MATTER WHAT WE NEEDED. TOM WAS
TRULY CASTRO ROYALTY AND FOR
DECADES HE CARED FOR AND
UPLIFTED OUR BEAUTIFUL
COMMUNITY. I KNEW TOM WELL- AND
I CAN SPEAK FOR SO MANY IN MY
COMMUNITY WHEN I SAY TOM. WE
LOVE YOU AND WE MISS YOU. HI
TOM HAS AWAY- HIS- HOME- ON
OCTOBER TWENTIETH OF THIS PAST
YEAR IS SURVIVED BY HIS HUSBAND
JERRY- HIS BROTHERS DWIGHT AND
MARTIN. AND HIS SISTERS LEE
ADAM BARBARA- TOM- REST IN
PEACE AND JERRY WE LOVE YOU TO
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN
TOM'S MEMORY. MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO IN MEMORY- OF
EACH- RIGHTS ON. A PARTY'S
ADDITION WAS BORN IN THAILAND
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN. AND
CAME TO SAN FRANCISCO TO LIVE
WITH HIS ELDEST DAUGHTER. ABI
SAYS BROTHER DESCRIBED HIM AS
SERIOUS AND STUDIOUS ALWAYS
YEARNING FOR THE WORLD BEYOND
THEIR FAMILY'S FARM FOR HIM.
AND FOR HIS CHILDREN. HE
STUDIED- TAMAZIGHT UNIVERSITY
IN BANGKOK ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S
MOST PRESTIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS I
MADE ACAREER ONE OF THAILAND'S
LARGEST BANKS. HE WAS A DEVOTED
BUDDHISTS ANTICLINES GENTLE
NEARLY. BLIND EIGHTY FOUR YEAR
OLD MAN. HE WAS A SAW AND
SEVERANCE AND KILLED ON JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST WHILE TAKING HIS
MORNING WALK. FOR THE SOLE
REASON- BUT HE WAS ASIAN.
OFFICER WAS KILLED LAST MONTH
IN A HATE CRIME PART OF THE
TRAGIC AND DESPICABLE RISE IN
ANTI ASIAN ATTACKS THAT WE'VE
SEEN. DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THE
CHAU SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER
HIS DAUGHTERS AND
GRANDCHILDREN. ALTHOUGH HE
LIVED FOR EIGHTY FOUR YEARS SHE
WAS TAKEN FROM THIS WORLD FAR
TOO SOON PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING TODAY. IN HIS MEMORY.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
TURN IN MEMORY OF SEWING ON
NORDSTROM. BORN IN HOLLYWOOD IN
NINETEEN THIRTY THREE TO A
SINGLE MOTHER I WAS- AND WORKED
FROM THE AGE OF THIRTEEN TO
SUPPORT HER FAMILY. HIGHS
AROUND CAME TO SAN FRANCISCO-%
WHERE SHE MADE A CAREER FOR
HERSELF AT CITY COLLEGE OF SAN
FRANCISCO. WHERE SHE ULTIMATELY
BECAME THE CHAIR OF THE
SCHOOL'S CHILD DEVELOPMENT
CENTER. PROVIDING CARE FOR
CHILDREN AND EDUCATION FOR
PARENTS SETTLING BROWN PARKS-
GRANT PARK IS IN SAN FRANCISCO
SOUTH OF NO VALLEY. NAZARIAN
BECAME AN OUTSPOKEN MEMBER OF
HER COMMUNITY IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE SO AND- HELPED FOUND THE
ST OAKLAND PARK COMMITTEE- IN
ORDER TO STOP THE FREEWAY FROM
BEING BUILT. THROUGH THE MIDDLE
OF A NEIGHBORHOOD OR SORT OF
DESTROY THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF KLEIN CAN
IMPART CLIFFORD DESTROYED GOING
CANYON. EYES AROUND HER
COALITION BECAME KNOWN AS THE
GUM TREES GIRLS- DUE TO THE
HIGH DENSITY OF GUM TREES IN
THE AREA WHERE THE FREEWAY WAS
SLATED TO DESTROY. THE COUNTRY
GIRLS ULTIMATELY STOPPED THIS
FREEWAY IN ITS TRACKS. ON
MAINTAINING ONE OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S MOST BEAUTIFUL AN
ECLECTIC COMMUNITIES THIS IS
PART OF THE SAN FRANCISCO.
FREEWAY REVOLTS. STOP A PLANT
BASICALLY TEAR UP THE CITY.
WITH FREEWAYS AROUND PER OF A
PARK ASSOCIATE. FROM NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND TWO. AND
ADVOCATED FOR DECADES FOR HER
COMMUNITY. DURAN WAS AN ART
LOVER AND CREATOR SURE THE
GIANTS SEASON TICKET HOLDER.
HIGHS AROUND DIETING COVE IN
NINETEEN ON FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH
THE AGE OF EIGHTY SEVEN. THAT
IS SURVIVED BY HER SONS
RAYMOND'S THOMAS AND MARCUS AS
WELL AS HER THREE GRANDCHILDREN
REST IN PEACE AROUND. MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO HOUSE
OF THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF FOUR K. SENSORS.
JORGE WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY IN BOGOTA COLOMBIA AND
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO THE L. G.
B. T. TO SPANISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITY. JORGE EARNED HIS
DEGREE IN ANTHROPOLOGY AT UC
BERKELEY AND SETTLED IN SAN
FRANCISCO. HE SPENT DECADES
CREATING AWARENESS. ABOUT SELF
CARE AMID THE HIV CRISIS. LIKE
THE STORIES AND HELPING FOSTER-
ACCEPTANCE AMONG IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES FOR THEIR QUEER
CHILDREN. WHERE HE WORKED WITH
COUNTLESS ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORTING LGBTQ YOUTH AND
PROMOTING FAMILY UNITY OR HER
CO FOUNDED THE PUBLIC OUR GROUP
BECAUSE COLLECTIVE WHICH
CREATES WORKS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF EDUCATING THE PUBLIC AND
PROMPTING HEALTHY DISCOURSE ON
SERIOUS ISSUES. JORGE ALSO THAT
ARE YOU KNOW US SAN FRANCISCO
BASED SUPPORT GROUP FOR GAY AND
BISEXUAL- LATINOS ARE FOR HER
TOOK JOY IN THE PLEASURES OF
LIFE HE LOVED ART CANOEING AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY LOVE
CONNECTING. WITH PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF CULTURAL BARRIERS
JORGE BROUGHT PEOPLE TOGETHER
IN WAYS THAT MADE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE I WAS THE PERSON
THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE INSPIRED
BY. HER HEAD PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER ELEVENTH THIS YEAR- AT
THE AGE OF FIFTY HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS PARTNER MIGUEL HIS
MOTHER EUNICE AND THE SIBLINGS
AND IT AND IN REJECT- BODY EVER
BRCKO AND CARMEN. PLEASE JOIN
ME TODAY IN THE TURNING IN
MEMORY. OF HER HIS SON SAYS.
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
ASK THE SAN RETURNS IN MEMORY
OF LAWRENCE FERLINGHETTI. ONE
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S STRONGEST
VOICES AND ADVOCATES FOR SOCIAL
EQUITY IN THE ARTS ARE TRUE
ICONS- LAWRENCE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY IN NEW YORK BUT
WAS RAISED IN FRANCE BY IS AN-
ORGAN LEARN TO SPEAK FRENCH
BEFORE LEARNING ENGLISH. HE
SERVED IN THE NAVY IN WORLD WAR
TWO AND EVENTUALLY SETTLED IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE HE OPENED
THE CITY LIGHTS THE CITY LIGHTS
POCKETBOOKS SHOP IN NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE. CITY LIGHTS BECAME
KNOWN AS THE PLACE OF PUBLISHED
AND SOLD BOOKS. THAT OTHER
PUBLISHERS HAVE REFUSED
CONTROVERSIAL BOOKS THAT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FIND
ANYWHERE ELSE. IMAGE SPARKED A
VALUABLE CONVERSATION ABOUT
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AND THE
ARTS. LAWRENCE PUBLISHED MANY
ATTITUDE OF WORKS OF THE BEAT
LITERARY MOVEMENT. SUCH AS HAL
BY ALLEN GINSBERG. AND PROVIDED%
A VOICE FOR THOSE ON THE
FRINGES OF NINETEEN FIFTIES AND
SIXTIES AMERICAN SOCIETY. AS
SUCH A LAWRENCE WAS CONSIDERED
THE SPIRITUAL GODFATHER OF THE
BEAT MOVEMENT. I'M PUBLISHED
WORKS INSPIRED THE SOCIAL
REVOLUTIONS OF THE LATTER HALF
OF THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
LAWRENCE IS ALSO THE CREATOR OF
HIS OWN WORKS AND WAS
CONSIDERED A PROLIFIC WRITER OF
GENRE BENDING POETRY. AND
POLITICALLY AGITATED OF WORK.
LAWRENCE PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND OF
INTERSTITIAL LUNG DISEASE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER SON
AND THREE GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE
JOIN ME AND ADJOURNING THE.
SENATE AND MEMORY OF LAWRENCE
FERLINGHETTI. MADAM PRESIDENT
OF TODAY TO. IN MEMORY. OF TEN
JONES- GAY RIGHTS ACTIVISTS AND
VALUED MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY. BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY CANCER THREE
TOURS OF DUTY- IN THE VIETNAM
WAR HE WAS ONE OF THE EARLIEST
AFRICAN AMERICAN LEADERS OF THE
LGBTQ RIGHTS MOVEMENT. I WAS A
LONG TERM SURVIVOR OF HIV. IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES CAN HELP
TO LEAD THE LGBT COMMUNITY AND
SAN FRANCISCO MOBILIZING THE
FIGHT FOR LGBTQ RIGHTS IN THIS
COUNTRY. HE CONSTANTLY
ENCOURAGE THE MOVEMENT TO
DIVERSIFY EMPHASIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTERSECTION
ALITY THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE. CAN
WAS A CRITICAL VOLUNTEER FOR
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION ORGANIZING SOME OF
THE FIRST LARGE SCALE FUND
RAISERS FOR MEDICAL RESEARCH
FOR HIV AIDS. HE WAS THE FIRST
BLACK CHAIR OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO LGBTQ PRIDE
CELEBRATION COMMITTEE WHERE HE
LED THE ORGANIZATION I'M ONE OF
THE LARGEST GAY PRIDE FESTIVALS
IN THE WORLD. ABOVE ALL ELSE
CAN WAS A MAN FULL OF LOVE FOR
ALL PEOPLE WITH A NEVER ENDING
DRIVE FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY
HERE'S ONE OF THE KINDEST
PEOPLE I'VE EVER. THAT IS
SURVIVED BY HIS SISTER OF THE
SANDRA HENDERSON CAN WE LOVE
YOU WE MISS YOU REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HI. FIVE GO
AHEAD NO PROBLEM. SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- MEMBERS OF GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ASK THAT
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF TOM TAYLOR A LONG TIME
HIGHLY RESPECTED LEADER AND SAN
FRANCISCO'S LGBTQ COMMUNITY TOM
WAS A LONG TERM HIV SURVIVOR-
WHO WAS TOLD TO PREPAREFOR HIS
DEATH IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE.
BUT IN A VERY TOM WAY HE SAID
NO THANK YOU INSTEAD OF DYING
HE LOOKED FOR ANOTHER THIRTY
SEVEN YEARS AND THRIVED DURING
THOSE THIRTY SEVEN YEARS TOM
WAS TRULY A REPRESENTATION OF
HOW TO LIVE LIFE TO THE FULLEST
HE WAS PERHAPS BEST KNOWN BY
THE BROAD COMMUNITY- FOR THE
HOUSE THAT HE AND HIS HUSBAND
JERRY- OWN IN THE CASTRO- WITH
TRULY EXTRAVAGANT- CHRISTMAS
DECORATIONS WITH ALL SORTS OF
INFINITE LIGHTS AND ORNAMENTS
IN A SIXTY FIVE FOOT TALL
CHRISTMAS TREE. BUT PERHAPS
GREATER SIGNIFICANCE TO OUR
COMMUNITY TOM WAS THE STEWARD
AND THE CARETAKER OF THE
ORIGINAL RAINBOW FLAG AT HARVEY
MILK PLAZA A CASTRO MARKET AND
HE CREATED THE DIVERSITY
FOUNDATION OF SAN FRANCISCO TO
MAINTAIN THE FLAGS AND TO
UPHOLD WHAT IT REPRESENTS THIS
FLAG IN SO MANY WAYS IS THE
SYMBOL IN THE FACE OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND TOM'S COMMITMENT
TO THE FLAG WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. TOM WAS A CLIMB TO
SELFLESS AND GENEROUS HUMAN
BEING ALSO EXTREMELY BLIND YOU
ALWAYS KNEW WHAT WAS ON HIS
MIND BUT HE WAS ALWAYS THERE
FOR THE REST OF US TOM WAS TRUE
CASTRO ROYALTY AND FOR DECADES
HE CARED FOR AND STEWARDED THIS
COMMUNITY. I KNEW TOM WHILE HE
WAS A FRIEND I HEAR SOMEONE I
KNOW I SPEAK FOR SO MANY WHEN I
SAY TOM. WE LOVE YOU AND WE
MISS YOU. TOM PASSED AWAY IN
HIS HOME ON OCT TWO. OF TWENTY
TWENTY. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
HOUSE JERRY. HIS BROTHERS
MARTIN AND HIS SISTERS LANA
BARBARA PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN MEMORY OF TOM TAYLOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER PLEASE BRING EVERYONE'S
NAMES FORWARD SO WE CAN
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE THEM.
MEMBERS THAT COMPLETES THE
JOURNEY AND MEMORIES WE WILL
RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT NINE
AM HAVE A GREAT DAY.